this is Jocko podcast number 399 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
Jiu Jitsu is life
this statement is often made by
practitioners of the art of Jiu Jitsu
some mean it in a playful way Jiu Jitsu
is so fun and engaging that it seems to
permeate every aspect of life others
mean it in a more serious way the power
of Jiu Jitsu becomes an obsession and
every waking moment is spent trying to
learn develop and improve Jiu Jitsu
skills
but for me the statement Jiu Jitsu is
life has always been about the actual
correlations between Jiu Jitsu and life
yes the struggles trials tribulations
and triumphs that are part and parcel of
Jiu Jitsu are also reflect what we all
experience in life
I was introduced to Jujitsu in the early
90s by revered Navy SEAL Master Chief I
was a young seal at the time and I was
overseas on my first deployment
during our morning muster the master
chief asked if any of us wanted to learn
how to fight
I raised my hand and my life changed
forever a few hours later this lanky
master chief who's much older and
smaller than I was was tying me in knots
placing me in positions where I had no
other option than to tap out to
surrender
I was dumbfounded it didn't make sense
no matter what I did I could not survive
from more than 30 seconds with the
master chief I tried over and over again
doing something anything to survive but
I could not
neither could any of my fellow seal
teammates who had also joined me for the
lesson
after almost an hour the Master Chief
looked at our exhausted faces and said
welcome to Gracie Jiu Jitsu
I had no idea what that meant at the
time but it seemed like I had been
exposed to some kind of magic a magic
power that I did not understand but I
did understand one thing
I needed to learn this magic power this
power of jujitsu
the master chief whose name was Steve
Bailey had trained in the legendary
Gracie Garage in the late 80s and early
90s in Torrance California
he was no by no means a master of the
art
by his own admission he was just a
beginner
but even with the most basic Jiu Jitsu
moves he was able to completely Dominate
and easily make my teammates and me
submit over and over again
so began my Jiu Jitsu Journey
I continued to train with Master Chief
Bailey on deployment when I got back to
the States I found a jiu jitsu
instructor named Fabio Santos whose Jiu
Jitsu lineage traced directly back to
the Gracie family
I trained as often as I could sometimes
speeding to the Jiu Jitsu Academy for
lunchtime training then returning at
night for more classes I was obsessed I
learned the basic positions of Jiu Jitsu
the mount the back the guard the half
guard and side control I learned the
basic submission holds of Jiu Jitsu the
moves to actually make opponents tap out
the straight arm lock the Kimura the
Americana collar chokes the guillotine
chokes the rear naked choke and foot
ankle and knee locks
over time I learned how to fight
but I also slowly began to recognize
that Jiu Jitsu was not just a catalog of
individual moves
instead all the moves were
interconnected they worked best when
combined together in sequence to support
each other
that lesson soon led to the realization
that Jiu Jitsu was not just a
combination of moves either
but that there were underlying
principles of Jiu Jitsu that made the
entire system work
but most importantly
over time I realized that the principles
of Jiu Jitsu were not just a way of
fighting
they were a way of thinking
I saw the correlations between the
principles of Jiu Jitsu leadership
combat and life itself
I began to apply these principles to
everything I did
and the more I applied these principles
in other aspects of my life the better I
was able to execute I became a better
seal a better leader
and a better person
so that right there is an excerpt
from the forward of a book
it's a forward that I wrote for a book
which is called the 32 principles
harnessing the power of jujitsu To
Succeed in Business relationships and
life
and it's written by Henner Gracie of the
renowned Gracie family
who have had
the most significant impact on martial
arts in the modern era and I owe that
family so much
and it is an honor to have Henner here
with us tonight to talk about his life
his lessons learned and his book The 32
principles
Henner
thanks for joining us thank you guys
what a pleasure to be here after seeing
you guys do so much good work with the
podcast and everything else you guys are
doing so thank you Echo for helping pull
this one together and thank you Jocko
for that amazing forward
well it's an honor to be able to write
it and as I was telling you before
Jujitsu gave me so much in life and it's
an honor for for me to have the
opportunity to give back
and it's also kind of weird for me to
say that Jiu Jitsu gave me a lot in life
because for you I can't even imagine
what it's like growing up in your family
and and with your last name and doing
what you've been doing your whole life
and I'm very curious to hear what that
sounds like from the inside
so uh let's get to it man let's get to
it let's talk about you let's talk about
how you got here and let's start at the
beginning so
Cory and Gracie your dad son of elio
Gracie Elio Gracie the creator of Gracie
Jitsu of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
um a significant part of that is that
your grandfather Elio
was kind of a small guy and kind of a
sickly guy I don't mean to be
disparaging but he was like a frail
looking guy and he had to take what
came to Brazil
in the form of Japanese Jiu Jitsu maybe
judo-ish
what came in that form he had to take
that and turn it into something that
worked for him
what do you think
yeah you're spot on
um so when the Gracie Brothers my father
my grandfather being the youngest one
were introduced to Jujitsu in Brazil in
the early 1900s my grandfather was
actually restricted from participating
so only his older brothers were allowed
to practice these Japanese techniques
that they had learned
and
um he suffered from vertigo dropped out
of school in the third grade convinced
his Mommy couldn't go to school so he
was a frail young man was not really
allowed to participate in any type of
physical strenuous activity so he would
watch his brother's practice jujitsu
several years passed watching his
brother's practice and teach and one day
his older brother Carlos the oldest of
all the brothers was scheduled to teach
a private class to a student and Carlos
was absent the student had showed up to
participate in the class and elyu my
grandfather had showed up to observe the
class but Carlos wasn't there so edu at
that time offered to teach the class in
his brother's absence and he's you know
16 years old give or take of the time
he says you know so would you like to go
through the class with me to the
gentleman who was an influential Banker
in Brazil and the man said of course kid
let's go he had known the kid from
watching so many classes he's always
around the mat you know little Matt rat
but not one who had practiced so my
grandfather at that time went through a
class with this student purely based on
what he had memorized from watching his
brother's practice
and they were successful by the end of
the class Carlos eventually showed up
late apologetic the student said no
worries I actually had a class with your
little brother and if you don't mind I
would like to keep taking classes with
him from now on
and the student in that moment promoted
my grandfather from nothing to being a
teacher of Jiu Jitsu so my grandfather
was thrust right into it of course love
that he was able to perform what
techniques he was able to perform but
then realized uh soon thereafter that
there were many techniques that were not
suitable for his limited physical
ability and began modifying and adapting
the techniques his brothers were
involved in this process as well but he
just dove in head first it's almost like
one of those things where because you
can't have it you want it more right
you're you're in the desert dying of
thirst the water tastes a lot better so
for him I feel like the deprivation from
not being able to participate in it made
him go gung-ho turns out he becomes the
champion of the family he starts
fighting in challenge matches as a as an
older teenager and becomes the guy of
which basically they're organizing now
Valley tudo challenge matches for my
grandfather Carlos being kind of the
manager older brother figure
coordinating these fights and then my
grandfather's out there fighting anyone
they can get their hands on to
demonstrate the efficacy of Jiu Jitsu
and like you said he was a small guy
right I guess five nine hundred and
forty pounds give or take and he's
defeating Giants with these techniques
and that's really the beginning if you
want to go all the way back that's
really the beginning of you know MMA and
valitudo and these Gracie challenge
matches in Brazil
and he was successful and and the name
became very the Gracie name my
grandfather and his brothers became very
well known in Brazil at this time fast
forward you know 20 30 years 1950s when
he fought Kimura my dad was born
um soon thereafter and now October 23
1951 I think it was when he fought
Kimura
um and I think my father was born in 52
born into this Legacy of fighting and
this is what we do everyone does Jujitsu
and my grandfather had nine children his
brother Carlos had 21 children so the
only thing we're better at than Jiu
Jitsu is reproducing and these like
rabbits everywhere like Gracie's being
born like you can't believe it and all
of them are just kind of on the mat from
day one and learning this thing
and my father grows up in that
environment of Jiu Jitsu for everyone
from day one everyone's choking each
other all the time from as early as they
can remember and then um you know he
decided to bring it to America 1978. he
landed here in Southern California and
uh everyone he met he invited for a free
class if they told their friend the
friend got a free class and the
referring person got another free class
so everyone told every friend so that
they would get all these free classes
and before you know it 1978 through 1989
uh they're in the garage and before you
know it there's not enough space right I
think there's like 130 people on a
waiting list to get into the garage
and uh throughout this entire time there
are challenge matches happening in the
garage these original Gracie challenge
matches in America where you know these
students of the garage would go out to
their professors of other disciplines
and say hey to their karate coach or
their Taekwondo or Kung Fu coach I'm
training this Jujitsu stuff in the
garage with these Gracie brothers and it
really works and you're gonna I think
you would love it and of course in their
ego and pride the instructor of the
other discipline says no I don't think
that works and in fact if they tried it
on me I would just knock them out and
then the student would go back to them
and say Hey you know to Mr Gracie this
karate teacher doesn't think it would
work and then that would go back and
forth two or three times before
eventually my dad says look if they want
to test it out they can show up whenever
they want we'll be happy to just see
what works and what doesn't
and those who happened and many of them
were recorded and they're on YouTube as
Gracie challenge matches and that was
really the precursor to the actual
creation of the UFC which was of course
my father and art Davey his partner who
were like dude if this is so powerful
the display of Jiu Jitsu in the garage
when you have these masters of other
disciplines getting strangled
unconscious or tapping out in 30 seconds
60 seconds if we're doing this in the
garage and everyone who watches this is
just absolutely enthralled by the
display of Truth and Effectiveness what
if we put this on pay-per-view
television in UFC one you know November
12 1993 and the rest is history it is
crazy to watch and those the the first
video Gracie in action I think I think
that's fully on YouTube by the way yeah
I think we should watch it fully on
YouTube but it was look you watch it now
and you go oh of course but you watch it
back then and it it was mind-blowing
mind-blowing and I I was very lucky in
that I saw I did Jiu Jitsu before I ever
saw any video of jiu jitsu before the
first UFC so I knew what was going to
happen but if you didn't know any of
that and you're watching it would be
hard to believe you know I've always
found that if someone doesn't know
anything about Jiu Jitsu they they're
three to five submissions before they
even think that this is real so like
you'll get a wrestler you know that has
never seen Jiu Jitsu before he can't
really find a wrestler like that anymore
but in the 90s you could definitely find
people that would be like oh what's this
this doesn't work be like okay
cool and you roll and you tap them and
then they're like oh let's go one more
time and you go again you tap them again
and then you they go oh let's go and it
took like three to five times before
they'd go holy crap there's something
here that I really don't understand so
yeah that must have been crazy for
people to watch in the garage in uh
Fabio Santos he had a bunch of those
videos and he was in a bunch of them too
um yeah we'd sit around and watch those
things and you could see the disbelief
in people's eyes after they got tapped
once twice three times
after they threw those devastating what
they thought were devastating punches
what they thought were devastating kicks
and the greasy Jiu Jitsu practitioner
just closes the distance takes them down
and chokes him so this was like a
this was like a revolution a true
Revolution that hasn't really I don't
know I can't think of any other sports
that have had such a dramatic change
in them as martial arts because of this
phenomenon of Gracie Jiu Jitsu it's it's
an unbelievable change in the course of
events yeah I agree and people ask like
what do you think the biggest impact was
and I think that
if I had to sum it up I would say the
Gracie family
changed the
distance from which a fight is fought
right when you talk about Hollywood and
you talk about Bruce Lee and Chuck
Norris and like the era of the 70s the
80s early 90s pre-ufc there was very
much a belief of flashy punches and
kicks from that range that striking
range and that's where men fight stand
in trade blows and you hope to get one
on them before they get one on you and
what the Gracie family kind of came and
said was no you know intelligent people
don't stand in trade blows 50 50 and
risk getting knocked out we stayed too
far where you can't hit us and then when
you think you're gonna hit us we get too
close where those hits have no more
power so we change the fundamental
distance from which a fight is fought
and it was cheating it really was
cheating because once the person who
doesn't know Jujitsu is in that close
range not only are they not effective
with the strikes that they learn from
watching television or from years of
practice right depending what their
Source was not only are they not
effective they're actually
counterproductive because there's
nothing more energy depleting than
throwing strikes that don't land that's
like one of the most exhausting things
imaginable And yet when you're in a
close range and you pull someone even if
you're on the bottom you pull someone on
top of you they're striking and not
Landing they're just pleading so fast
and then it's 30 60 seconds later we
just pick up the pieces and decide what
opportunity we want to take advantage of
and
um you know so that's to me that was the
biggest shift it changed what was
acceptable in terms to the distance what
a fight looked like
changed
um
and to me it's like when you talk about
what makes Jiu Jitsu so addicting what
makes Jiu Jitsu so powerful right like
we're in right we're sold it'll be part
of our lives for the rest of our lives
yeah there's a massive population out
there that know nothing and have no
participation and have nothing to do
with Jiu Jitsu but the people who are in
are all the way in
and when I think about why that is
I feel that
it's because the practice of jujitsu
changes
our operating system as human beings
more profoundly
and I think we would all agree in less
time
than any other activity we can think of
right and why is that because when you
practice Jujitsu there are three
distinct and Incredibly profound
psychological shifts that happen in the
practitioner
the first is how they deal with problems
the second is how they deal with other
people and the third is how they deal
with themselves how you face yourself
when you talk about how we deal with
problems
conventional wisdom says
if two people get into a fight and the
fight goes to the ground the person who
is on the bottom
is losing the fight
right
but in Jiu Jitsu not only is that not
true
in many cases the opposite is true
if you were to send someone down the
street to the nearest bar and find the
meanest baddest beard you could find 300
pounder drag them over here
put any one of us on our back
and put him on top of us
and then let the world take a survey and
say who's winning everyone who doesn't
do Jiu Jitsu and doesn't know of our
skill sets would say that guys the beard
is winning that guy's losing it's
automatic that that would be the
assessment and the conclusion the world
would come to
but we know
that the moment that guy lays on top of
us his life is in danger
that's crazy and a matter of 30 to 60
seconds he's tapping out with any number
of choices that we make from underneath
him to end his life or to you know
dislocate a joint if we go all the way
with it but we wouldn't because we're
compassionate human beings
so with Jiu Jitsu we often hear this
saying
and why we love it so much it teaches us
to be comfortable in uncomfortable
positions right it's a very common one
but I think it's much bigger than that
and much more powerful Jujitsu teaches
us to win
in worst case scenarios
so what the world perceives as
unwinnable worst case scenarios we look
at as absolutely winnable situations
that we can optimize to our advantage so
that affects the practitioner in a very
profound way the second one is how we
deal with other people
right and when you talk about
kind of The evolutionary way of things
and you look at members of a species
a larger stronger member of a species
will consistently defeat a smaller
weaker member of the same species right
the larger Silverback defeats the
smaller Silverback for a mate or for
territory the larger squirrel defeats
the smaller weaker squirrel for the nut
but humans are unique in their ability
to kind of go against the natural order
of things and learn skills
and process information that will give
them a
strikingly consistent Effectiveness
against members of their own species who
are larger and stronger than them
and Jujitsu is the fastest way for a
person to accomplish that
such that if two people saw if people
the world saw us standing side by side
with the with the monster beard that we
recruited and stood us next to that
person they would go oh man the same way
we looked at hoyson UFC one what did you
feel poor hoists
but if you were in the family what did
you feel poor Taekwondo guys poor art
Jimerson poor Gerard Gordo because he
simply doesn't have the resources to
deal with the techniques that we will
bring to the equation and the fact that
humans can do that we can learn and
violate the natural Order of Things
once you tap into that you're on the
inside and you don't leave because it's
too rewarding and it's too special and
it changes the way you deal with
adversity in every aspect of your life
and then the third one is how you
face yourself
right 99.9 percent conservative estimate
of the world has never tried a Jujitsu
class
because they don't feel capable
I'm too old I'm too young I'm too old
I'm too I'm Too Tall I'm too short I'm
too fat I'm too skinny you name it
they've used it as an excuse not to do
Jujitsu even though they've heard you
about it Ad nauseam over so many
podcasts right like they hear about it
but they're still I'm not good enough
now what's crazy is for the lucky few
who take your advice and Venture onto
the mat
not only do they realize that their
initial fears were almost entirely
unfounded
but they realize that their body is so
much more capable than they ever
imagined you unlock your secret
potentials when you do Jujitsu and the
best analogy I've come up with and there
may be others but it's a Swiss army
knife imagine if everyone was equipped
with a Swiss Army knife
99.9 of the world is only using the
knife blade
people who do Jiu Jitsu know that there
are I looked last night what's the Swiss
army knife with the most instruments is
33 instruments so the knife plus 32
others and I'm like wow so they don't
know they got the tweezers the
magnifying glass the nail file the
Phillips head screwdriver the scissors
all these other tools you don't even
know you've had those available to you
all your life but they're right there
your body is the Swiss army knife and
when we do Jiu Jitsu the ways in which
we connect with other human beings
to increase our Effectiveness and
decrease their opportunities against us
it's it's it's in it's it's infinite and
it's amazing to tap into that so I look
at the world of people with Swiss Army
knives only relying on this blade and I
go man what a sad existence you only
lived your entire life only using the
knife function
so it makes me so happy when someone
starts suing Jujitsu and they realize
that they are to a Swiss army knife they
aren't too old they aren't too young
they aren't too fat they aren't too
skinny so for me
every single time you step on this
Jujitsu mat and you practice this
incredible art
you're reprogramming your brain
in these three significant ways number
one the problems you thought were
insurmountable
are fully surmountable and in fact
they're simply techniques waiting to be
discovered number two the people the
opponents you thought were unbeatable
are beatable and number three the body
that you have that you thought wasn't
capable is capable
and that's where the rewiring happens
every single class and then naturally
that does something to a human being and
then it changes eventually how they live
their life
initially your learning techniques every
technique you learn it's exciting
because you see a new move it's a new
solution to an old problem you're like
wow that's awesome so the addiction is
to individual techniques initially
and you learn hundreds eventually
thousands of moves but somewhere between
blue and purple belt maybe a little bit
after purple bill
a dedicated practitioner shifts
and their Obsession and their focus goes
from
technique obsession
to principles of the art
right a rather limited list a relatively
small number of principles that make all
of those thousands of techniques
possible and once you tap in and you
have a relationship with these Timeless
and Universal principles that make
everything possible in jiu jitsu
you separate from that obsession with
individual techniques and then once that
relationship with those principles is
true profound and labeled and totally
real for you then it starts to translate
into your everyday life and at that
point Jiu Jitsu isn't just a fighting
system for you anymore it's now an
operating system for your life
and that's why I chose to wrote the book
because I realize that these 32
principles were not limited to my combat
Effectiveness they were as relied upon
in my own life and as effective
entrepreneurially right from a family
perspective relationship perspective
business perspective in every aspect
they were as reliable and effective in
these Realms as they were in combat
and I thought man what if I could write
a book where
the reader doesn't have to go through
that first three four five years which
can sometimes be unforgiving right there
are times in that Journey where it just
kind of sucks where you're having to
sort it out and figure it out so how sad
that people who don't want to go through
the grind will never get to the to the
glory land of these 32 principles being
available for them as life tools so I
said what if I could write a book that
makes those principles right it kind of
distills the art down to those
principles and gives someone with no
martial arts experience the ability to
understand what they are and how they
apply personally and professionally
and then hope that after they read a
book like this we bring them in the back
door and we go hey you now love the
principal so let's go do some Jiu Jitsu
I'm just saying the last page of the
book might nudge them in that direction
yeah uh I think it's Miha the other day
one of our Jiu Jitsu training partners
he had been asked something about and he
posted a video about
um you know what's the hardest belt to
get in Jiu Jitsu and you know he had his
black belt in his hand and he's like
nope this is not the hardest belt to get
in Jiu Jitsu the hardest belt to get is
the white belt the the biggest step
you're gonna take as a human being is
actually showing up at the Jiu Jitsu
Academy with a with a soul full of
humility
and put on that white belt and step out
on the mat that's the hardest one
now what you're talking about about this
different bodies and
people we all adapt our bodies to jiu
jitsu so my Jiu Jitsu is a little bit
different than Echoes Jujitsu a little
bit different between we all we all
develop our own Jiu Jitsu and it all
works for our our size and our shape and
it's classic your grandfather he had to
focus a hundred percent on being on the
bomb not 100 but like a vast majority
being on the bottom being overpowered
being out strengthened and he had to use
these very technical Maneuvers from his
back this you know I think the guard is
the most prominent thing that that
really stands out from your grandfather
for Gracie Jiu Jitsu it's like oh you
can be on the bottom and win
you can be on the bottom anyway I mean
even Judo you can get you can get you
can get pinned you know it's a 30s it's
a long pin but you can get pinned you
can't get pinned in Jiu Jitsu if you're
down there and you're still breathing
you can keep fighting and that's a huge
difference I mean wrestling you get
pinned for for three seconds and it's
over so he had to figure that out he had
to do exactly what you said like open up
all the other tools in the Swiss army
knife to make it work and clearly
created a system where that's the
foundation of the system is no matter
who you are you're gonna learn leverage
and you're gonna learn these techniques
that are functional regardless of how
big that other person is because no
matter how big you are there's always
going to be someone bigger there's
always going to be someone stronger so
you've got to learn to do the technical
moves and that's where it's so powerful
about it the other thing that's
interesting about jiu jitsu
is when when and I don't see you don't
you don't get to have these memories
because you grew up in Jiu Jitsu I get
to have these memories Echo we'll have
some of these memories when when we were
kids we looked at martial arts
as this mysterious thing right as this
thing where when you watched a movie
about martial arts you saw some things
right
and some of the things that you'd see
would be like this this
discipline right oh you have to have
discipline you see like the the karate
school with everyone training and you
know punching boards and getting hit in
the back of the neck with a cane or
whatever and having to stay still it was
like this rigid discipline and this
humility being humbled and you have to
be call the master master and you have
to humble yourself
and then you got to win fights because
you could kind of have this magic power
but then if you really started exploring
the martial arts like some of that stuff
just ain't true you know what I mean
like some of that discipline you got
from the master down at the strip mall
that guy was full of right and and
some of that humility that he was
talking about he wasn't humble at all
and some of that fight winning that he
was talking about wasn't a real thing
because he'd never been in a fight
before
what Jiu Jitsu brought was I say this
all the time like you will learn
discipline in Jiu Jitsu because there's
going to be nights you don't want to go
down and get on the map this is going to
be nice there's gonna be you work just
nine hour 10 hour 11 hour day you get
home you're tired you're you're sore
from the two days of working out and you
don't want to go train you have to have
discipline to go and train you have to
you have to have humility because you're
100 gonna get submitted by people people
that are smaller than you people that
are weaker than you people that haven't
been training as long as you're gonna
catch you in a move you're gonna have to
tap so you will be humbled so these
things that seem like magic but didn't
really exist
now they existed and then finally you
get into a fight
like Master Chief Bailey like here's a
guy I'm looking at him and he was tall
but he's not a you know he's a pretty
skinny guy and he was super old too he
must have been at least 40 at the time
so I'm thinking like who's this old man
what's he gonna do and he could win and
he could win every single time it wasn't
like a chance no he was going to win so
these Matt these things that when Echo
and I were growing up watching martial
arts
thinking oh it's discipline it's
humility it's winning fights
they were all not a hundred percent true
in a lot of cases look I'm not trying to
take any look there's you know a lot of
great things that come out of Taekwondo
a lot of great things that come out of
karate and there's schools of those uh
of those disciplines that are squared
away and and and respect to them but
there's also a bunch of you
know there's a bunch of schools that
don't have that kind of stuff and
Jujutsu had it and it had it in Spades
so that's what I think the appeal was it
was like the answer to the question that
all these young people grew up going I
want that magic power I want that
mysterious power I want that discipline
and I want that humility and I want to
be able to win and with Jiu Jitsu you
could actually have it but you had to
earn it you had to earn it
um
so your dad moves up here 1978.
um he's growing that gym to 120 students
they have a waiting list this is the the
seals used to go from San Diego from
Coronado go up and train and I know a
bunch of them this is awesome to talk to
those guys about those old days and
master chief Steve Bailey was one of
them
you're born in what 1983 1983 you're
born
um
how old are you
okay so you're you're age zero when you
start doing Jiu Jitsu you're just doing
Jiu Jitsu from birth
how old are you when you realize
what your last name is and what it means
UFC one okay so 1993 93 because prior to
that when you're born in a house and in
the garage is the thing that's happening
I think this is happening in every house
right like everyone just does they wear
pajamas and they do Jiu Jitsu in their
garage this is a normal family thing
little did I know that was totally not
the case and uh growing up around this
and seeing these challenge matches when
I'm seven years old and there's guys
fighting in the garage and I'm just
standing there by the rabbit like this
tiny little rabbit car that brown rabbit
that we have and I'm just watching and
people are fighting and it's totally
normal and we're desensitized to that
very early and
um then we moved to the school in 1989
we outgrew the garage we moved to the
school and in 1993 when the UFC hits and
this is going to be on television and
I'm like 10 years old and I remember
begging to go to the UFC UFC one hiron
was 12 years old two years older than me
and was invited to go to UFC one so I'm
like let's go this is my ride all my
life I've been waiting for this and what
was very contentious and boom he don't
got to go and Henner stays home for his
10th birthday which was two days before
UFC won
and I was watching at home with my mom
and I was so pissed and I'm like this is
whack you know so he don't over there
and then to make the matters worse in
between the fights on UFC one
um Hedon and hawkzone hickson's older
son were in the ring with rags and
little spray bottles and they were
cleaning the blood off the mats between
the matches and I was so pissed I'm like
they got to bleed the blood boys
ah and then
um
after UFC won a bunch of parents called
in saying this is crazy you have
children wiping blood of grown men off
the floor that can never happen again so
when I finally got allowed to go to UFC
2 several months later I did not get to
be a blood boy I just got to walk around
and get a bunch of autographs backstage
but anyways after UFC one and two of
those early ufcs I'm at school it was on
TV and then like a substitute teacher
comes to school and is like reading my
name off the list and goes Gracie he's
like yeah I just saw the Ultimate
Fighting Championship
who was that I was like that's my uncle
so then I'm like all right this is cool
like some people know who I am this is
crazy so little by little I start to
realize that this is a real thing and
like it's a real 10 11 12 years old you
really start to say okay something's
happening here
that is shocking everyone else even
though it's totally normal for us
the world is waking up to something that
is not familiar to them because our
magic what we've been doing as normal
for the last 80 years 70 years
it's magical to them for some reason and
everyone thinks hoist is going to lose
but then he defeats these larger
opponents that's normal for us we expect
him to win we would be shocked if he
didn't but to everyone else they're
shocked that this little you know pretty
Brazilian guy in a ghee 6-1 178 pounds
is defeating Ken Shamrock they don't
understand that
and um that's when I realized okay this
is a this is a special family this is
crazy not all families are doing what
we're doing
how many hours a day are you training
jiu jitsu at 10 11 12 13 years old
um so yeah as a kid it's an interesting
thing it's a it's a it's a and I'm
dealing with my own kids right now we're
careful because because you're born into
it it's easy to overdo it right it's one
thing to for a parent to bring their
child to the school at eight years old
and the kids motivated and wants to go
do it and Falls head first in love with
it it's another when you're born without
a choice to be around this thing and
this thing is to some degree what takes
your data wave all the time to go to
work and what keeps your parents from
being around you and playing with you
it's kind of the culprit on the other
side so it's this give and take
relationship but eventually
um around 10 11 12 years old I'm
training you know every day an hour or
two doing a Class A kids class
um but there was around 12 years old
there was a time where I would go to the
class and there was one other student in
the kids classes who would consistently
beat me and it really made it hard for
me because in my mind I'm UFC 2 UFC
three like Gracie family Legacy I gotta
defeat everyone this is crazy no one can
beat me in the gym I gotta be number one
and her name was Terry
[Music]
so my nightmare is a girl named Terry
who's kind of stocky athletic girl and
she was just a little bit bigger and had
trained consistently and just had my
number so I would go to class and it
would be a bad day if Terry was there so
it'd be times where I say Dad I don't
want to go to Jujitsu and he says Henry
you have two options you go
or you sit in your room until I get back
it's in six hours because he goes and
works all night and come back at 10
o'clock you guys know how that is
one time I'd stayed home no video games
no console no phones no nothing right so
I'm sitting at home in my room I'm like
gosh you go to the bathroom come back
and then finally he comes home and I'm
like man I can't do that anymore I'm
gonna go to class even though it sucks
to get beat up get beat up and then
everything changed at 13 years old when
there was a man who came in with his son
his son's name was Robert Mendoza Jr
five-year-old kid getting bullied like
his targeted bullying case right not a
general thing but a specific incident
this boy was dealing with
and my dad said okay let's do some
private classes with Henner and I'm 13
years old right never had a job never
really just training and just doing my
thing still in school the whole thing
Hannah are you going to be his teacher
it was like ten dollars a class to train
with Henner for a private class
so I started teaching this kid Robert
Mendoza Jr and it's successful and we
build this kid up and he no longer has
problems with bullies and he's confident
and several months passed and I'm like
wow this is awesome and I'm having this
rewarding experience as a teacher
and that's when I found my other Wings
right one is the technical proficiency
self-defense my own ability you know to
be effective in Jiu Jitsu the other is
what I can do to empower other people so
now I'm like I kind of got that
addiction where I'm like this is crazy I
can be a source of improved quality of
life of confidence of really rebuilding
someone from the inside out I could be
the architect of that this is amazing
let's go for this so more students more
students before you know it 14 15 16
more students privately eventually I'm
teaching kids group classes at 14 15.
I'm teaching adult group class by 16 and
17. I'm teaching Delta by 18 years old
my dad you know in North Carolina at
Fort Bragg so like it went all the way
you know and I'm like this is wild
people aren't doing this kids of my age
are not having this opportunity
um and then soon after uh around yeah 18
years old he'd almost 20 is when my
hoist and my father split hoist decided
I'm gonna go do my own thing have his
own organization and move on they were
teaching kind of shoulder to shoulder
that whole time uh post UFC all the way
until like 2
2002 and then when hoist went to do his
thing now it's me and hiron who are 18
and 20 essentially who are thrust into
leaderships of head instructors of the
Gracie Academy in Torrance and we're
kids I was still a brown belt and
there's you know 200 students and I'm
like this is crazy there's guys who've
been training here who are black belts
since I was seven six five years old and
now I'm they're supposed to trust me as
their new leader
how is this going to go over so
naturally we lost a couple students but
it was a it was a very testing time for
me and hitom and for the business for a
place to leave were you going to school
like high school and stuff like this so
so you're doing normal normal school and
other stuff wrestling in high school you
know my Junior and Senior year did you
only wrestle with your Junior and Junior
yes I played basketball for two years
and my wrestling coach who's Tom Hazel
who's a Oklahoma State stud like you
know All-American several time Tom Hazel
is the wrestling coach of the school but
also fought Hickson on Gracie Jiu Jitsu
in action he's the wrestler in El Camino
College who Hicks on him grapple he
looks like a grizzly bear yeah love the
guy and he ends up in hixson's guard and
Hicks on Armboy he had a Hixson and a
front headlock on Turtle Hixson slips
out and pulls guard and then Thomas in
the guard natural wrestler equation he's
we're gonna be on the bottom they're
going to be on top and Hixson armbars
him from the guard and anyways it was it
was not a striking challenge match but
it was a challenge match of like this
amazing wrestler in the South Bay
against Hixson Hickson defeats him all
respect all good fast forward don't know
20 years and Tom Hazel is the wrestling
coach at West Torrance High School where
I go to high school and so I'm over
there playing basketball for two years I
was tall I could dunk as a freshman so
they like that and then after two years
of wrestling every single day coach
Hazel saw me on campus he would come to
me and say hunter
when are you going to play a mansport
every single time he saw me because he
wanted me to wrestle man or when are you
gonna play a man's sport just always
digging in and finally after two years I
I'm like all right let me give this a
shot I shifted to wrestling to two years
of wrestling and that was a change of
pace for sure how did you do in
wrestling good I I won uh first in CIF
right Southern section third place in
Masters and much as most of south
southern California and then um ranked
fourth in state went to State lost to
some stud went to Nationals I think I
got like ninth in state and then went to
Nationals and uh then got rolled up by
like a two-time Nevada station I got
cradled I'm like dude these guys know
what they're doing so at the local in
California and Southern California level
I was able to hack the whole system
because I'm over here with my butterfly
guard and my Hooks and my guard and my
Mount control and my back control so I
was able to put a spin on wrestling that
really they weren't used to it was like
wrestling an alien and I told Coach
Hazel I said here's the problem I'll
wrestle but I can't practice every
single day because I'm running the
family business I leave school I have
lunch and I go to the class at four
o'clock I'm teaching kids all the way
till nine o'clock group classes in
private classes because I'm running this
business with my brother and he goes all
right Henry as long as you keep winning
you don't have to come to practice just
show up at the meets and if you win
those meets you just keep showing up to
those and I said we got ourselves a deal
so I did two years of wrestling with no
wrestling Jiu Jitsu and hooks and there
are many times where I would pull guard
he's like don't lay on your back and I'm
like butterfly sweep into Mountain he's
like yeah hold up so I basically just
kind of hacked that whole whole way
through that I didn't really take the
wrestling serious I just applied my
skills in that environment and I was
happy with it and it really taught me
how to turn the switch on because
wrestling pace and Jiu Jitsu Pace I'll
lay down for 90 minutes bro and I'll
just choke you at the very end wrestling
it's like six minutes if you don't mount
on this guy in six minutes You're Gonna
Lose by points go so it taught me it was
it was a beneficial shift in my timing
and my energy and my explosiveness
um that I was I was grateful for that to
show up when it did when you go to a
wrestling tournament in California right
now like
this this day and age you will see Jiu
Jitsu oh yeah like the kids just there's
so many kids come from Jiu Jitsu and
they go into wrestling and so you see a
lot of butterfly sweeps it's kind of
crazy you see Mount pins like that's not
a normal thing in wrestling right but it
is in Southern California you'll see
people get mounted pins it's kind of
ridiculous so you're
working all day I mean all night you're
going to school all day are you what are
you are you have any uh normal normalcy
in your life do you are you into music
are you no Muse nothing else no music uh
it was that that particular time as
hoist kind of stepped out and me and
hidon took the lead it was crazy like I
didn't even do homework at home I would
go at lunch I would go to the library to
do my homework because I knew I had to
go run the family business at night and
I took pride in getting good grades in
school he don't not so much but that was
his choice so I like I cared about doing
well so
I just had to make things work and then
I would go teach for five six hours a
night and then go to school the next
morning and do it again and know that
that was the routine so it's like a
full-time school and really a full-time
teaching job
um and then I graduated and the idea of
going to college or not was a very tough
decision as well because here I am
running this family business but also
I'm in a position where academically I
would qualify got several colleges
interested in scholarships for wrestling
because my academics were there and the
wrestling performance was there so I was
like man there's opportunity to go to
college I'd be the first one here in the
US to do it my dad went to college in
Brazil should I do that so there was all
these mixed feelings about it but the
conclusion was that I know what I need
to do the conclusion was Jiu Jitsu yeah
you can't I couldn't leave for four
years at that critical time the whole
business would have suffered and and
might have been it might have might have
been the end of the rainbow there for
the Gracie Academy as a standalone Jiu
Jitsu business so I chose to stay I
learned everything just running that
business I made every mistake imaginable
um and then you know 18 19 20 21 22 23
after sportifying was your dad like
overseeing the business side or was he
kind of like yeah it's tough right
because it's such a it's such a human
interaction based business that he was
already I think in his 50s or late 40s
hoist and kaiki were the ones teaching
most of the classes so when they stepped
out he was not really a figure on the
mat in a prominent way so the people
aspect of our business was really just a
void so me and he don't filled that void
and then since we were the ones
interacting with the students He was
largely on the administrative side he's
there but really it's a people business
right we're in the people business we
just happened to teach Jiu Jitsu and
those connections matter so much so he
was there as a supervisory role but in
terms of what are we going to do to grow
this business to a level that it will
allow us to stay together and prosper
compared to what you see so often in Jiu
Jitsu which is like splintering
splintering everyone do their own thing
everyone spread everyone move off and
leave each other so that was my thing
I'm like look 18 years old we started
running it by 22 23 I had kind of popped
my head up we had built our confidence I
was a black belt now the students who
stayed loved us and the students who
left left but after three or four years
we were still around 225 students and
that's was like hold on it really kind
of rattled me because I said we took
over we had about 200 students when we
started running this we're at about 225
but several years have passed what is
going on so that's when we started
asking all the right questions of saying
wait a minute how is the student
experience in this building how are we
treating these students from the first
phone call from the first interaction
the first class certainly and how where
are we losing them so we started running
the business like an actual business and
really asking ourselves the right
questions and then everything started to
change we rewrote how we teach beginners
we rewrote how we teach kids we wrote
how we introduce people how we talk to
people on the phone everything and then
in 18 months we were at 750 students
pushing beyond that once we decided to
start asking the right questions and we
grew out of that location we moved to
the Artesia Boulevard location
um after 17 years in the first location
we moved to Artesia
um and it was a larger School larger mat
we needed the space and then we kind of
found our Rhythm and we we were so
successful in our revamping of how we
run a jiu jitsu business that we finally
decided to start licensing our programs
and our methodology to schools all over
the world and that was in you know 2008
2009 and now we're 250 schools deep and
our school in Torrance has 2 000
students so we figured out we we jiu
jitsued Jujitsu School operations right
like we really just started to be
analytical and Technical and seeking
more efficient processes and learning
from our mistakes and uh very happy with
where it's landed so your competition
life I think did you really compete that
much before brown belt because I know
kind of the first big as far as I know
the first big win you had in competition
was as brown belt in like ibjf right is
that or did you compete before that but
it was just kind of yeah no there
blue and purple belt and brown belt
different Regional different tournaments
Jeff Higgs I think I competed against
Jeff a couple times how'd you do I beat
him oh yeah he was cool he was really
kind but I think I choked him a couple
times he was a strong guy man he's all
right face and just like so stable
um so Jeff a couple times and then uh
the pan AMS I fought a former world or
world champion Fabio Leopoldo beat him
as a black belt very early in my black
belt career so nothing too crazy
um you know I I scratched that itch and
then it was interesting because around
19 years old I actually suffered a
herniated disc from training incidents
and in my L5 S1 lower back and I had
surgery and then that prevented me from
doing Jutsu for 10 months so that was
kind of for me a big Paradigm Shift
where I said wait a minute I suffered an
injury as a teenager as a late teenager
here that will affect me for 10 months
what happens if this happens when I'm 30
or when I'm 40 where I suffer an injury
or something happens in my life that
will prevent me from using this Swiss
army knife to make a living every single
day
like I believe I need to so for a Jutsu
teacher your body is the only tool you
need and the only tool you can be
without
so I really at a very early age I
started asking questions about wait a
minute this is this this doesn't work
like I can't get injury to be sidelined
this is crazy
and that's when I realized okay what's
the landscape right now because remember
growing up in the UFC kind of the
reality of our families fighting hoist
is fighting UFC's going my dad was
involved in all that my dad sold his
part but it was still happening and all
these people are fighting very much the
question in my head was is my future
a fighter do you go fight and that's how
you pay your bills that's you entertain
and you fight and you train every single
day to go fight some other guy and you
beat him is that my destiny to do that
until I'm 40 and then retire and hope to
have enough money
and
the you when you really assess the
landscape two factors played it number
one was this injury I went man this is
crazy because if you get injured you're
out of the game and number two was when
you look at the landscape of who was
fighting in the UFC when I was 19 20 21.
now we're talking 10 years after the
UFC's Inception when you look at who's
fighting now it no longer was a matter
of karate versus taekwondo versus Jiu
Jitsu it was karate Taekwondo and Jiu
Jitsu and wrestling and kickboxing all
blended into the same person fighting
each other with all very much the same
skill sets with slight variations from
person to person based on their
historical kind of upbringing in martial
arts so I'm fighting against guys who
very much believe what I believe which
is Jiu Jitsu is the best
and historically in the Gracie family
went all the way back that really wasn't
what the fight was about it was about
proving that Jiu Jitsu is better than
whatever else you're doing but if we
both believe in this religion of jujitsu
then we're good like yo I believe too
cool unless it's a personal thing right
unless there's a bad blood and there's a
personal thing but really when it comes
to the Gracie challenge matches it was
bring me someone who doesn't believe
that this is the best and let's prove it
to them
so once the MMA and the UFC was absent
of that reality I went man so I'm not
even fighting for jiu jitsu anymore I'm
fighting for me only me to make my money
to pay my bills
and I thought listen that's commendable
and the people who do that requires a
level of discipline and dedication and
and and and expertise in their craft
that is right it's it's it's it's
unbelievable What It Takes we've all
seen that
but I don't know if that's going to be
if that's the end of my road here if
that's the if that's the path I want to
live
so instead I looked at the landscape and
said man Jiu Jitsu is known worldwide
but there is no really structured
dissemination of this art anybody can
teach anybody who knows this if I know a
friend who has a friend from Brazil
he'll teach you over here this guy knows
that right back in those days it was
just like wherever you could get it so
it was clear that there was a demand for
jiu jitsu but there wasn't a supply an
effective supply chain so I thought man
if we could really organize right in the
wake of this accident as well if I could
organize shujitsu in a way where
everything that I've ever learned could
be put online
in linear fashion so that anyone
anywhere in the world could log on and
watch lesson one
and once they finish lesson one watch
lesson two which Builds on lesson one
and do that all the way through every
skill that I've ever learned in this
family I would be doing a great service
because if I get hit by a truck then
someone can log in and see Henner's path
through Jiu Jitsu and hidon's path
through Jiu Jitsu and learn the art very
much the way we learned it and it's
forever right immortalized in this in
this online linear curriculum and that's
where Grace University was born but it
was fueled by this fear that if
something happens to me where I can't do
Jiu Jitsu anymore how can I preserve
everything that I've ever learned
especially in the wake of that accident
and that uh that injury that sidelined
me for so long and today you know Gracie
University is really the central
Communication medium this website where
all of our certified training centers
that's where they get their information
people who don't have a school near them
are learning in their garages for all
over the world 390 000 students in 196
countries learning they've opened up a
room they put some mats down and they do
Jiu Jitsu and that all came out of this
realization that someone's got to be
responsible before organizing this and
letting people have access all over the
world and
if I get injured again at least I can
say I documented everything I knew
so you focus you decide to focus and you
just explained you decide to focus on
being a teacher and spreading the word
of Jiu Jitsu and spreading the knowledge
of Jiu Jitsu and so this starts in your
Academy
um the Gracie University it used to be
the Gracie Academy right and now it's
Gracie University the headquarters is up
there in LA and and so then from there
what came did you start with the the uh
training centers the Gracie training
centers the Gracie certified training
centers and then the Gracie garages one
of the what are those two things about
yeah so once we refine the curriculum
internally for one school in Torrance to
a degree where we felt comfortable this
is how beginners should learn Jiu Jitsu
for the greatest retention and for the
greatest preservation of these right
fledgling Jiu Jitsu Journeys where
they're so fickle right someone has a
bad experience they're gone you see it
here I'm sure where it's like one bad
Training Day on a third or fourth class
and you'll never see that person again
on the Jujitsu mats so once we crack the
code on how to avoid that high attrition
so commonly associated with Jiu Jitsu
then we begin licensing those programs
out to these other schools these
certified Gracie Jiu Jitsu training
centers now were those were those things
that you first gave out like let's say
it was 2006 is that what these things
going on in 2002
we changed it internally 2005 2006 we
changed it it was successful for a
couple years and then we licensed it up
so 2008 if I wanted I want to be a
Gracie certified gym or whatever how do
how do you teach me do I have to go to
your Academy how does that work because
we don't have online yet right yes
initially the very very beginning we
didn't have online so we said look we
want to certify some people and a lot of
these people had other martial arts
backgrounds you might own a karate
school we want to certify you to teach
just a curriculum for beginners 36
techniques very much like we do with law
enforcement right you're not a master
you're not a black belt but you can
teach someone a beginner curriculum and
then as you involve as you evolve your
skill set and grow you can grow your
level of certification so someone comes
in says Hey I want to after a Jujitsu at
my karate school you learn 36 Gracie
combatives is this beginner program 36
techniques once you learn those 36
techniques we then teach you how to
administer and teach that program and
only that program
and then they learn that material they
go back and now they're teaching it in
the very beginning they were white belts
people left us as a white belt with a
few stripes and say hey just go teach
these beginner techniques and nothing
else but what happened is once Gracie
University the online came into play we
said look instead of someone coming here
spending you know 80 hours to learn
these 36 techniques learn them on your
own learn them wherever you are because
then you don't have to leave your family
for so much time once you learn the
material demonstrate proficiency either
by going to an existing school or by
sending in a video where you show me
that you know these 36 moves and then
you come to California only to learn how
to teach them so now someone can take a
year six months to a year to learn this
little basic curriculum and then they
come to California to learn the teaching
methodologies and then once they do that
they're level one certified training
center now many of these schools are
brown and black belts much higher skill
level but they don't have the structure
they suffered from what we suffered from
which is Henry I've had a school I've
been under so and so member of the
Gracie family Affiliated for the last 17
years and I have 112 students
teaching Brazilian Jiu Jitsu in America
the hottest martial art in the hottest
market with the number one promotional
vehicle the UFC and then you and Joe's
podcast number two and three right in
terms of like bringing attention to jiu
jitsu and you can't get more than 112
people to want to practice this art in
your community something is wrong not
with Jiu Jitsu but with how you're
delivering it so many guys would come in
with the lots of Jiu Jitsu background
but no business Acumen and no knowledge
of how to deliver Jiu Jitsu in a way
that makes it safe and structured for
beginners so they would come get
certified and they would go back and
someone like that could be a higher
level of certification because they had
that previous knowledge so on the
website they'd be listed differently
than someone who's only teaching Gracie
combatives and only teaching children
Gracie bully proof like simple basic
beginner curriculums so so then once you
have that thing going away so hold on
what's a Gracie garage Gracie garage so
people Grace University online hundreds
of thousands of people want to learn
from home most of them don't have a
school near them right some of them will
go to just a random local BJJ school
right where they'll go in and say hey I
want to learn I watched the Gracie
University online I want to train with
you guys can I train here yes great they
become a student and we never hear about
them some of them see what we do online
they like the methodology they like the
safety they like the self-defense
emphasis in the beginner program then
they go to a BJJ school and they go man
this is not resembling what I saw in
those videos and I want to do that
because that's what I believe Jiu Jitsu
should be for me I'm older I'm out of
shape and it feels safer
or the curriculum emphasizes what I care
about so then they'll say hey even
though there's a BJJ school here I want
to learn on my own because I want to
follow this curriculum so they don't
have a training partner so what we
created was the opportunity for anyone
at home anywhere in the world who has
access to the curriculum
who has training mats 10 by 10 100
square feet which is smaller than this
room 10 by 10 mats the curriculum and a
poster of my grandfather in their garage
or in their room if you have those three
things you can apply for Gracie garage
status now what is a Gracie garage it's
an unofficial at-home Training Center
for like-minded Grace University members
who just want to collaborate to learn
together in the absence of an instructor
but they just need a body because their
wife isn't interested in rolling with
them on the floor outside of the bedroom
right like that's it like so so it's
like a networking it's a it's a it's a
yeah it's a totally networking play and
it pays homage to the Gracie garage but
none of these have certified instructors
now the beautiful thing is
it's a great way for someone to say man
I need a partner so they list themselves
and then they get inquiries from people
now their address isn't publicized but
there's a comment and like a direct chat
feature where I could say hey Jocko I
see you have a Gracie garage
um can I come out and you would go well
I don't know you so let's go meet for
coffee and we sit down or let's go meet
for some choco Fuel and we sit down and
we have a conversation and you feel my
vibe and if you like it you invite me to
the house for a training session and
before you know it not only are we best
friends we're recruiting other people
and now there's 17 people in this Gracie
garage doing Gracie combatives in the
absence of a school that they want to
train at and they're building and then
in many cases this has happened where
these garages exist for 12 months a year
year and a half the people who run these
garages become so fanatical about the
curriculum and about their progress and
they actually make measurable progress
and they become good at Jiu Jitsu in
their house then they apply to come do
the instructor certification program
level one basic they go back they open a
school those 17 garage members they get
a discount on the membership for the
first year and then they start paying
full price after that they have have all
these built-in students they tell all
their friends and it turns into a
for-profit business so Gracie garages
has become that Gracie garage
classification has become the seating
program for so many certified training
centers today that started and then guys
grow their businesses like this Apple
Valley California Johnny Vasquez is a
great example Corporate America full-on
well-paying Job start the Gracie garage
starts training moves out of it to open
his school once he gets certified as a
blue belt and then in the first three
years as a blue belt after opening his
certified Training Center surpasses 350
students as a blue belt then he gets his
purple belt continues to grow changing
locations and now I just talked to him
last week he's pushing 750 students as a
brown belt
and he had to quit his job because the
amount of time that work took was taking
him away from growing the school and now
he's making more money than he ever has
but he's running a jiu jitsu business
doing what he loves and he has like 10
or 8 other instructors who've been
through the same certification process
and he's scaling his business and
growing it next for him is going to open
multiple locations and he's in a
neighborhood with UFC fighters other
black belt gym owners BJJ schools he's
not out in the middle of nowhere there's
actual schools within miles of his
location and he's the most successful
School in Apple Valley the most
successful martial arts school as a
brown belt so all of this because
not only Johnny's hard work ethic and
and dedication to the process but these
systems that we developed that then we
said hey we can't be the only ones and I
gotta say like coming up in this family
there's very much a feeling of if we
don't do it it's not right only we can
do it right only we can do it the best
only we can deliver so I have to say
that there was certainly some mold
breaking that me and Hedon had to do to
get those who came before us to agree
number one to do online learning right
because there was some heavy scrutiny
there and number two to allow other
schools to be certified with our name
and with our programs because oh no
they're never going to do it right
they're going to violate this they're
going to break that they're going to do
it wrong they're going to water
everything down
and I said unfortunately if we have that
mindset we will remain as one school
forever and other organizations which
trust in the other people more are going
to grow more effectively and then at the
end of the day we just box ourselves out
of the entire Jiu Jitsu growth
opportunity because of this feeling of
if it's not a hundred percent no they
can't do it my theory is no if they can
do it 80 in the beginning they'll reach
their 100 over time and we have to
delegate and we have to permit we have
to trust that they're going to do the
right thing now in these 250 schools
we've been burnt sometimes we've had
people who've made terrible mistakes as
leaders and we've had to terminate those
relationships but would I take it all
back no way because the tens of
thousands of students at these schools
who are benefiting from our processes
right and all the lives and the letters
and all the happy changes that have
happened as a result of us trusting in
these instructors all over the world
many of whom are the same Taekwondo
karate kickboxing instructors who 20
years ago were on the other end of the
challenge match but now they're not only
not our enemies they're actually our
needed allies in the global expansion of
the way that we teach jujitsu
how did you
come about with the online Gracie
University so gracieuniversity.com yeah
this is your online training protocol
one thing I will say is you know from
the perspective of the rest of your
family look at you like you can't teach
this stuff online
this is before people understood what
you can get online and you can get all
kinds of stuff online there's people
that have fought in the UFC that only I
mean even Evan Tanner remember Evan
Tanner yes Evan Tanner they're like hey
where'd you learn Jiu Jitsu he's like
the videos like the Gracie in action
video right like he was a wrestler but
he learned Jiu Jitsu from watching those
gracing action videos
and so now and then you've got other
other Fighters out there that have
learned moves and learned Jiu Jitsu and
they where'd you learn that from oh I
learned it from YouTube so I think there
was a maybe a lack of vision
and I can put myself in this category
you know you think how did I learn Jiu
Jitsu that must be the only way to learn
Jiu Jitsu is to have somebody grab your
arm and put it over here and grab your
yeah put your weight over here and and
physically do it with you not
understanding that you could sit down
you could watch a video and you could go
hey come here for a minute buddy let me
do this do to me do it try it again oh
they they said oh they're real specific
about putting your wrist over here okay
how's that feel oh yeah that definitely
okay so you can do it it takes a little
bit more effort it takes it almost takes
a more studious mindset you know to
learn that way you can kind of be a
knucklehead like me and go to a jiu
jitsu class and you're gonna learn like
you're gonna you're gonna learn it when
you start because I do this now too
obviously look at videos go online look
dissect what's happening you have to be
more engaged mentally to learn that way
but there's no doubt that you can learn
by watching videos so how did you come
to that conclusion to start the Gracie
University online yeah that's a great
question and when it All Began there was
a lot of scrutiny whether or not you
could actually learn online
and
the the need for the online university
I've explained which is I got injured
and I said if I don't document this
stuff forever
it may never be documented and if I
can't train for the rest of my life so
it was more of like a fear right like a
productive paranoia what if I can't
teach anymore so let me capture
everything I've learned and leave it for
my kids and their kids and their kids
and their kids preservation of History
was my mindset because my grandfather
didn't document everything he learned my
dad did not document everything he
learned my uncles were not documenting
in fact they were very anti-video of any
sort not my father he had some vhs's
instructionals and hoists was in on
those but I have other uncles who were
not only were they not producing videos
they believed that no there's only one
way for this information to be
transferred is by touching another
person and there's an honor and there's
a humility and there's a respect and
that engagement that can never be
violated there wasn't there also like
let's keep this stuff for us let me tell
you I mean so they're away so let me
tell you about this one so Gracie
combatives is
was our beginner program the first
iteration of that program was produced
in 2009 2008
um and we just right now finished
production and we'll be releasing in the
next two months Gracie combatives 2.0
after 13 14 years we're reshooting that
program what makes Gracie combative so
unique is it's the first attempt at an
instructional series that is a complete
like closed system that is linear and
builds off itself right people do a lot
of instructions and most of them are
online now this is even DVDs when people
did them even during DVD era instilled
online to this day what are most
websites a bunch of videos you log on do
you want to learn sweeps or do you want
to learn arm bars and you click a little
filter you write something in it pops up
sweeps or arm bars and then you see a
group class of an instructor teaching a
technique in front of 20 or 30 students
and you just happen to be a fly on the
wall watching that instruction to a
group that model the problem is it
doesn't consider the student who is
actually using this material as their
sole source of instruction it's ideal
for students who train somewhere else
who want to supplement their training
with additional details that you're
specifically good at you know Guillotine
chokes I'm going to watch Jaco's
tutorial learn Guillotines you already
know what you need when you went to
Jocko's website so for us I went no
that's not good enough we need to create
a curriculum that anyone who is
intrigued by Jujitsu for any of the
Avenues in the marketing in the UFC who
says I'm gonna go learn Jiu Jitsu online
lesson one has to be high welcome to
jujitsu
teach the Trap and roll lesson two has
to build on that lesson one so that
linear progression was very very new
it's very and the reason why other
people don't do it I'll just put this
out there is it's so much work when you
film a group class I'm already teaching
that group class so it's much easier to
turn on a camera and just film what I'm
already gonna do for a room full of
paying students when we filmed our
linear curriculum me and Hedon had to
budget time separate from all the
classes we ran every single day we had
to budget Standalone time to film
classes that were only meant to be
watched in order by a global audience of
students who wanted to learn where they
didn't have accredited schools that they
believed were going to offer what they
needed
so it was so much it's like having
another full-time job versus double
dipping on my existing full-time job by
just filming the classes
so that's what we aimed for that's what
makes Gracie University unique is
everything is in order and that's what
makes Gracie combatives at the time
unique so when we came out with Gracie
combatives the original DVD program
members of my family
the feeling was you don't need to do
this
this is too much if you do this program
with this level of guided Clarity and
linear learning progression opportunity
for a student with this much detail why
would they come to our schools that was
said to me and I went holy cow here I am
all I'm trying to do is do this family
proud and like teach Jujitsu in a way
and get it out to the world right do
what my grandfather wants to share Jiu
Jitsu with the world empower the weak
against the strong
and I got an uncle saying that they
don't want I have a lot of uncles so I
can say that no one knows what I'm
talking about okay and I won't tell you
which one he was a badass though and
they all are so uh I have an uncle
saying hey Henry this is too much the
detail and the clarity of the curriculum
is too precise they don't need a teacher
with this level of clarity
and all of a sudden I was conflicted
because on one hand I don't want to
disappoint my uncles and like feel like
I'm the black sheep that's doing
something that's gonna take food off
their table no way
I just want people who don't have access
to my uncles to be able to learn Jiu
Jitsu also so it was such a crazy
dilemma
and
there was enough support and enough uh
in the family as well there's enough
support for the curriculum and the way
we approach Jiu Jitsu online and on DVDs
at the time that we went ahead with it
now what I now know in retrospect
and to all those people who said no you
can't learn online and this is crazy and
I think some of them really believe that
you couldn't learn online others were
fearful that if it's true that you could
learn online then why would you ever go
to a school there's this mixed bags and
some people will say you can't learn
online but really what they're feeling
is please make it so that learning
online is impossible because if it is
why would anyone go and just not learn
online with you guys
I know it was mixed emotions for
everyone but here's what I now know
after the fact in retrospect is that
five percent of people
are capable of learning on their own
at home with the training partner that
they found on a website
off a website through a linear online
curriculum one out of 20 people have the
discipline the studious personality
Engage The ability of block it out and
I'm gonna do this
I now know that to be a fact because I
know the numbers of our website and I
see how many people sign up and I see
how many people stick it through all the
way it's five percent give or take so a
hundred people go to the website
five of them see it through and go all
the way 95 out of those hundred
many things happen to them but it's my
belief that they watch the first three
four five lessons that are free we make
the first ones free you log on you say
oh this is awesome we try to hook them
and then they sign up for a membership
the 95 of those people say this is
amazing I want more of this but I want
to learn in person because my wife
doesn't want to train her my husband
doesn't want to do it or my sons don't
want to do it or my daughters so let me
go find a school and they show up at
their local BJJ School
largely because they liked what they saw
and we don't have a school in their area
if they did they'd probably go to that
but we only have 200 schools and in a
whole world that's very little so 90 I
would say 95 of the time there isn't a
certified Gracie School of ours there so
they go to the random BJJ school they
show up saying yeah I've seen some
Gracie videos over there and I want to
learn Jiu Jitsu I got my introduction
with Henry and he don't online but I
want to sign up for Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
because you're in my neighborhood right
proximity matters in this case and they
sign up so not only is it not true you
can actually learn online because I've
seen those who've committed to the
process Not only was that not true it
also wasn't true that we were stealing
students from the brick and mortar
schools the opposite was true we became
I think pre-y your podcast and pre-rogan
doing what he's doing we were a top
driver of people into Jiu Jitsu with the
Gracie breakdowns from YouTube where we
break down these UFC fights and draw
people in and then we send them to the
website they'd watch the lessons online
and then right after they go find a
school near them so I took great pride
in being in Ambassador for jiu jitsu who
sucked people into the art with very
good breakdowns and then guided them on
how to solve to see these first few
lessons and where to end up so and many
people in the time since then have come
to me and said Henner man I started with
your breakdowns and I started online
with you and I found a school nearby
which school and random Jiu Jitsu over
here and I'm like dude that's freaking
dope I'm responsible I got you in and I
never got a letter from the owner of
that school saying Henry thank you for
this student and maybe it was the same
guy who was saying you can't learn
online but I'm okay with that because I
know what I've done and I know where I
sit and the irony in all of this is
today every one of my family members
everyone has a website everyone's
teaching Jutsu online and I'm just like
cool all right they came around
especially post covid right post covert
everyone was like he don't in hand over
onto something let's build these
websites because we can't teach in brick
and mortar this is crazy so thankfully
everyone's on that page now and learning
online is is one of the most reliable
ways and everyone agrees and happy to
say we still do a great job in terms of
presenting it linearly and but there's a
lot of other great resources you can
find whatever you're looking for now and
our Focus right if for those who don't
know is really that beginner experience
whether it's a woman whether it's a
police officer whether it's a child
whether it's in a man anyone who wants
to learn Jiu Jitsu that first six to 12
months if it's done correctly will set
them up for train for the rest of their
life if it's not they quit they don't
give it a second chance in most cases
and we never hear about them the I
believe
the the skeletons in the Jiu Jitsu
graveyard the volume of those skeletons
are greater than the number of people
who do Jiu Jitsu today more have tried
and stopped than Who currently practice
and I'm trying to I'm trying to change
that
so you keep talking about uh Gracie
combatives well explain greasy
combatives yeah so um post UFC one two
uh US army rangers right they recruited
the Gracie family to go down there and
to begin teaching these soldiers right
and at that time very much like military
things are it's a one-week thing let's
go do Jiu Jitsu for a week let's go do
this shooting for a week let's go snipe
for a week so Jiu Jitsu for a week my
dad hoist other members of the family
are going down there teaching these
Rangers and lo and behold right as you
know well over time the entire US Army
modern Army combatives program is
Rewritten to incorporate
um you know the Gracie's Jujitsu
techniques that were taught to them in
the early 90s there and when we're
teaching in that type of constrained
environment where you only have so much
time to teach a soldier
you can't just say BJJ vast art
thousands of techniques let's just do
Jiu Jitsu you can't do that you have to
say wait a minute you only have 40 hours
what can we teach you in 40 hours that
if you get in a fight six months from
now and all you have is that you're
gonna survive that fight
and that is the essence of what the
Gracie combatives program is it's a
mindset of number one the adversary is
not a jiu jitsu chess player like you
right we're not playing the game of
jujitsu because that takes you know
countless years to prepare for and
there's infinite techniques and there's
always new ones being invented what does
a beginner need to learn
in the least amount of time that if they
get into a fight six months from the
date of commencing their Jiu Jitsu
practice they're gonna survive against
someone 20 pounds heavier than them
who's trying to just punch their head
into the pavement so that same mindset
that we have with the Army we decided
man let's make a program for beginner
civilians where they can learn and we
named it Gracie combatives because the
mindset was the same and many of the
techniques I'd say 90 of the techniques
in Gracie combatives are the same as the
ones we originally introduced to the
Army in the early 90s in this mindset of
least amount of time maximum preparation
if that's all you have you're going to
be okay you're not a world champion
you're not competing in Jiu Jitsu but
you understand distance you understand
leverage you understand timing in a way
that the average person who does not
know these tools won't have the
resources to hurt you right in any
significant way that's it so then when
we started teaching this to the civilian
sector we made a very specific
curriculum and people that's what we did
in 2005 2006 when I realized man this is
crazy like we're not growing as a
business we put in Gracie combatives
this beginner program these 36
techniques and we put them on a card
system and every time you did a class
you got a check mark for that particular
class and there was three boxes next to
every class and you wanted to do each
class three times and the genius of the
program was you didn't have to do those
23 classes in order you could do them
out of order any sequence every class
you came to if it's class 17 today we're
going to see the leg hook takedown from
standing clinch and we're going to see
the Kimura from the guard done that's
the curriculum and if you've already
done this class great you're going to
get it again if you haven't done this
class we're going to teach it in a way
that requires no prerequisites to make
sense of that class so now you have this
beginner program where someone can show
up anytime into this curriculum never
feel confused overwhelmed Left Behind
incapable because we're speaking a
language that we call LCD language
lowest common denominator so everyone in
that class is being spoken to as if
they've never seen the class and those
who know the class knew what they showed
up for because it's on the schedule and
to make Matt is even stronger every
single one of our members has access to
the Gracie University online curriculum
so students can preview that lesson in
full detail or review it after the fact
if they forget a detail and that reduces
anxiety so much because we're in a very
kind of educationally stimulated Society
Brazil wasn't like that Brazil go to the
Beach's Feet Sandy show up you know
white dust them off on the mat and do
some Jiu Jitsu and whatever we learn
tomorrow doesn't matter we do something
different than we did today it's all no
big deal but in America if you have a
beginner show up somewhere in a place of
study of educational Pursuit and you say
to them hey
in order to move on to the next level
just keep showing up one day I'll let
you know when you're ready which is how
99 of BJJ schools function just keep
doing the thing and then one day I'll
let you know when you're ready for the
next thing
no imagine going to Stanford and they
just said keep coming to classes and one
day you'll get your degree no you have
to tell them what they need to do and
they will commit to that process so
Jujitsu was largely absent of that and
our good friends the Valente Brothers in
Miami had their own version of a
beginner curriculum like this where it
was clear what you needed to do there
was a set number of techniques different
techniques
um than Gracie combat has but a
curriculum nonetheless and they had
success with it and that's when I was
like man let me try that with Gracie
combatives
um these these military kind of rooted
techniques and let's offer this to
civilians and it worked and that putting
that program in for beginners is what
took us from that 225 to the 750 plus in
18 months and that's when I went holy
cow if a beginner comes in and sees this
and knows what they're going to get and
is this stimulated to show up and it's
almost like it gamified it because
there's a check mark there's a box and
every class they come to we check the
box for them the receptionist does so
they see their card filling up and then
once you fill up this column over here
20 classes or more you're eligible for a
stripe on your white belt and you keep
filling all of this up and at the end of
this once you complete all of this which
is typically 8 to 12 months there's a
test you can take demonstrating
Proficiency in these 36 techniques and
if you pass that you're in your Gracie
combative spell which is a white belt
with a blue stripe through the middle
and then we added this into the equation
and it became so clear for the student
what they had to pursue and then once
they earned that then they move on to
the advanced Jiu Jitsu class where now
they're rolling intensely with other
training Partners blue belts and Beyond
and they're kind of figuring out the
Deep Waters of jujitsu and in the for
the best analogy you go from playing
checkers to chess you go from Gracie
combatives for another beginner someone
who doesn't know Jiu Jitsu to the
complexities that we love so much about
infinite Jiu Jitsu and that chess match
that we're so addicted to but the
mistake that 99 of BJJ schools make is
that that beginning doesn't exist and
the chess match is the beginning so when
someone comes in they're immediately
thrown to the trenches of survival
Synchro sink or swim and you just go and
figure it out and Only the Strong
Survive and when you roll goal because
think about it two grown men sitting at
a desk eight to ten hours a day joints
are stiff ligaments are like they're
aged ligaments and then they sign up
because they see a podcast and they hear
you enthusiastically praise Jiu Jitsu
they go to their local BJJ school and
the coach goes in and says and I've
heard the story a thousand times all
right guys you guys are about the same
size cool welcome to jiu jitsu first
class we see a technique maybe second
class third class they might delay a
little bit some do it on the first day
you two are going to spar now what does
that mean coach well just try to beat
him and you try to beat him but I don't
understand like I don't how do I do that
just don't tap out is what I've heard
coaches say to beginners so then and now
the thing is this you guys want to care
and you want to go win in that
engagement because the coach is watching
and it cares to be effective and you
want to be successful but your joints
aren't ready when you're not 12 years
old you're not 15 years old you're not
21 where those joints are just kind of
pliable still right you're you're stiff
you're old so now you're sparring two
grown adults the recent situation in
Santa Monica One of the cops we know was
recommended by one my friends GO train
BJJ Go Cops need to learn Jiu Jitsu he
goes to the local school because
everyone says to first day they're
sparring standing startup roll the guy
falls down posts his arm dislocates and
damages his labrum and he's going to
have to have surgery so this is his
first day trying Jiu Jitsu and to me
this is where it's so sad because the
art that is for everyone
is taught in a way that makes it for the
elite and that's the saddest part and my
grandfather's not here anymore but I
always try to channel what he would want
and in my belief it's like he was the
small the weak right Jiu Jitsu is the
Triumph of human intelligence over brute
strength
but if we're not able to give it to the
small the weak the unathletic people in
society then what service are we
providing we're giving Jiu Jitsu to the
people who don't need it we're giving it
to the people that we need to prepare
for instead we're giving the we're
giving Wings to the rattlesnakes they
don't need Wings they're rattlesnakes so
this is kind of something that I
struggle with today in Jiu Jitsu and why
I do the work that I do to just try to
tip the scale back because if you're one
of those people who wants to learn but
you don't feel like the school near you
is safe to do so you'll go in you'll try
a class and then you'll never do it
again you know but if we can make sure
that that initial Landing is soft and so
on for and so forgiving and so and so
contextually relevant that's another
thing BJJ class first day x-gard lapel
feeding through the leg and doing this
and and a beginner saying what to
themselves
I don't understand what's happening what
does this have to do with UFC one that's
huge what does this have to do with
hoist and the Gracie challenge matches
and all the fight prowess and
Effectiveness that the Gracie family is
known for I don't see the connection so
for me I'm a big one on safety if they
cannot get hurt in the first several
months you cannot
number one number two is contextual
relevance it has to make sense every
class a beginner comes to every single
word that comes out of your mouth they
have to say
make sense give me more I love this I'm
so glad I didn't spend time with my
family tonight to come be here with you
guys I'm so glad I chose this hobby
after hearing a podcast I'm so this is
it I want nothing more than more of this
in my life
contextual relevance and that's what the
Gracie combatives program does for our
students is it like it makes every class
like yo you're in a fight manage the
distance manage the damage we want to
avoid The Knockout close that distance
get a hold of every fight every class
starts with the same discussion so
everyone's Being Framed constantly about
why we're doing this thing and then if
you shift to women empowered right
Gracie bully proof these other programs
all of them there's contextual relevance
with every technique taught so the kid
who's nine years old Hears A discussion
about a bullying encounter or an
exclusionary bullying situation or cyber
bullying which are discussed in the
classes they role play these scenarios
in addition to doing Jiu Jitsu and so
many schools they teach Jujitsu and then
no contacts just do Jiu Jitsu and get
really good and the hope is that the
child will give it the contextual
relevance if they need to one day even
without being instructed on what that
contextual relevance would be same is
for women the act of doing Jiu Jitsu is
beneficial of course but but in the very
beginning every day they're asking
themselves should I come back tomorrow
and if the answer is I don't know why we
did this today then you know the answer
to the first question
how long is the bully proof program so
Gracie bully proof we split into Matt
munchkins which is three to four three
to five years old and then beginners all
beginners and then five to seven is
little champs and then seven to twelve
is Junior Grapplers these are all
entry-level beginner programs kids come
in of course the bat munchkins are just
playing with their parents on the mat
having fun but five to seven and seven
to twelve they're learning they're
they're engaging in discussions about
bowling every class different scenarios
what if the guy does this what if the
guy does that what if the opponent does
this what if the bully does that what if
you're at your house and they're playing
and they say do this or you're not my
friend let me write my name on your
forehead with a sharpie or you're not my
friend and then you look straight at
them say hey I guess we're not friends
then
kids need to role play this
kids need to hear their voices saying
these things because to assume that
they're going to muster up the courage
and the clarity in that moment just
because they learn a few arm bars and
some sweeps there's no guarantee that
that connects but if you can have them
role playing these and they're getting
that same as the arm bar and a trap and
roll Escape or an elbowscape those are
rehearsed techniques to build muscle
memory and confidence in their execution
the verbal aspect of jujitsu in boundary
setting is so critical but it's largely
completely untouched in 99 of schools so
you're expecting kids to make these
connections that they don't make so in
terms of the length they stay in these
entry-level programs until they
6 8 12 months a year and a half
sometimes and then they evolve out of
that to What's called the black belt
club and it's a kids club now you have
your more advanced kids who've learned
several techniques 20 30 40 techniques
they've done all these role-playing
situations that make perfect sense for
the lives that they're living and they
love them Jaco they lean into them
they're like we're like yo the kid who's
the bully you know pretend like you have
this Sharpie like you're about to write
it and then the other kid knock it out
of their hand and say yo if that's the
case I guess we're not friends then so
they lean into these situations and yes
you might feel silly as adults talking
about this but what's crazy is that for
them this is normal because it actually
happens same is true for women empowered
classes when we talk about someone
encroaching on their personal space and
we teach these women like look when
someone walks towards you you have to
look them dead in the eye and say don't
get any closer
if they take one more step you triple
your escalation and your intensity in
your voice and I'm not going to do it to
not pop the audio but you freaking rip
them and you say I said back up and you
look him straight in the eye and here's
the thing a woman might know Jujitsu but
if she's never heard her voice say that
and I'm telling you right now it's class
number six in our curriculum is this is
called stop block frame and my wife is
the head instructor of the program I
just there to get beat up by her and
play the perp and we're doing these
classes and these women bro we have a
class of 70 women on a Tuesday night
like tomorrow night there will be 70
women doing beginner Jiu Jitsu in women
empowered role-playing these situations
and I'll tell you it's the hardest
technique in the whole curriculum for a
woman to hear her voice
uh objecting someone's encroachment and
speaking assertively and potentially
disrespectfully to another human being
because all their lives they might be
taught don't ruffle feathers don't do
this don't do that don't be don't cause
a scene be pleasant be kind be right be
all of these things and they're being
boxed in and for these women they get
very emotional about expressing
themselves like this because they've
been holding it in for so long and no
one ever told them when it comes to your
person be polite be friendly be cordial
and this is true for all of us but when
it comes to your personal safety
screw politeness
do what you have to do but someone had
to teach them that and some women are 40
years old and never were told that
they're allowed to be disrespectful
they're allowed to be assertive they're
allowed to look straight in someone's
face and tell them don't take one more
step and here's the point with kids with
women and even with men boundary setting
is the number one self-defense tool all
of us must Master because how many
fights have we avoided just by using our
voice and saying Hey listen to me I can
see you're upset you think this was your
parking spot let me do me a favor don't
get any closer I'm gonna move my car but
stay where you are don't take one more
step towards me when you can assert like
that what do they think number one right
this guy's a ninja or he's carrying a
gun it's one or the other because
there's that level of clarity and
precision now here's the problem with
this formula of boundary setting people
typically only set boundaries that
they're capable of enforcing
the truest self-defense statement if
there is one people only set boundaries
they feel capable of enforcing you're
not going to say don't take one more
step
if if they take another step you don't
know what the hell you're gonna do
you're completely like oh my God Panic
where are we gonna you don't do it you
don't do it you never set the boundary
in fact you never look at the person
what do they normally do they look down
they pretend like they're on their phone
they grab their keys they fidget they do
anything but engage with this person
because they don't want and they don't
know what they would do should things
get out of hand right here but when you
know what we know and we know that we
can handle this 300 pound beard from the
bar down the street gently and
effectively he's not going to get hurt
I'm not going to get hurt and we're
going to take care of business once you
know that you can talk to the beard and
say listen man I can see you had a few
too many drinks but do me a favor stand
right where you are don't take one more
step in my direction
and you can say it calmly you don't have
to even yell at the top of your lungs
and he goes whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm
drunk but I'm not that drunk I know this
guy means what he says right now because
the the power of a boundary is directly
correlated to the ability to back it up
right you learn how to fight so you
never have to right we built I went to
the U.S Air Force Base and Minot Air
Force Base one time to go teach a huge
course of 100 plus Airmen uh Sexual
Assault Awareness prevention defense
techniques
um and I went to the base of the
commander of the the office of the
commander and he shows me the map on the
wall
and he I see all these red dots like
chickenpox and I said Commander what is
all this and he says each one of those
is like a silo right or whatever it is
in the ground with a nuclear warhead
ready to be deployed
and I'm talking thousands of dots on one
base it's all of like Minot right and I
go but Commander like how many of these
would it take to like end
Mankind and he was like probably like
six
whatever the number is like a nominal
figure
I said why so many and he said this is
why we don't have World War III
and then I went Jiu Jitsu bro you learn
how to fight you prepare for war so you
don't have to go to war right and that's
such a massive component in all of this
so when we talk about kids when we talk
about women there's an initial threshold
of time that someone needs to spend
building their confidence learning this
idea of boundary setting for their own
safety once they find their voice
they're safe we have a kid Max who just
came to me two days ago his mom Patricia
and Max is 10 years old kindest little
boy and two kind right and it's one of
those things where respect and kindness
and politeness and the parents raised
their kids to be so sweet and so kind
and which is what we all want for our
kids
but the bully sniffed that out and the
bullies sniff out the weakness and they
sniff out the kindness and they go up
there's my target so max was at Junior
guards right this beach thing where they
swim he's a very good swimmer and a joke
was being made uh this is literally last
week and the joke is being made about
him and the guy says yeah I have a
YouTube channel I'm gonna call it Max is
an idiot or whatever he says you know
and then a friend of Max's actually said
hey man leave him alone and then the
bully starts shoving this friend who
stood up for Max the bully starts kind
of sweating them and then Max in this
moment and never ever has used his voice
and the mom is tormented because this
guy's a chronic bullying victim never
spoke up ever so Max's his friend is now
being targeted and in that moment Max
says wow this I have to do something
because he stood up for me and it's not
right what he's doing so he stands up he
puts himself between the two kids and
Max says as instructed verbatim if you
have a problem with him you have a
problem with me
and the bully goes and he just turns and
he walks away
and Max's mom came to me the next day
with her private class in Jiu Jitsu and
she says Henry you have no idea what
this means we celebrated when we got
home and you have no idea what this
means for me I've put on 60 70 pounds in
the last year dealing with the bowling
issues because if I have to worry about
him every single day I can't worry about
me so the fact that he did what he
learned a hundred percent has taught and
it worked perfectly he found his inner
strength he found his voice and now that
he can focus on him I can focus on me so
this is why we do it right but the
contextual relevance mattered to Max
because it was so specific the struggles
he was having and then his ability to
overcome that his life will never be the
same he now knows it on the other side
of asserting yourself verbally to a
bully
most likely will be not a fight
especially if you bring the fire and you
bring the conviction and the skills that
he brings most likely the bully doesn't
want to fight because if they did they
would just punch you in the face they're
gonna go they want the easy target so
when you show that you're that hard
target it's not going to continue and in
Max's cases that's what happened the mom
was like over the moon so that's what I
hope to provide every beginner it's not
like and you see in BJJ there's this
attitude of oh survival of the fittest
If You Can't Hang then it's not for you
Jiu Jitsu is not for everyone right
these are all random projections on the
art that people who've joined the train
along the way are making up about this
like yeah this is only for the Only the
Strong Survive and I'm like this is
crazy the very art that wasn't designed
to empower the weak
those people are precluded from learning
it largely because of the culture that
exists in so many of these schools and
it's again it's kind of sad when you
think about it because who really needs
it isn't getting access to it
um a lot of times when I talk about Jiu
Jitsu from a self-defense perspective
one of the things that plays a huge part
is
if you do Jiu-Jitsu you are used to
people grabbing you you're used to the
physical contact you're used to the
grind you used to and if someone grabs
you you're not used to that
you don't even know what to do like
you're it takes you seven seconds just
to contemplate and and comprehend what's
going on whereas if you do Jiu Jitsu
someone grabs you you actually are 100
comfortable and okay with it and you
have a plan you know what you're gonna
do you're gonna make something happen
there's no there's no psychological
barrier that you have to break through
to start reacting to it so that's a huge
part of it
I mean a lot of times I'm sure if you've
never been grabbed by someone before
your immediate response is just to
freeze up mentally freeze the other
thing that I like to say
you know I'll get asked this question
you know okay if you are a 110 pound
woman and you get you get assaulted by a
220 pound guy
can that woman really stop that guy from
let's say dragging her into a van right
the classic whatever horrible scenario
can this 110 pound woman stop this 220
pound guy from grabbing her and pulling
her into van
first of all what you already mentioned
is part of it
if that guy approaches her and he sees
that she's gonna be a problem
he's probably when you when they do
interviews with with perpetrators they
always say they're looking for a victim
that looks like a victim that's what
they're looking for they're not looking
for a hard time
number two
can a 110 pound woman stop a 220 pound
man from grabbing her and put in her car
there's a decent chance she can't
there's a decent chance she can't but
let me tell you what she can do first of
all she can make it a problem he's
probably going to avoid her if he
decides no this is the one
she is going to make that evolution
last
12 seconds longer yes 19 seconds longer
seven seconds longer 30 seconds longer
it is going to be a totally different
story and that seven seconds is what it
took for a passerby to see a license
plate that's seven 20 seconds is what it
took for a police uh car to roll by that
nine seconds is what it took for a
bystander that was watching that saw
this suspicious thing happening go and
intervene in the situation so
that that time that you will buy
yourself it could literally be the
difference between being abducted or not
being abducted and it's the same thing
with a little kid you know when you've
got little kids when they know how when
they know what they're doing it can take
an extra like go try and grab my
daughter like go try and grab my
daughter and pull her into a van good
luck dude you're gonna have problems
you're probably getting choked to be
honest with you so so that just just to
let people know that yes it gives you
because it gives you the confidence
and you talked about hey it's this sort
of confidence that you have and the way
you carry yourself which
you know I remember seeing um
you know like self-defense videos in the
80s right and you know it'd be a woman
that would be you know no no no it was
kind of a kind of became like a thing
right this loud voice this assertive
voice
and yeah sure that's gonna work some of
the times
but you need to have more than that and
and that's what these techniques will
give you maybe look there's a decent
chance that someone you know you you
react correctly a perpetrator just goes
dude I'm out here I don't this is what
I'm looking for
but if they are determined it's going to
cost them time and that time could very
well be the difference between a license
plate being seen on someone else
intervening you that person just saying
oh I'm not putting up with this so very
important to think about that is the
woman empowered is that a course is that
a is that the same thing are we talking
check marks yep it's exactly the same
every beginner course is the same in the
sense there's a card there's a 20
techniques women empowered is 20
techniques
four check boxes next to every class and
your goal is to fill in those boxes over
time every month the lessons cycle again
and again no experience for any one of
these classes it's available online for
those who don't have a school near them
and we have women all over the world
doing with their sisters their mom their
husbands learning these techniques as
early as 12 13 years old 14 years old
they're doing this because that's how
early this is a problem right for these
young girls so 100 it's the same thing
but I love what you're saying because
there's an absolutist
kind of cohort of men online largely men
who go that would never work like we'll
show a self-defense technique of me and
Eve on Instagram and like try that
against a 200 pound guy that would never
work and there's like an absolutist
approach which is if you can't beat up
this man and submit him in time into a
pretzel then what's the point of
learning Jujitsu and I love what you're
talking about because we explain this
concept of the bystander intervention
score in fact when a perpetrator is
selecting a Target
he's selecting the target as much as for
who the target is as what the
opportunity around that Target presents
so he's looking for the low chance of
bystander intervention if you're in a
grocery store and I'm standing shoulder
to shoulder to someone and the
perpetrator is right there and there's
people walking by the opportunity to
carry out that assault is so limited
because the chance of bystander
intervention is so high same exact
perpetrator same exact potential Target
put them on the path to the car from the
grocery store to the car and he's
waiting in the car right next to hers no
one else is there it's 10 o'clock at
night there's only the checkout guy and
you in the parking lot that's a whole
different opportunity so he's more
likely to act in that situation and
you're right his determination to take
action in that moment is a function of
his belief that the chance of bystander
intervention is very low and if that's
the criteria for why he's choosing to
attack in that moment what you're saying
is accurate in the sense that you don't
have to beat him up you simply have to
delay his successful strategy whatever
he has planned you have to delay that
law long enough to where he concludes
that the chance of bystander
intervention is Rising by the second for
two reasons number one you're slowing
down the progression of the assault by
making Base by going to the ground by
tangling up his leg by tripping him in
the process again I'm not beating him up
I'm just preventing his outcome from
being achievable and then number two
you're drawing attention by yelling at
the same time you don't even need a
bystander to come you need that attacker
to conclude that intervention is highly
likely and if he concludes that he's out
and this is the best advice for women is
like you don't have to beat the guy up
you simply have to convince him in that
moment that you're more headache than
what he expected he wants the attack to
be fast and quiet so what does that mean
let's go slowly and let's go as loudly
as possible and a lot of the techniques
we teach are based on this understanding
and just think of what a reduction in
burden this place is on the student
right in this case we're talking about
women in sexual assault but think think
about what a reduction in burden this
place is on someone when they understand
that victory in a fight isn't
necessarily beating someone up
Victory is preventing Effectiveness
against you that's a big difference
that's a big change in like the marker
because people think of martial arts
historically what do they think oh yeah
Punch Kick annihilate chop poke his
throat rip his heart out of his chest
he's like you gotta annihilate and kill
someone to win that fight but what we
learned through Jujitsu is right if you
don't lose the fight if you didn't die
if you didn't get abducted
and it's someone larger and stronger
than you then you won if two people
fight and nobody wins who won that fight
I asked this question to group classes
all the time two people fight nobody
wins who won the smaller person the
person who was supposed to be
annihilated prevailed in preventing the
larger stronger attacker from
accomplishing their objective and most
schools don't teach this mindset the
mindset is go go go go go go submit
annihilate sweep get on top dominate
even within Jujitsu such that you're
creating this mentality around people
learning it for self or applying it in
self-defense where if they don't win the
fight they lost where no I think people
should start with no if you survive and
you don't lose you won over time you
develop your skills so highly that you
can tie someone in a pretzel with one
arm and it's no big deal and he could be
a big guy it's just it's a joke right
after at the level that we're at but
early on think about what a reduction in
burden that is for a practitioner to
know that the bar for success in this
martial art is simply survived rival in
the ways that you're talking about I
love that
so that's that's the women empowered we
have
the the Gracie survival tactics
and and and then the the bully proof now
the bully proof that's a curriculum as
well like that's a card type thing yeah
it's a card type thing it's an online
course I say all the same these all
these beginner programs it's the entry
portal to jiu jitsu for people in our
brick and mortar School in Torrance at
all of our certified training centers
and um and hundreds of thousands of
people online learning parent teaching
child the Gracie bully proof online
curriculum is very much teaching the
parent how to interact with the child
the way that I was interacted with with
my parents growing up it was a game we
call these the Gracie games these
techniques that kids learned very early
on and then what happens is you learn
these Gracie Games you start building
playfulness about Jiu Jitsu once you
have that relationship with it now we
teach you really the use the Rules of
Engagement because it's one thing to
teach kids techniques and not know when
and how to use them rule number one
avoid the fight at all costs rule number
two if physically attacked defend
yourself rule number three if verbally
attacked follow the three t-steps talk
tell tackle rule number four never Punch
or kick the bully establish control and
negotiate rule number five when applying
submissions use minimal force and
negotiate they have to memorize and
internalize this and once we see a child
has that then they go into the junior
combatives program which is also online
they do these techniques at home they're
learning more advanced adult type
techniques and then they're just growing
and then eventually when the parent
thinks the child is ready they evolve
into our Gracie combatives and then our
Master cycle kind of advanced adult
curriculum and kid could be 12 years old
and is learning adult curriculum with
their parent from home now now hold on a
second how do you know anything about
getting bullied holy cow bro good
question or is this inherent in the
Gracie no household yeah so so people
think that because I'm a Gracie that oh
you guys family of Legends Fighters you
never got bullied and um they're wrong
they're wrong and and the reality is the
bully was in the house
hiron was the bully my older brother
that's two years older brother bro
because he seemed so super freaking nice
listen they explain the keep it playful
movement okay this came way later in his
life he was not playful when he was 11.
bro it was nuts so he comes out of the
womb
23 months later I came out
that's a big difference that's a big
advantage that's a big head start in the
race in a family of intense physical
practice and Jujitsu and fighting from
day one so he has essentially two more
years of shujitsu at every phase of my
life so we're growing up in this crazy
family Fighters everywhere
um doing our thing and he's just beating
me up you know normal brother stuff and
then we're getting older and it's
happening you know whatever kind of
frequently there and everything's kind
of okay just beats me up when he gets
mad he gets pissed off let it out on
Henner because how like the next brother
in the lineup was just too much younger
it was like abusive but we're like I was
tall and we're kind of you know whatever
close in age so he would just beat me up
there was a time
when our uncles were there there's a
very famous picture of all the uncles in
front of a house on the grass in front
of a small little garden that's the
Torrance red beam house we're talking
the machados the hanzu Hoist hoyler my
dad when they all came here for the
famous Chuck Norris seminar where Chuck
recruited my dad to bring some Gracies
and they all went and they were all
staying at our house on Red beam and
they were all there and it was so cool
to have all these Legends right most
people have Idols they admire and heroes
they were all my uncles they were my
grandfather they were in my family so
the guys I admired most were all there
and you guys he don't freaking got me
and beat me up so bad and I don't know
if it's because
you know they were there that he like
felt this testosterone bump of like yeah
I'm badass too like these are my uncles
but I'm the man and I got the short end
of the stick and he just ripped into me
and beat me up and sadly so what is this
like you guys were happy but you guys
are having like lunch you guys are all
hanging out and all of a sudden he just
hits a double so here's the thing here's
the thing here's the thing how old are
you I'm we're I'm nine he's 11. okay
right so or like 10 and 12. so the
problem is is that I'm pretty sharp
intellectually and verbally
Heaton is less sharp in both of those
categories but more physical
very sharp and very athletic and very
strong and very good at Jiu Jitsu
relative to me at the time
and just older and stronger and heavier
and bigger but the point is the way
these things kind of went is there was I
was not innocent in every encounter I
wasn't just minding my business doing
homework and I get beat up right like I
was a little sharp with the tongue and I
would say
but at the end of the day my finals my
final play was always one of
intellectual you know like making him
feel stupid right and then his final
play was all right you want to do that
and you're going to get it cool so I
wasn't entirely interesting but the
point is it escalated and I got beat up
so badly and they were all there so the
shame was 11 times what it would have
been because all my Idols were there and
I was laying on the floor and he's
beating me up and I'm just he left and
I'm laying on the floor crying like in
the fetal position and I remember
thinking to myself
I have been busy many times and he's
done this other times for different
reasons and to different degrees but I
will never forgive him for this one
it's one of the most profound feelings
I've ever had as a kid like that I
wanted to hold forever nine years old I
will never forgive I will forget a lot
of things this one I remember thinking
on the floor crying there's nothing that
will happen ever that will allow me to
forgive him for this incident right now
in front of my uncles at the house on
this fateful Tuesday morning and red
Beam Avenue in Torrance California
and you know that was it and I held on
to that and I held on to that and I held
on to that and you know we thought of
many other times nothing as remarkable
as this one although there was one time
when we were like 13 and 15 we were
playing on this trampoline before they
had the Nets right the crazy trampolines
back in the day didn't have the Nets and
we were fighting and he freaking let me
have it on the trampoline thought it was
cool like a UFC octagon and he beat me
up on the trampoline and then he jumps
off the trampoline to leave after I'm
crying on the freaking trampoline Lane
there so as he's getting off and he just
let me have it Relentless beating me up
because older brothers can do that he's
walking off I run from the trampoline
he's on the grass walking I run I jump
off the trampoline with both legs
horizontal
and I spike him in the back between his
shoulder blades sending him flat onto
his face on the Grass full face plant
and shocked like Whiplash like you
wouldn't imagine falls on his face and I
let him have it with everything I had
and by the time he got up I was in the
kitchen hugging my mom's leg mom
eat out loud he turns around and goes he
don't stop and she yells at him in the
kitchen and he freezes and like you can
see it in his face and it was one of
those but I just that was one where I
came back with the Vengeance and
violence and uh and then our parents
divorced
and they they said who do you want to
live with and I said I want to this is
like months later years later it was
this thing right they divorced and I
said I want to live with my dad and all
other four of my siblings chose to live
with my mom
so I move out with my dad move out and
that's kind of the end of us beating
each other up because there's not one on
each other's neck all day so we're still
working together teaching every night
right now I'm do at the at the Academy
we're doing our thing and then one day
we're training I'm 17 he's 19.
downstairs old old Academy Carson Street
the original Steve Bailey Academy and
we're freaking doing our thing over
there and we're sparring and this is
still when we think like we're going
there's got to be Fighters This is
Gracie family we got to go hard and
we're training crazy just him and I in
the room completely alone I had never
once submitted him in my whole life ever
so we're training 17 and 19 and I'm
freaking going hard and he freaking
guard I jump up a try he pulls I go for
an armor he jumps up he pulls out of an
arm bar leaving one arm in for the
triangle I locked the triangle but I
have long legs and he's kind of thin
like I am so he goes to pull out of the
triangle hiding his arm like shrugging
to slip that out of the center area
and it gets stuck and I grab his wrist
like Fedor uh verdum and I armbar him in
the triangle and he
and I swear to God I looked around
nobody was watching and there was no
cameras right so I was like did anybody
see that nobody and I was like no
and right away didn't no emotion on his
face shake hands bump fist he beat me 10
more times right there in 10 minutes and
then but what was impossible
was not possible
everything changed haven't you rolled
with people that were unbeatable to you
and in your mind you thought they're
simply unbeatable and then you crack the
code and then just once and you go holy
cow and you roll with them differently
on the other side of that momentary
Victory where you go okay it might not
be all the time but it's possible and
then the ratio started changing 10 Taps
to one and then out of ten I would get
two and then out of ten I would get
three and now out of ten like nobody
wins five times
and of the five where somebody wins
he'll get me three and I'll get him two
you feel me like we're close like I'm
pretty good yeah so and then what
happens is I'm just waiting now because
there will come a day where two years
Advantage becomes two years
disadvantaged over like 57 and 59 I'm
like let's go and I'll get him so I got
bullied in the household and when I got
bullied at school to hideon's defense he
did help and back me up when it happened
and he'd almost say like I tell this
story all the time and he laughs and
yeah now Hannah's tough because of all
that beating and this and that and the
other but I know a thing or two about
you know having what you feel is you
violated and the importance of setting
boundaries and standing up for yourself
and it's a real thing for me
and by the way the whole not forgive him
forever
once we freaking took the Helm of the
ship together when hoist left and we
took over the family business and we
were running it and we created Gracie
University and we write these
curriculums and we're spending countless
hours together documenting all of the
Jujitsu that we've ever learned
it became clear that it was freaking him
and I and we're taking this all the way
you know and he's been such a loyal and
hard-working and reliable pillar and I
feel like we were up against so much
scrutiny and with a lot of these
initiatives online licensing doing these
things you know Gracie combative's belt
who are you guys to change the way
things are like there was so much
scrutiny from the outside that I
strongly believe that even though these
were all great moves and I in many ways
I was I was I was kind of the the the
the the brain behind the engineering of
some of these if not for hiron standing
right next to me saying hell yeah let's
go I got you this I love this let's do
this together
I don't know if my Standalone pole in
the wind would have been able to
withstand that level of public scrutiny
um but two of us it was like Wow yo it's
not just she's right here let's go so
knowing that all we've built would only
be made possible with both of us I went
no we're good like we're good we're good
so did you did he ever say anything
about it or do you just have the mutual
understanding that what the tap out or
the beating me up uh the beating you up
and being like hey man
he never apologized but he'll very make
very clear that I'm as tough as I am
because of him today
so he's actually he's actually taking
credit for it
it's classic Tito's not very sentimental
so the point is but it's all love and
man I just he's everything and more that
I could have asked for in a brother and
I I just I feel I'm so lucky and I feel
like
people who don't have what we have you
know it's it's just a different
existence it's it's now we have kids
together so when we first shot Gracie
Bulletproof the DVDs 14 years ago the
first kids program that we put out we
borrowed other kids like five-year-old
or seven-year-old a 12 year old an
eight-year-old so we literally last week
and that's why we're waiting kids so now
we have children I have a four and a
seven-year-old he has an eight and a 10
year old so literally when Jack asked me
to do the podcast with you guys or
reached out to schedule last Friday is
what he proposed I said Jack I can't
we're filming we shot last week after 14
years Gracie bulletproof 2.0 with our
own children nice so the whole program
revamped and we did it together and the
kids had the best time and it was just a
big bonding for us as fathers now of
kids he has two daughters I have two
sons and I wouldn't have it any other
way
uh speaking of principles I learned a
principle from Jeff Higgs who you
apparently defeated uh by choking but
Jeff is awesome but one of the things he
told me one time is like if you ever
catch someone that you don't normally
catch
you have to like next roll you gotta be
going 110 because they are gonna
freaking go ham on you and it sounds
like that's what Heron did to you oh
yeah and there was nothing I could do
about it like it was straight up and you
know I just I found the Kink and I just
I knew it was possible and there was a
big change in the psyche right there
when I knew he was beatable I was like
dude that's crazy because 17 years like
you guys started as adults so your races
are with other adults who are other
it wasn't even in my makeup that this
would ever happen
so it was a big breakthrough and um
that's hard to imagine because honestly
that's I think that's when I forgave him
honestly I think I forgave him for the
beating when I became boom I'm here I'm
tough I'm badass too like you and he
started respecting me and he never beat
me up there's no more at 17 18 19 we
were already older and we had so much
other things to worry about as a united
front to run this business and take it
to the world that I think that was the
moment honestly where I went holy cow
he's human like me and it's all good um
we mentioned Gracie's Revival tactics
and I think this is important a lot of
law enforcement listen to this podcast
and this is a huge
topic and in in the current environment
that we're in right now
where did Gracie survival Tactics come
from where is it right now yeah honestly
it traces back to the Rodney King
incident right early 90s when
um you know that happened and then LAPD
right afterwards contacted the family
and said hey we need help kind of
revamping our defensive tactics program
so they created a civilian expert panel
of civilians uh to come together of
different disciplines my father being
one of them and to suggest that
different ideas and what can we do and
of course
um you know law enforcement use of
forest became under high scrutiny not
just for LA but Nationwide and at that
point there became this demand for hey
how can we control people in less
violent ways and with greater degrees of
Effectiveness so Jiu Jitsu happened to
be kind of on its rise right then UFC
one like 93 94 95 and it was like it was
a known thing so it got us into some
rooms and my father started it was
called grapple initially Gracie
resisting attack procedures for law
enforcement and it uh the police
officers started going for it and little
by little I was brought up around that
era teaching a lot of classes assisting
a lot of classes and then one day my
father and I were set to schedule or
scheduled to teach a course in the early
2000s scheduled a teacher course in
Texas Arlington Texas near Dallas and he
couldn't make it was had a situation
with health situation with his family
and he said Henry you're going to go
teach us and I was like 19 years old and
he's like Henry you're going to go run
this yeah 19. 2002. he said you're gonna
go run this GST this Gracie survival
tactics course had since changed the
name
and I'm like sweating bullets I'm gonna
go to a room full of law enforcement
trainers in Texas they expect horion
Gracie the creator of the UFC to show up
and some kids going to show up teenager
to run a class full of grown men who've
been teaching in law enforcement for
decades some of them and I think it was
like 60 50 60 guys in the room and I'm
like oh my gosh this is the worst thing
imaginable
so I show up in Texas the host is
Charlie Fernandez great guy and still
works with us to this day and I say
Charlie you know my dad's not coming
he's like oh I said yeah you know he had
to stay home so I'm running it he goes
all right Henry let's give it a shot
let's get out there and see what they
say so I show up in front of everybody
and I say guys I know you were all
expecting My Father Here
um
he's not coming here there's a health
condition for his family and he had to
stay so here's what I promise you
this will be the most productive
and rewarding
training course you've ever taken of any
kind in your entire law enforcement
career
and if not you just tell me on the last
day
and I'll give you your money back
it doesn't have to be a second day
Let's Have Some Fun by the first day I
learned everyone's first name in the
room by literally the first six hours so
I was connecting with everybody full
full force go go go go go amazing
techniques amazing week the whole thing
taught the class every day connecting
more with them they're accepting me they
love the teaching I knew what I was
doing right and these these are all
white belts for right they're a girl
they're adults but they're white belts
and I'm a black belt at the time so life
is good so I teach the whole class on
the last day
I line them all up and I spar with all
of them I think it was 50 guys I spar
with every single one of them everybody
taps
and it was like 30 seconds 14 seconds 27
seconds one minute right back to back to
back to back to back it was a good
workout
tap all these guys and then after I do
that and then I say
okay guys thanks for coming you know
here's your certificates
does anybody want their money back
not one claim their money back and that
was the last GST course my father ever
taught
so from that at 19 years old I'm taking
over this program that is kind of the
the teaching of Jiu Jitsu to law
enforcement and it just it just ramped
up I'm traveling every month typically
every single month a week a month to go
teach a course to some state in the
Union here and teaching techniques and
certifying trainers so for those who
don't know we train the trainers every
agency has a defensive tactics
instructor or two or five or Twenty
depending on the size and then we go
certify these instructors in about 40
hours they learn these core techniques
23 techniques in level one there's a
level two course that teaches additional
17 techniques 40 techniques altogether
so I'm teaching these courses certifying
these trainers but what the world
doesn't know what America doesn't know
is that once a trainer gets certified by
someone like us they go back to their
agency and then they train their
colleagues but the amount of training
permitted in police agencies across the
country
is disastrously
embarrassingly low
on in most agencies if you had to
average the whole country I would guess
just from anecdotally I would guess it's
about
two hours a year that the average police
officer the end user not these trainers
that we're working with but their
colleagues it's about two hours a year
of training that they're getting in
these Hands-On skill sets
and
that's laughable it's not it's barely
even laughable some states have a zero
annual training requirement California's
requirement for example is four hours
every two years horrible so what the
problem that this creates in law
enforcement is that when a a use of
force incident occurs and you have an
officer that engages with the subject
goes Hands-On
and
quickly escalates their level of force
to what is often perceived as excessive
force
the general public is very quick to make
the determination that that was an
abusive escalation and a deliberate
escalation of force based on their power
advantage that this officer has
but what I'd caution everyone to to kind
of know and consider is that in many of
these cases
the officers are escalating their level
of force not in all of them right
because there are some bad apples there
are officers who shouldn't be police
officers who do abuse the force and the
power that they have but in many cases
the officers are escalating because
they're having an amygdala hijack right
they're they're losing control of their
prefrontal cortex and they're operating
in their lizard brain fight flight
freeze and they're panicking and when
they panic because they only got zero
one or two hours a year of a skill set
designed to mitigate this type of
physical encounter
when they panic in that situation
they're going to escalate very rapidly
to the levels of force that they train
more regularly right so many agencies
have their officers qualify with their
pistol every month or at least every
quarter right to hit the target and make
sure they're on point for liability
purposes they want to make sure that
those officers are dialed in there so
naturally when push comes to shove what
are you going to resort to your taser
right your baton your pepper spray your
firearm you're going to resort to those
tools that you're training more
regularly so it's just so sad that right
in all these cases where these officers
are escalating these they're forced so
rapidly and the public is now
scrutinizing them so heavily because
every incident is being recorded on 17
cameras so to be clear officers have
always been this poorly trained right it
wasn't better 17 years ago we just
didn't see it 25 years ago it was worse
we just didn't see it so now that we
have this wave of new uh accountability
from the general public and visibility
for the general public right there is
what the general public perceives as a
an appropriate level of force based on
the threat the officer is presented with
and and listen people aren't saying that
cops should not be using force and
people should that suspects and
criminals do not need to be handled
sometimes aggressively and sometimes
with high levels of force no one's
saying that but there is when you see an
incident take place and you have a
teenage girl who's 14 years old who's
prone doubt outside of a mall that she
was accused of shoplifting and you have
a cop on her back punching her in the
side of the head because she wouldn't
pull her arms out and put it behind her
back and this cop is 240 pounds and the
woman the girl is 110 pounds and he's
punching her or an elderly person in a
similar situation when people people see
this
what do they feel
they feel that the cop is Right
deliberate and excessive and abusive
with their power and in some cases they
are but I would go so far to say that in
many of the cases these officers who
escalate this level of force are doing
so because they don't have lower less
violence less aggressive means of
accomplishing the desired outcome
because they're panicking and for all of
us as well right we train so that we
don't panic but all of us are in in
areas where we are not experts and we
are not investing in those skills we're
all equally prone to panic in some other
environment if you ask me to cook
Thanksgiving dinner for 20 people I'm
going to start sweating bullets because
I don't have the training in that
capacity but to know that we're sending
officers into these physical encounters
but yet we're giving them two hours a
year it's the biggest lie in law
enforcement that these officers are
sufficiently trained and it's a terrible
disservice to the officers because now
they're in they're not equipped to go
out there and do it safely for them and
their families for the agencies it's an
incredible liability and for the
civilians you're now getting arrested by
an officer who in literally all you have
to do is rip away from a grip and you
just flipped that officer's switch
because they're panicking and now
they're going to do everything necessary
within the law to neutralize and subdue
you and this all came to a head in
Marietta Georgia
a couple years ago when there was an
incident at an IHOP where an officer
a number of officers were trying to
arrest the guy who was unhappy with the
breakfast experience there push came to
shove and they dogpiled the guy and
they're ripping away and they let him
have it right the typical dog pile but
excessive force in the pile punching him
from every angle and even though he was
resisting arrest right like it was
justifiable that they had to go Hands-On
they had to take him down it didn't look
good so there was an inciting incident
on the watch of Marietta Police
Department in Georgia and this is an
agency that we had been we had been
interacting with from a GST Gracie
survival tactics trained the trainer
perspective for 11 or 12 years so their
trainers were trained by us but
it fell apart when they go back and they
teach their officers an hour a year or
two hours a year so it it's one thing to
say the trainers have been trained it's
another to have the officers be prepared
in this capacity so this inciting
incident happens in Marietta Georgia The
Command Staff initial knee-jerk reaction
was what what the heck is wrong with
these officers why do they do this why
do they do that so they want to get
upset at the guy but the problem is they
looked in the mirror and they said wait
a minute
the guy got two hours of in-service
last year 18 months ago was his last
in-service block whatever 12 months ago
how can we hold them accountable for
what the training that they never
received
let's be honest so at that point they
said let's pilot something
because I have been advocating for as
long as I've been running this program I
had been advocating look it's a joke
we're all here doing this and I'll sit
in the room with 100 officers who are
trainers and I'll say guys this is all a
joke right we all know that you guys are
going to get certified go back and it's
all going to fall apart because you're
only going to be given two hours because
your Chief is too scared to and always
the excuse is what we don't have the
money we don't have the money to train
these officers two hours a week we don't
have the and workers comp we're scared
of injuries of the officers on training
so we don't want to put them in any
physical encounters not realizing that
if they don't train when they get in the
use of force in the field they're more
likely to injure themselves so it's it's
one of these so I have always heard the
reasons why Command Staff will not
approve regular weekly training my
recommendation is the minimum one hour
per officer per week in America
everywhere and that's like barely
scratching the surface twice two hours a
week is what it actually should be let's
be honest you lift twice a week you do
you you everything you do if you do a
thing you better do it twice a week or
you don't do that thing right that's
just the known you don't if you don't
surf twice a week you're a surfer used
know how to surf but you're not a surfer
if you don't do shoots twice a week
you're not doing Jiu Jitsu so anyways
I've always said this but I've always
get roadblock click Henry they will
never proof they'll never prove so
Marietta who had been known as for 11 12
years decided we're gonna pilot a
program where we're going to get new
police recruits and we're going to allow
them to train at a local civilian-owned
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu School carefully
vetted Brazilian Jews to school where
they can do regular classes couple
nights a week after their Police Academy
training throughout the day and let's
see how this goes they put these
recruits through that the recruits that
came off the line were very clear
the most confident the most mentally
prepared and well-adjusted right to deal
with altercations than any class that
had ever come off the line they go out
in the field and within weeks and months
they're using the T the techniques that
they had learned in Jiu Jitsu simple
clean takedowns arrests and Senior
senior officers are looking saying yo
where'd you learn that and they're like
yo that's practice last week like this
is this is what we do this is a jiu
jitsu super chill so it was so
successful with the recruits this kind
of pilot study that they said let's open
this to the entire agency let's let
every officer who wants to train Jiu
Jitsu on the Department's dime and they
did it 95 out of 145 officers opted in
to this training program at this Jujitsu
School in Marietta under the Command
Staff there and the data that came back
18 months later
is the data that I've been waiting for
for 25 years since we've been teaching
law enforcement it's the data that every
police chief in America needed to hear
to
neutralize their very much
closed-mindedness to jiu jitsu so 95 out
of 145 18 months pass the injuries
officer injuries in the 18 months
following the commencement of BJJ as a
regular supplemented practice every week
18 months the workers comp injuries for
officers in use of force Encounters in
the field went down by 48 agency-wide so
you have historical workers comp data 48
reduction in the following 18 months
number one number two oh by the way
of the 95 officers who opted in and the
other 50 officers who did not 100 of the
workers comp claims came from the non-ju
Jitsu training officers so the 95
officers who opted in in that 18-month
window no workers comp claims zero were
attributed to their injuries there
weren't any to report
so what does it tell you all you got to
do is get the other 50 officers on board
like and you should pull no punches to
make that happen because that's how much
safer it is 53 reduction in injuries to
civilians in use of force encounters
when the officer was one of the BJJ
population the untrained officers were
more than twice as likely to hospitalize
a civilian in a use of force encounter
that this is common sense to us but
there was never data to substantiate it
to the chiefs of America who need
numbers to make actions right 59
reduction in use of force encounters at
all they studied a shift of officers
where it went from officers who knew no
jiu jitsu and they completely switched
out that shift with officers who
practice Jujitsu the entire shift and
the use of force incidents overall went
down by 59 so anecdotally they're saying
wait a minute so you're saying not only
are they less injurious to themselves
into civilians they're less likely to
have a use of force encounter if they
know Jiu Jitsu of course first for all
the reasons we already explained you can
de-escalate verbally and you can set
boundaries when you're capable of
enforcing them so they're like cannot
believe this data now it's only 145
officers so we'll call it a relatively
small I've seen six officer agencies and
12 officer agencies but this is a
relatively small agency
sixty six thousand dollars in change
saved in workers comp claims that never
happened
this is one of my favorite numbers
because this was the number that I can
now go back to every police chief
whoever said Henry it's too expensive
because the cost of the training during
this same period was twenty six thousand
dollars two thousand six hundred classes
at ten dollars a class for this
particular relationship 26 to 26 000
they had taken 2 600 classes one
reported training injury what's a crack
nose when one of the guys was rolling
zero workers comp claims attributed to
the training at this agency and on the
in the civilian sector in the civilian
training and they're in there with
civilians in the regular classes bonding
with civilians building that Community
relationship so all kinds of unintended
and we don't know what lawsuits were
avoided as a result of this training
being in place so what additional
savings this is only the measurable
savings so now twenty six thousand
dollars take it off the top of the 66k
that you saved from fewer injuries to
officers because they're not clumsy in
their uses of force and we look at a net
savings a net profit of forty thousand
dollars for the agency at the end of all
this in more than paid for itself
so this is the type of relationship
Police Department
civilian-owned Jujitsu Academy where the
officers need to be sent to train with
civilians on a regular basis funded by
the agency this to me is the future of
law enforcement in America every single
I think between 10 and 15 years from now
any agency that is not engaged in a
privatized partnership like this
is is we're talking archaic it's like yo
you guys are still in the two four six
hours a week what's wrong with or six
hours a year crazy like so and what's
Wild is we just signed contracts in
Southern California Manhattan Beach
Police Department is the neighboring
city of Torrance and El Segundo Police
Department two neighboring cities May
1st they both started on this exact same
deal all of their officers permitted to
train at Gracie University are
headquarters paid for by the agency
every officer shows up they're wearing a
gee they're in classes with everyone
else and within I think it's May June
July so we're just two or three months
in over 33 percent of the agency
officers have already opted in this
short this Chief is blown away cannot
believe it and it's like hen are the
people that are opting in because of the
safety because of the structure because
of the curriculum design they feel safe
they're having a fun time learning they
all get video access so these officers
are engaging in that but what's Wild is
the chief didn't want to do it in the
beginning the chief said enter this goes
every against everything I feel to
Outsource this type of training because
historically in law enforcement it's a
very like closed off no everything's
behind closed doors how we train what we
do what we know who we let teach us and
who we let influence us very close
society and he said Henry we would
rather have this is in the initial
negotiations why don't you send me an
instructor and do the training in my
agency he asked send me your best guy
it's only down the street let them train
my officers at our Police Department I
said Chief listen to me right now
if we send you one of our officers best
I'm sorry one of our best instructors we
have many a dozen good instructors if we
send them every week twice a week to
teach your guys and gals here's what
will happen
because the room is full of police
officers who know each other and they're
training an environment familiar to them
and they're training with people
familiar to them
there's going to be this cop culture
that infects and permeates the mat and
it will prevent the progress that is the
type of progress that we want for these
officers for the officers that need it
most is not going to be possible they
will infect their own environment cop
culture the profanity on the mat the
disrespect one guy's a wrestler in high
school he's going to walk in and say hey
show you try that on me it's not going
to work and there's going to be this
attitude the whole program is going to
fall apart so let me just say this right
now please try this in this civilian
partnership kind of form give me six
months if it's not the best thing you've
ever done for the agency I will send you
one of my instructors six months from
now and we'll do it from that point on
if it works we keep going he said deal
we're three months in we're three months
in and last last Saturday two Saturdays
ago Chief Jaime Bermudez of the El
Segundo Police Department came to
Torrance at the Academy on a Saturday
morning
and he authorized
the pinning
of a Gracie triangle pin a bronze Gracie
triangle pin on the right
pocket uniform Duty uniform of Officer
Sergeant Alex Levitt the first officer
of El Segundo to complete 100 classes in
this partnership bronze pin is a hundred
classes silver pin is 200 classes gold
pin is 300 classes
we agreed there should be some extrinsic
motivator the same way they have
Marksmanship pins or your sergeant or
your SWAT pin recognize the thing that
you want people to care about and they
will care about it more so the pin got
awarded to officer Levitt two Saturdays
ago and he said this is the best thing
we've done he couldn't be more excited
about the partnership he's excited for
more officer Levitz working on his
silver pin now it's a little Gracie
triangle nothing on it just a triangle
and it's on the pin and he got this
approved by the city the whole thing
this Chief everything's official so now
you have El Segundo officers wearing a
Gracie pin driving around and I call it
the Gracie de-escalation pin and they're
so proud of it so this is the future of
law enforcement any agency that's not
doing this to me they're they're they're
they're pretending right they're like
playing they might be saying okay we're
doing our two hours a year and we're
doing Jujitsu and we're touching it but
until you enter this type of partnership
with the civilian owned school you're
never going to get the officers the
culture and the training environment
that they need to get these skills sharp
so that when officer Levitt encounters
it's just another day of class it's the
only way so we couldn't be happier with
it and I look forward to more of these
Partnerships and more agencies all over
the country
yeah this is so badly needed across the
country I've been begging for this for
years now
um especially like after the the George
Floyd incidents and all these things
that happened
man police need Jiu Jitsu 100 there's a
um
I also want to say this you know I
started off reading my little excerpt
and I described Jiu Jitsu as magic right
I'll let you use magic and I truly
believe it's magic but guess what
you have to learn it you have to train
it all the time it's not magic that you
can learn one time and now you got a
magic trick now you can use it it's
gonna work like no you actually have to
practice this magic in order for it to
work you can't just take two hours you
can't just take four hours you can't
just take six hours
you have to train on a regular basis you
know you put it out there as as uh two
hours a week I've been saying that
police officers should train
20 of their time and that's not just
pure Jiu Jitsu that's de-escalation
that's weapons that's legal procedures
you should be training 20 in the SEAL
Teams we would train for 18 months to go
on a six-month deployment
police officers train two four hours a
year when you say defensive tactics by
the way that a lot of time that includes
like their weapons handling they're
cuffing people when you're learning how
to cook people that's not easy that's
it's there's techniques to learning to
Cuff people into cuffing people properly
when they say four hours it includes
cuffing it includes like weapons
retention it includes all kinds of stuff
then you get this thing where you know
people ask me like oh have you ever used
Jiu Jitsu in combat and I'm like oh yeah
of course people are surprised by that
and they're surprised by that because
you know oh I've got a gun I've got you
know a primary gun I've got a secondary
gun I've got a bunch of friends with
guns I've got knives why would I have to
use Jiu Jitsu well it's because when you
enter into a building in Iraq there's
civilians in that building there's
people that are unarmed you can't just
go in and shoot everybody so you've got
to deal with these civilians how do you
do the civilians well you ask them to
get down sometimes they don't get down
sometimes they resist sometimes they're
scared sometimes they're frozen you have
to be able to put hands on people and
get control of them in a way that
doesn't hurt them that's what Jiu Jitsu
does there's a scary thing going on when
it comes to trying to subdue somebody
with strikes we we were taught a a
technique called a muzzle strike the
muzzle strike is you basically you have
your weapon and you you hit them in the
face
with your muzzle of your weapon which is
a very like sharp point right it's
putting a lot of intense pressure into a
very small area
and when we were taught this and look I
was already Jiu Jitsu I already
understood all this stuff they're
teaching like hey when you do this to
someone they're going down
and I knew that that was not true
because I punched a lot of people and
I've hit a lot of people and I've hit
people with blunt instruments before and
you don't always get a knockout in fact
you rarely get a knockout you very
rarely get a knockout so if your method
of subduing someone is to hit them in
the face with the muzzle of your weapon
or to hit them in the face with a baton
or to punch them in the face or strike
them in the face and you think that's
how you're going to get control of them
it just doesn't work and what was really
horrible about those muzzle strikes is
when that muzzle would hit somebody
would cause this acute wretch really
heinous acute damage so they get big
massive Cuts they're bleeding all over
the place they're scarred for life by
the way it didn't knock them out now
they're actually pissed and scared and
now they're fighting back even harder so
what does the practitioner do muzzle
strikes them again
so you end up muzzle striking someone
five six seven times all they're doing
is bleeding all over the place now you
still have to tackle them and try and
get control when you don't know Jiu
Jitsu so it's just a disaster jujitsu
you don't need any of that you can get
control of people without striking them
because striking is totally unreliable
now where are you at or what are you
hearing about chokes because there's
been a lot of
of departments that have completely
banned jokes of any kind and part of
this actually would say the vast
majority of reason for this is because
you have untrained people that were
trained for two hours they were taught a
choke now they're panicked because they
really don't have the skill set but they
remember how to put that choke on and
they put it on they squeeze it as hard
as they can they break somebody's
Hollywood bone in it and and they die
that terrible right if you if you know
Jiu Jitsu you know exactly what's
happening when you're choking someone
you feel them you feel them
um submit you feel them say oh I'm gonna
lose this fight or you feel them pass
out and by the way I've been choked out
I don't know how many times let me do
this is a normal thing you get choked
out the most beautiful thing about
getting choked out is you wake up and
everything's fine you can do it
absolutely you're normal you're 100
normal you're a little more humble but
your everything is the same you get you
get hit in the head with a baton seven
times before you finally get knocked out
you have a concussion for sure obviously
you have whatever kind of brain
contusion you have all kinds of risk of
getting killed by that you hit someone
wrong in the temple it you can kill
somebody very easily doing that
if you kill someone with a choke you
really you really made a huge mistake
and you don't understand what's
happening
or you intentionally did it it takes a
long time to kill someone of the choke
you can't kill someone with a choke in
five seconds they go to sleep in five
seconds they go to sleep in seven
seconds to kill them you have to
purposely choke them aggressively for a
couple minutes that's what you have to
do so what are you hearing right now
there's obviously a lot of resistance
against jokes what are you hearing right
now on the front yeah from police so I
was
very uh active in the defense of
vascular neck restraints right choke is
a bad word in law enforcement but we're
all talking about the same thing right
restricting the blood flow to and from
the brain loss of consciousness is met
you let them go you cuff him up best
thing imaginable the most valuable tool
imaginable for law enforcement please
don't take it away because you can take
my gun away in a fight but I can still
get your neck and I can still save your
life and my life if you allow me this
proven effective and very safe technique
so but that's spoken from a room of Jiu
Jitsu practitioners right and it's
always that's always the message from
people who train regularly to invest in
this skill set and know this technique
intimately the problem is we're talking
about a population of you know however
many you know hundred thousand tens of
thousands of officers in the country
right hundreds of thousands millions who
are getting that hour or two hours a
year and if one of those hours is here's
how you choke someone and all they
remember is wrap the neck and pull as
hard as you can when does it work what
happened what are the effects what is
the result what's the Aftercare
procedure if they don't have those
things dialed in it is more a liability
than an asset so for the longest time I
was of the opinion that because I'm
speaking from this Silo of Jiu Jitsu
expertise and you know how many times
how many chokes do we see on a regular
basis and how safely are they used
because we live in that world and we see
the millions of chokes on a daily basis
that are completely no long-term adverse
effects and are safely deployed and and
released when they're effective
it's a whole different perspective you
know so I just seen the amount of chokes
that were used incorrectly and just
generally listen what I've learned with
law enforcement is
you know they can't change too quickly
right that's kind of what I've learned
the hard way is like 25 years ago I was
like oh we got to be training twice a
week no nobody listening you know what
I'm saying so instead of saying screw it
I don't want to deal with you guys
anymore I'm not going to go teach law
enforcement anymore we kept doing it and
then Marietta a couple years ago has
this thing they'd finally do the model
that we've been touting for however long
in terms of regular weekly practice
and they have this glowing success and
now this influences others so the point
is you kind of have to move at the speed
of law enforcement which is a massive
institution and and it's very gradual so
um my point is
I advocate I used to Advocate much more
strongly than I do now and now I fall
into the lineup for example chokes for
offensive application these vascular
neck restraints are not part of GST
anymore because what I don't want is the
chief to come say ah GST they teach
vascular neck restraints as an offensive
tool can't do it in fact in California
uh I was on a I was on a zoom call with
the California post police peace officer
standards a training commission
about precisely this they said now that
we're taking out vascular neck
restraints by law you cannot teach them
as an offensive tool in California what
can we do instead of that and we were
there talking about like over under like
seat belt grip and there was like seven
or eight guys and on the call I was like
this you guys we're here all and I'm a
civilian everyone else is a cop and I
was invited by LAPD who we have a good
relationship with and I said you know
commission I said we're here talking
about choke and over under instead and
take this technique out
why is nobody talking about the real
problem here
which is the fact that post this
California Commission
mandates only four hours every two years
who are we fooling by pretending like
that is the acceptable training minimum
for an officer in California to go
Hands-On With a Civilian and we expect
them not to escalate their level of
force unreasonably in a moment of panic
can we shift the conversation away from
replacing the choke with an over under
and shift it to and the guy said to me
said Henner thank you for being here on
this call today he said uh if you want
to talk about that it's a much bigger
question and we should talk offline and
then boom we stepped offline and we
spoke privately and he said look Henry
like it's a gradual thing it's a
slow-moving ship and basically and we
were not post certified at that time
which means Gracie our program was not
endorsed by the state and basically his
without so much without so many words he
said Henry listen if you want to make a
difference get post certified for your
current program and then once you're in
you can make the change from within and
I talk about this in the book
um and I did just that and I I got
California post certified for Gracie
survival tactics soon after we got uh
State Certified in about 41 other states
um and it's just been amazing because
once you're State Certified based on the
state commission you uh officers can
come do your course without any problem
it's like yo if you go ask your Chief
Say Hey I want to go to the Gracie
course first question is it post
certified if the answer is yes go get it
have fun if it's not post certified
which we weren't for 20 plus years
oh but we don't have the budget and this
net but if it's post certified it checks
so many boxes in the states requirements
so to answer the question chokes neck
restraints I strongly support them but
um I've I've kind of put that sword down
and I said man it's not worth the fight
the whole country's moving one way and
public opinion as well by the way public
opinion supports a lot of the changes
that are being made you don't got the
public screaming out saying no let all
officers use neck restraints because
Jujitsu is safe and we need them to
strangle us instead of punching Us in
the head or beating us with a baton
they're not saying that because they
aren't educated so you have an
uneducated civilian population you have
an uneducated law enforcement population
about the safety and effectiveness of
these moves and then you have the little
Jiu Jitsu community in law enforcement
or guys like us who are kind of on the
edge of that Community saying this is an
amazing technique please keep it it's
like the wave came and went and now it's
not even talked about anymore it's not
taught in any of our programs as an
offensive tool but we do teach the
defenses to it so in that sense they're
doing it but they're doing it in the
right under their yeah well they have to
learn to defend themselves because
people people know how to exactly right
MMA and everyone's watching so everyone
and we've seen jokes we've seen officers
get choked and rear nakeds and the
officers don't know what to do so we
teach the defense and in that sense it's
part of the discussion but in a very
much the other side of it yeah I have a
question real quick uh is that for all
jokes like all what do you call it
vascular neck restraints yeah is that
for all of them like like a head and arm
choke for example anything yes now it's
the case where anything that prevents
blood flow to and from the brain is
considered a vascular neck restraint if
that's the intent of the move like an
arm triangle a triangle triangle a dark
anything if it's if it's intent is to
stop blood flow and to make them go
unconscious you're not seeing it taught
in law enforcement now there are a few
states in the middle of nowhere like out
there that they still have chokes at
what they call like an intermediate
level of force where it's able to be
used before firearm it's not considered
deadly force I've worked with some
departments where it's lethal Force
there you go and then there you go it's
lethal form so and that's kind of and
that's the thing is it's lethal force
and like I would be okay with that I
would be okay with the tool being
permitted to be taught so that if we're
in a fight and the suspect has a knife
or takes my gun that I could wrap his
neck put him to sleep handcuff him and
wake him up and save his life and save
my life in the process but there's some
agencies now and many states where they
say no you can't even teach it so you
could you could if the guy has a takes
your gun and is running towards someone
else you could run him over with your
car before you could neck restrain him
like it's crazy how restrictive it is
you understand like it's it's nuts well
there's a huge uphill battle to
re-educate the World on the the safety
of neck restraints and what's happened
in the last few years has done nothing
to help that because there's been people
that have died in terrible situations
and it's like oh yeah there's no one
that's standing up and saying no that's
that that looked great that was a super
move but if you have to come and arrest
me or you have to arrest someone please
just choke me so here's the joke so
here's the thing hear about you guys we
don't hear about the unremarkable uses
of force yeah right we hear about the
crazy this guy killed this guy what
about all the neck restraints which
there are countless in law enforcement
where they were successfully used to not
just the person stayed alive but it
saved lives it saved my life saved the
suspect's life because we used that tool
Arlington has a great example they enter
a house they're clearing rifles out SWAT
team the guy jumps on his bed the
suspect reached crawling towards his
headboard to reach in and get a hold of
something the SWAT officer throws he
slings his rifle he jumps on the bed
from Turtle position sinks in the
vascular neck restraint rear naked
squeezes puts the guy to sleep wakes him
up in cuffs there was a gun in the
headboard equation over there and he
saved both of their lives as a result of
not shooting him so we don't hear about
that that didn't make major news that
this guy's life was saved by a neck
restraint so
um yes in terms of re-education when
might this happen 10 to 15 years from
now when every agency has every officer
training two plus hours a week and there
are learning these in the civilian
sector and they're learning them safely
and how to deploy them and they're
capable someone in law enforcement is
going to bring back the discussion to
say look lives are being lost because
we're not having this tool can we please
get it back at it intermediate or even
at a lethal Force Level but let us learn
it and let us have our own judgment as
to when we use these techniques yeah and
if you learn them correctly you'll know
what's going on and you'll be calm and
you won't be freaking out because you're
training all the time and that's what
we're doing also the secondary effects
of this like you take a normal cop who's
under all kind of stress his family's
freaked out like things are going on and
you send them to Jitsu class
three times a week his whole life got
better he became a he's going to become
a better more relaxed more confident
more confident human being across the
board this is going to have so much
impact in in anywhere that picks this up
and starts moving in this direction and
you know what this my theory of 20 for
training that means you know you you
work for you work five days a week
and that means one of those whole days
one of those whole eight hour days is
training
who and people say well we can't afford
that because you know we we can't afford
we need people on the streets who would
you rather have on the streets
who would you rather have on the streets
a hundred cops during this shift that
never get trained or 80 cops that are
highly trained highly proficient highly
competent who do you want there's
something bad happening in your house
and you're going to have 10 officers
respond that haven't trained in three
years in nine months
or eight officers that have been
training 20 of the time it's a
no-brainer it's not even a question
everybody knows the answer to that
so there needs to be a mind shift that
it's not just about quantity getting
people out there the street it's how
well are they trained and training has
to be happening all the time it has to
be sustained uh and I'm happy to see
what you're doing yeah and listen it's
just a numbers game now you guys every
single agency like we have Marietta we
have El Segundo we have Manhattan Beach
we have other agencies around the
country that are engaging these
Partnerships all of them Marietta was
first and the first that I know of with
this type of prominent data but all of
them are producing data so naturally
what's going to happen is you're going
to be eventually you're going to be a
chief that looks at this and it's like a
deliberate uh indifference right you're
going to be you're going to be guilty of
not taking action when you could have
taken action to provide ample training
to your officers and this idea of two
hours a week to me is the biggest lie in
law enforcement is that cops are amply
trained to handle Hands-On encounters
effectively and because the LIE is so
widespread and the general public thinks
that officers are training I think if
you were to ask survey the general
public right this is and the Very very
general public and say hey how much
training would you say in a police
officer gets per year with their gun
they're going to say I don't know 10 20
hours a month how much training would
they get on Hands-On arrest and control
tactics same thing 10 20 hours a month
that's the problem because when the
public expectation is that they're amply
trained in that field or that activity
or that that skill set
but then the reality is so far from what
they expect it to be do you see how you
set up the public for such a massive
disappointment when the officer's
performance doesn't match their
expectation of whatever because when you
look at a police officer what do you see
nice boots nice uniform shiny stuff nice
car nice guns everything is in high
quality stuff so it's natural to think
they must have money to spend on the
things that matter boots uniforms cars
training learn how to use Hands-On
skills so you don't have to rip out your
taser too soon or your firearm too soon
that's the that's a reasonable
expectation from the public but what we
see is that's not the case so the
disappointment Factor when an officer
does escalate their level of force
whether it's right through abuse of the
force or whether it's through amygdala
hijack the Panic that ensues when you
simply aren't prepared to handle the
situation that disappointment Gap is so
massive and that is why the relationship
with between civilians and law
enforcement right now is at an all-time
low in the history of the world in
America for sure never has there been so
much distrust and and just lack of faith
and belief in what law enforcement is
capable of and a lot of these are rooted
on these violent videos where we look at
it and we go man that cop could have
handled that better every Jiu Jitsu guy
watches those videos and goes you got to
be kidding me
um at some point you know what's going
to change at some point some civilian
whose family member was killed shot
whatever run over
is going to sue their Police Department
because their police officers weren't
trained there you go and and once that
happens and I I would if I was on a jury
I'd give that all day long like you know
your your mother father brother son
whatever you know drunk shoplifting
mouthing off all of a sudden gets shot
and killed somebody's gonna go hey why
did you the kid wrestled in high school
of course you pushed him he did a double
leg what do you think he's gonna do like
there's gonna be a lawsuit like that and
the the police should lose that lawsuit
because if I was in charge and I had
police officers going out that were
supposed to be responsible for being
able to handle these scenarios and I
didn't train them I didn't role play
them I didn't put them in scenarios
where they're using simunition and
figuring out when they can actually pull
their weapon out or when they shouldn't
all those things the people are going to
it someone at some point is going to sue
these police departments for not
training their personnel properly and
there's going to be a seismic shift in
what's going on at least I agree and the
more this data exists with more agencies
the more the stronger the case right the
plaintiff will have in that um in that
situation I agree 100 it'll come to a
head you know but luckily there's
progress being made little by little
ages and what's crazy this is one last
thing on law enforcement and then we can
move on is that there's this General
belief lack of awareness I would say in
the general civilian Community regarding
what law enforcement is as an
institution people believe that law
enforcement is like a federal thing like
there's like police in America
and and then like the military right or
like the FBI or like a federal agency a
lot of people have no idea that every
single agency is its own independent
entity every single one so that means
that Torrance Manhattan El Segundo
Hawthorne California within five miles
of where we are there's seven different
agencies all of them have their own
chief that decides what their own
officers are going to do so literally
they're whatever is 18 I don't know how
many 18 20 000 agencies in America every
single one of them has to make the
decision to step in this direction and I
think it's important that the general
public know that because then they
realize that when one officer in the
middle of nowhere in Iowa does something
wrong and excessively you know uses
Force excessively in a use of force
encounter that goes viral on some video
that we don't villainize all of law
enforcement and say police in general
are bad I think it's so important that
civilians know okay well no that agency
is not providing ample training to their
officers but Marietta is doing a great
job since their incident in IHOP went
viral and they've tightened that up now
they have no remarkable incidents
because everything gets put out quickly
they're putting out fire with water like
they're doing a good job so I think it's
a disservice uh to law enforcement to
the communities to the civilians
Nationwide to think of law enforcement
as this one big thing and we definitely
have seen that right in the wake of you
know viral incidents that have you know
in terms of have really rattled the
country this generalization of law
enforcement I don't think it's fair it's
not true it's not the fact the fact is
because one agency performed poorly and
has zero hours of in-service a year
doesn't mean an agency that's doing two
hours a week for every officer isn't
doing an amazing job and there are
agencies in America today
um that are doing amazing work and they
should not be bundled in with the rest
of these agencies who are stuck in 1980
and who still don't even do any Jiu
Jitsu even in that two or four hour
block they're not doing Jiu Jitsu but
then you've got other agencies many of
which I can think of Bellevue Washington
at the top of the list these agencies in
Southern California so there's all these
agencies where it's like very
Progressive Lots of Jiu Jitsu lots of
great training and I just it's sad to
think that because they're wearing a
blue uniform the general public sees
them in many cases as the same as
wherever middle of nowhere an officer
who uses excessive force and I think
that's wrong and I think that the public
should be aware that it's not all the
same and the Chiefs and the police
Chiefs out there need to know that it's
up to them to carve out their own
identity as a police department and they
have to hold themselves accountable if
they don't want to be bundled in with
the rest of American law enforcement
which is so highly criticized by the
general public today more than ever yeah
well glad you're doing it um
before we get into the book because in
the book you refer to some of your
business practices one of them obviously
being Gracie University you also have a
couple other companies that you talk
about in the book the first one is quick
flip quick flip hoodies which I gotta
break down man
um freaking outstanding idea and and
when I saw that thing I was like dang
that's a good idea did you did I tell
you about this you did many times I did
I was like yo this dude thought of a
good idea it's a hoodie that turns into
like one of these
string backpacks what do you call those
kind of backgrounds drawstring backpacks
um you made this hoodie how do you I
mean I I take 20 seconds to tell the
story of how you thought of it because
it's so obvious if you especially
especially if you live in Southern
California in California in Southern
California
you when you leave you bring you bring a
hoodie with you because as soon as the
song goes down it gets cold it gets cool
let me say it gets cool it cools off it
cools off because we're in a semi-arid
desert what's known as a semire desert
so as soon as the sun goes down it goes
from 80 degrees to 54 degrees or 70
degrees today so totally comfortable in
the T-shirt sun goes down 20 minutes
later you're chilly you break out a
hoodie that's what everybody does that's
what I do been doing it the whole time
I've lived in California
you figured out that everyone has to do
that and they don't have a cool way of
carrying their hoodie so you came up
with this idea so yeah it's in the book
it's uh the river principle and in Jiu
Jitsu the river principle which you guys
know well is this concept that right
when an obstacle presents itself right
when you're the water's flowing down the
river and The Rock presents itself the
water doesn't bother with the rock the
water simply flows where the rock is not
where is the opportunity ignores the
obstacle and on it goes and in Jiu Jitsu
we're moving A Thousand Miles a minute
right so we're just constantly things
are always changing and when there's an
opportunity we go the second that
opportunity is gone it's what is now
available as a result of that
opportunity no longer being available to
me it's it's such a fast and this is
constantly reinforced on the mat so it
was December 27 2016. I was with my son
who was then two or one at the park uh
he's now seven whatever and I I was at
the park he's chasing squirrels I'm
chasing him I'm wearing a hoodie because
in the morning it's cold the same way at
night it's cold you leave the house in a
hoodie but at 10 o'clock the sun came
through and I'm like damn it why did I
bring the stupid hoodie like it's sunny
now the morning layer had burnt off so
I'm carrying my hoodie with me I take
off the hoodie I was about to tie it
around my waist and this is for the
viewers for the listeners I'll just kind
of describe it I took off my hoodie I
was about to tie it around my waist
right and I was gonna go fanny pack
style but I swear to God as the hands
came together it was like it was the
magnet opposite ends of the magnet where
they don't want to touch right the two
negative sides and I couldn't connect my
hands
and all I thought was I'm a cool dad
I can't do this I swear to I just was
like no I'm a new dad and I was like I
don't want to be that Dad who just so
anyways I was pissed off I threw it over
one shoulder like this I did like the
lofty toss over and then I when I bent
over to pick Haven up it slipped off the
shoulder and it fell onto the wet grass
so the moment of frustration right there
was so pronounced because I tried to be
cool and then when I bent over it got
wet in the little kind of slightly muddy
wet grass and I was like that's so
stupid I tried to be cool and I paid the
price so I pick up my son we take a
hoodie we go home it's two days after
Christmas in December 27 2016 I locked
myself in the office in-laws were there
all doing whatever I come out of the
office after 30 minutes I went in with
shoestrings paper clips duct tape
scissors and the hoodie that I was
wearing at the park I come out 30
minutes later with a prototype and I say
guys look at this and everyone's like
where were you guys they're all confused
and this is what they come up to I
inside goes my hoodie one turn out comes
my fully functional backpack
and they're like
which is happening so it functions as a
backpack you can put things inside of it
it has an extra little pocket for your
wallet keys or cell phone this goes on
and you can wear it and then I was like
dude it's too loose you know how
sometimes you bounce around those little
dressing backers they hang too low and
you're always like man I wish it would
hang a little tighter that's a function
of the string length based on the
circumference of the opening of the
pouch so I invented the world's flattest
cord lock and you can see it shaped like
a paper clip because that's the tool
that I took in this is a Christmas tree
lock it locks up and then you go here
and on the same thing on the other side
and now you can go to any height with
this and now you can run bike hike
parkour Jiu Jitsu this thing is not
coming off no matter what you can even
shadow box because I watch your videos
so I did Jiu Jitsu with Heaton on Shark
Tank with it so then it goes in and now
when you get cold my son's hoodie when I
leave the house right now even if it's
sunny when I leave the house I'm in a
quick flip my son's hoodie is inside the
quick flip and we're enjoying our time
at the park at Disneyland whatever so
I'm going out the house and it gets cold
in three hours I reach and take out his
hoodie here son take this reach in count
to three please too slow we're already
back to the hoodie and I don't have a
backpack to Lug around the just in case
backpack that you bring just in case you
need a hoodie it is the just in case
backpack so I did this I did a video I
went to Santa Monica or sorry Venice
Beach and I everyone I walked by I said
yo is there a better way to carry a
hoodie and I recorded 30 interactions of
these people it went viral this video
shark tank called when they saw the
video and said yo this is amazing we
want you to come on Shark Tank so I did
season 10 of Shark Tank Episode 23 went
on there got offers from Lori from
Robert and from Mr Wonderful and it was
a great experience it freaking blew us
up the next day we're selling we're
doing a bunch of that and then lo and
behold we're selling direct to Consumer
doing a great job and things were
awesome and then we started getting
calls from Google from Intel from Warner
Brothers different technology and large
corporations saying hey that's cool we
want to do Warner Brothers for all of
producers all across America 3 500
hoodies with our logo on it and I was
like
pivot principle principle 21 I'm like of
course right it's not just the hoodie
that they want to buy a quick flip
hoodie let's put their logos on it so
then I realized the real opportunity was
in the custom labeling of these hoodies
for these different organizations and
that kind of kept going and kept
speeding up until eventually Disneyland
called
and look at this Avengers hoodie
Avengers hoodie fully dialed in fully
sublimated and of course you're at the
park one tuck and roll and it's your
Avengers backpack of course you're at
the parks on off throughout the day and
every line so then I thought that was
the Holy Grail but it went one step
further
which is the first ever Jocko food yeah
check it out so inside goes the Jocko
Fuel and once this tucks in
one turn
and look at that what's gonna happen on
the outside look at that he came
prepared Man Came prepared boom hard
work clean feel no excuses that's true
for you oh man thank you one for you and
I made one extra since this is the only
Jocko fuel oh I get the extra for sure
for your number one Jocko fuel slash
Jocko podcast fan in the world you guys
figure out who that is and this goes to
them the only chocolate fuel quick flips
out there freaking awesome so cool so
anyways that's the river principle and
this idea that I could have I'm not an
apparel guy I have do you guys have to
understand Jiu Jitsu is the only thing I
know so when I drop the hoodie and that
frustration moment hit it was the same
as like any one of us being on the mat
and being in an armbar situation and all
we're asking is okay this sucks but hold
on
let's feel let's analyze let's where is
the opportunity in this adversity where
is the flow potential around this
Obstacle of this rock and I Jiu Jitsu
the hoodie and that's what's so wild how
interesting that you have an apparel
industry of billions and billions of
dollars and all kinds of people focusing
on technology there and on a fateful
Tuesday morning I invent the best hoodie
on the planet in terms of just
functionality
and I go wow that's crazy but it makes
perfect sense that it came from outside
the industry it often does right The
Innovation
um and I attribute it 100 to Jujitsu
that I didn't accept that rock and say
okay well this sucks like life just
sucks it was not a no there's a problem
no one thought of a solution where are
we going to take this and a company was
born and now I have a guy who runs the
whole thing his name is Jordan does an
amazing job and it's my side hustle
there's just a thing that was born and
it's like we have a dope hoodie
and it's a similar story with sleeper
hold right which is your travel pillow
yes a sleeper hold it's freaking nuts so
dude you're like a comedian with a prop
comedian over here just whipping out
your stuff so again sleeper hope is
crazy I'm flying traveling GST courses
every month I'm flying and my wife Eve
worked for the WWE Vince McMahon the
whole that whole show she did that for
five six years traveling every single
week with no like Seasons it's the
craziest traveling job of any profession
I've ever seen is WWE and they travel
every Wednesday come back every or
travel every Friday come back every
Wednesday so we're both traveling every
month for several for several flights
and I'm sitting next to a guy one flight
and he's just boom and we've all
experienced it the freaking bobble head
and I'm sitting next to this guy and I
took a little selfie footage of that and
when I landed the flight I texted it to
Eve and I said babe we're gonna solve
this problem we're going to invent the
solution to this because he was wearing
one of those conventional u-shaped
memory foam pillows and I said we're
going to solve this and I ordered two
airplane seats on eBay and within three
days they're in my garage airplane seats
are actually in my garage and we go to
work with every strap every rubber band
every mechanism you can imagine to
connect to the seat back slash head rest
of that airplane seat tinkering messing
around for several months come up with
the first prototype it's all this is
awesome so it's all about supporting
because every pillow on the market tries
to support bobblehead at the neck right
so basically as your head Bobs they try
to say okay we're gonna put something
under here the problem is from a pure
Jiu Jitsu standpoint supporting at the
neck is the shortest lever because
you're going from the base of the neck
to your Jawbone and that's a very short
lever the way to stop ahead from bobbing
is that you need the longest lever which
is right here that's a much longer lever
and will require much less Force to
prevent the head from bobbing the
problem is there is no mechanism that
holds your head up inefficient and and
acceptably socially acceptable way that
looks okay when you're using it so we
went to work on these straps and blah
blah and fast forward you know six
months we finally figured it out we
patented it and then we got busy with
quick flip around the same time I
invented quickflip and I had to choose
which invention am I going to take to
Market and I chose quick flip I felt it
had a more widespread use so we sat on a
sleeper hold for three or four years and
then quickflip blew up did his thing and
then covet struck and then I'm like
thank God we didn't launch quick flip
because now no one's traveling this
thing is completely fell asleep for a
year and a half or so no one was
traveling and then post uh covid we
finally said man I'm gonna do this I was
using it traveling to Cincinnati for a
keynote at Procter and Gamble uh
leadership Jiu Jitsu keynote and on the
flight a woman behind me sees me strap
in basically this contraption that holds
your forehead covers your eyes pillow
behind your neck and completely
eliminates bobblehead with perfect head
support right so I strap in and she
literally touches my shoulder random
woman in the class in the in the in the
in the airplane her name was Patty and
she said sir I just have to ask you what
is this
and I said well I'm so glad you asked
and I had my videographer there because
we're going for this keynote so I'm like
cool record this right now everything
you hear put the mic on this roll we
film our first infomercial in Flight in
a commercial flight on the way to
Cincinnati all these regular passengers
whose face I kind of blurred out and me
and Patty are interacting and she gets
the full Spiel we show it to her she
can't believe and she says Henry this is
crazy why don't you produce these
because this is I everyone needs this
and I said well Patty I just been
sitting on it and then covet if you make
this I'll buy it and we filmed this
whole interaction I sent that to even
with a flight landed and this is five
years after we invented it so I sent
that to you I said babe we're going to
take this to Market Now's the Time Patty
is ready the world is ready let's go so
then we did six months of preparation we
launched it on Kickstarter four months
ago and we sold 32 000 31 000 pillows in
40 days on Kickstarter a million dollars
raised and it's the number one travel
pillow ever crowdfunded and we just the
shipment of 50 000 pillows just landed
last week and we're shipping this week
to customers all over the world and
another company is Born Again out of
necessity Jiu Jitsu and in this case you
know just timing the release properly
and stop go stop go when it comes to
covet and
um anyways so I don't know you guys I
don't know what's going on with my life
you know I teach Jujitsu I teach police
officers I invented a dope hoodie and I
solved in-flight sleep deprivation and
these are my side hustles so anyways you
have his pillow or do I yeah yeah okay
if you need another one for your
daughter oh yeah yeah yeah okay sweet uh
at what point so you did you did a video
about Jiu Jitsu that is called also
called the 32 principles right yeah that
was now was that on Gracie University
yes it's an online course and this was
um during covid we all know that there
are principles on which all of jujitsu
is based we all know that because
there's so many similarities with so
many different techniques that even
without naming them and identifying them
and like classifying as a curriculum
it's just a known thing
but I feel like they were largely
unclassified especially on the micro
level what are the macro principles
Leverage
timing control efficiency which is a
blend of Leverage and timing and control
the efficiency is probably the Apex
principle of all Jiu Jitsu and then the
kind of the the macro principles are
leveraged timing and control what we
realize is that there are micro
principles right and what we found were
there are 32 micro principles
um you know the CL so clock principle
distance principle Detachment principle
connection principle reconnaissance
principle there's all these ones that
are talked that are communicated in the
book that
are all like it's almost like they're
the nitty-gritty of the principles
because these macro principles are
almost too broad
for them to be actionable in a very
specific way and when me and Hedon kind
of realize that there were these 32
micro principles we thought wow this is
beautiful if we can classify these we
can teach them visually teach them we
could really impact Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
because it's almost like we would
give all of the people who practice
Jujitsu kind of like the alphabet
on which their language is based because
it's one thing to learn a language
through osmosis right you grow up in a
household speaking Portuguese you learn
Portuguese imagine if you spoke
Portuguese right and you just heard the
language your whole life and by the time
you're at 20 years old you realize
there's an alphabet that makes sense of
all of that I feel like these 32 micro
principles are the alphabet for jiu
jitsu there is no Jutsu technique that
doesn't rely on one or more of these in
most cases jiu jitsu techniques rely on
two three or four or sometimes more
and for students to have that level of
clarity on what those principles
actually are and call them out of their
Jujitsu changes everything because what
happens is when a student knows the
principles that make their Jiu Jitsu
possible they can lean into them more
deliberately and they can make deposits
in those principles more deliberately
because at the end of the day when any
one of us is doing Jiu Jitsu and you
guys are rolling uh with each other or
anyone else and you land in a position
that you don't know a technique for
it happens to us every day I've never
been here before what the heck is this
position what do I do right now
what happens whether it's a conscious
effort or not for all of us who've been
around the mat for years decades or more
is what I call a 32 principles
diagnostic your body pulls from the
principles that you've immersed yourself
in for any number of years and based on
all of your experience you create a
solution a unique solution to that
unique situation that you've never
experienced before
and it's magical right haven't you seen
anyone you admire in Jiu Jitsu come up
with a solution for a situation that you
just asked about and you're like how the
heck did he make that up right now and
the answer is it's not that he had that
in the catalog he didn't have that in
his database he puts himself in the
position I don't know let me see lay
down get on top of me let me see we
always hear the Masters do that right
and then in that moment they just make
it up
so what they're doing is they're calling
on all these principles and when I lay
down in a position of of of a foreign
position for me I'll lay down and I'll
just get someone on top of me here's the
threat or it's happening while I'm
rolling my body automatically scans all
32 principles for their efficacy and
validity in that situation and then
let's say these four are possible it's a
rapid process these four are possible
but these two are going to require too
much strength this one is going to
require me to expose myself to punches
in a way that I don't think is favorable
so this is the remaining principle or
two whatever is remaining after all that
that I'm going to use to create my
solution right now and you invent a
technique that is based on that
principle or two and that diagnostic
happens every single day on the mats in
real time
that diagnostic that diagnostic process
and your diagnosing capabilities is
increased exponentially if you know what
those principles are by name right do
you have a curriculum you have a
relationship with each one of those
principles when you get in those unknown
situations you can create Solutions
rapidly and on the Fly exponentially
better than if you don't have a
deliberate and a a a really a true
relationship with those principles if
it's just kind of esoteric and it lives
in the background and you've never
really studied it and this is the
reporting that we're getting from people
who have taken the video course and have
watched the 32 principles on video the
Jiu jitsu-based course is that it just
added Clarity for black belt it added
that Clarity for white belts it taught
them that it's not about techniques in
the beginning learn the techniques but
instead of fixating on them try to
extrapolate the principle in every
technique because that principle will be
applied over and over again whereas the
technique can only be applied in a
particular situation for which that
technique is it's it's similar right
it's for one specific situation
so this is true in Jiu Jitsu we all do
it and what I realize is that I do this
in my life when I drop a hoodie when I
see a bobble head or any other thing
that I've had major challenges or major
Milestones or major victories it's
always what's the situation
diagnose the situation the threat the
concern The Challenge and then run a 32
principles diagnostic now for a large
part of my life this was unconscious
effort it was just the natural way I
operated because Jiu Jitsu was my DNA
now that I've classified these 32
principles with my brother and created
this published curriculum and they all
have names I looked back and I went holy
cow the extent to which these 32
principles played a part in that
milestone in that negotiation in that
victory in that invention it became so
clear that that's when I became very
committed to the process of saying man I
think I could teach people these
principles and then give them the
context personally and professionally
where they could be applied and let them
have my operating system without having
to spend 30 plus years doing Jujitsu I
think it'd be a great service the Big
Challenge in all of this is that Jiu
Jitsu is something so physical and so
visual
and when I first contemplated writing
the book I felt limited by ink on paper
and I went I don't know dude to
communicate the Detachment principle
with written word on paper
I might lose some in Translation in in
in in that interpretation there
so I asked the publisher I said look I
only want to do this if you'll allow me
to add a QR code at the beginning of
every chapter so that the reader can
scan the QR code before reading the
chapter and Visually and auditorily hear
and experience the principle in combat
as demonstrated by myself and my brother
and it's like a five to seven minute
video explaining a technique or two that
encapsulates that particular principle
of interest for that chapter if they can
understand conceptually that physical
application of that principle then the
the the soil is fertile for me to then
take them into the ink on paper in the
chapter and communicate the the personal
and professional application of the same
principle you know in life in business
and they said Henry we've never done
that that would be awesome let's go and
I'm like great and it was more work for
me because now I got to produce 32
videos on top of writing a book but I
was happy to do it and this is the
result and you know I I'm very happy
with with it and I think it's a
completely different experience for a
reader than what they're used to because
by the time they're done with this book
they will not only understand how these
principles apply to life in business but
they'll also learn several jiu jitsu
techniques and these principles in a
combat application and even if you're
not a practitioner by the time with this
book you're going to walk a little bit
taller you're going to understand some
concepts of of personal protection and
self-defense that could effectively save
your life in a fight not that you have
the muscle memory in their movements but
you'll know about distance you'll know
about timing you'll know about leverage
in so many different ways as
communicated in these 32 micro
principles yeah yeah
um
foreign
get the book I was you know I can't read
this whole book on on the podcast did
you do the audiobook too yeah bro that
was the worst experience of my life yeah
some people have a real heart I'm
surprised you didn't just love that
thing don't give me a script I'll talk
for three days straight got it give me a
script and watch me struggle was it you
feel me yeah I'm sitting in the studio
one quarter of this size and I'm reading
the Henry go back do that again every
sentence every period every letter
they're scrutinizing and I'm reading 70
000 words in two days 20 hours in two
days 13 hours on day one seven hours on
day day two I had to do it in two days
because I had other things going on and
uh I may never write a book again
because of the audiobook experience
uh so get the book and there's a ton of
good information in here obviously I I
just do want to take the opportunity
since you're here just to burn through
these things I got so many notes but I'm
just gonna burn through these things and
go through these principles chapter one
which is which is Rule one or principle
one the connection principle optimizing
your success by constantly evolving the
tools and tactics you use to connect
with others in the world around you
gracieuniversity.com is the example I
talk about in the book how right I broke
my back I want to reach the world with
Jiu Jitsu and I use these different
tools to not only connect myself with
the world but connect them with each
other and in Jiu Jitsu like I mentioned
about the Swiss army knife right our
body is a tool and it's capable of much
more than we imagined we have really 32
different distinct body parts that we've
counted thus far calf knee ankle InStep
toes all of these are little Tools in
Jiu Jitsu right but normal humans don't
use all those so this is the idea that
in life are you optimizing all the tools
available to you to connect with people
and the world to optimize your
Effectiveness so really are you are you
optimizing what's available
two the Detachment principle recognizing
when holding on does more harm than good
and when Letting Go does more good than
imagined I think everyone can relate to
that right like it's a pretty universal
life principle but in Jiu Jitsu right
how common is that where
no there's some times where let go right
now and the choke becomes available
because you let go of something else
right with my brother I was going for
the arm bar he's pulling out and because
I let go of the arm bar he ripped it out
and threw himself into a triangle so
that's the Detachment principle I tell
the story of my mom's you know untimely
passing a couple years ago and how
um after she she struck with a form of
cancer and literally was everything was
fine stomach a little bit of pain one
night she was going to babysit our my
son's uh mine and Eve Sons Henry my
tummy hurts a little I don't think I can
watch the boys tonight like straight and
we lived next door to her adjacent we
shared a wall so my house and her house
are like this
so going to my grandma's house that
night she's like I don't think I can
watch him Henner and um lo and behold a
couple days passed she goes over get
some scans get some things a couple
weeks passed she thought it was
gallstones you know thing let it pass
she finally goes and gets the scans and
she has bile duct cancer like a really
rare and very aggressive form
and I'm like holy cow so if massive in
Rapid decline in her health in a matter
of the next couple of months and what's
interesting is of course what we we all
as problem solvers we all go into save
mode right like let's protect let's save
let's go and everyone's thinking of
every single going to chips in Mexico
and do this alternative therapy and
everyone kicks into gear and my mom she
really rapid declining and real
discomfort she comes in and talks to me
and my siblings she says you know you
guys have had a really good life I'm
very happy
in not so many words
and that's when I realized that we were
holding on
for us
not even for her
so the type of love and support and
support that she needed at that point
wasn't the love and connection it was
the Detachment and the hardest was her
her husband my stepfather in that case
who equally was so committed no no no no
we got to do everything and as long as
he needed her she would not let go so to
the talk with him to say hey Mark
what she really needs is freedom from us
right now she's made that clear so this
was like and he eventually came around
and said okay
uh and and stepped back in his desire to
offer Go-Go and so proactive
and it was the most significant use of
the Detachment principle in everyday
life and once he stepped back then she
was able to pass away and she did so
peacefully and we were all there and of
course timing couldn't have been worse
in general she was still you know 60 mid
60s 67 65 years old but um
it was so interesting to realize holy
cow we're doing it not for her but for
us and when she made clear that she was
okay I'm good you guys I saw my
grandbabies spent so much good time with
him I'm okay then I went wow we gotta
shift everything to now support her the
way she needs to be supported not the
way we want to support
and Detachment principal made that
possible because so many times in jiu
jitsu letting go when I didn't think it
was the right play was the right play
yeah that's a powerful story that you
write in the book and and again the
that's what the book is it's various
stories either from your personal life
you also have stories in here from other
people what they've been through how
they utilize principles so a lot of a
lot of these stories are told that
really reveal how the principles can be
used not only by you but by people
around you that's what the book is
um yeah and that one's extremely
powerful
number three the distance principle
understanding the impact that distance
has on your Effectiveness Jujitsu this
is the one right as we said we changed
the distance from which fights are
fought in America and around the world
when UFC one hit
and this is true in relationships as
well right
you got to be careful because in a fight
the way we explain it is
Jiu Jitsu strategy you want to be all
the way out or you want to be all the
way in
and
if you're not careful you end up in
What's called the Red Zone in a street
fight or in an altercation where the red
zone is where you're not all the way in
you're not all the way and you're
punchable it's the tip of the punch
and in life this exists as well right
you want to be either in relationships
that are close and meaningful and Rich
where you're all the way in and you're
invest in that relationship or you want
to be all the way out where any
wrongdoings of the other person in the
relationship don't profoundly affect you
in a negative way that you had no
control over because if you exist in the
Red Zone where they're you're in but
you're not all the way in then you
expose yourself to that relationship Red
Zone where damage can be done because
serious damage can be done and I tell a
story about relationships where my
failure to manage the distance
effectively
caused uh some people that existed with
my brother and I in the relationship Red
Zone to do damage irreparable damage
that I I I you know I I to some degree
take some ownership of even though it
had nothing to do with it the fact that
this person used our reputation and the
fact that there was a relationship but
the fact that we weren't close enough to
mitigate the damage and to prevent it
from from furthering
um I have some sense of ownership of
that so it was a chapter where I talk
about a failure to manage the distance
effectively and the price I paid as a
result
number four the pyramid principle
investing in a strong Foundation you got
number five the creation principle
beginning with the end goal in mind and
then using targeted actions to make your
vision a reality
one thing I found interesting about that
one is when when I teach kids when you
teach an adult like how to pass guard
you need to tell them like okay put your
hand over here you got to get in posture
you got to push that thing down you
gotta once you get there you gotta
staple there you got to give them all
these little specific you can tell a kid
get out from between their legs and they
like just you tell them what to do where
they're trying to go and they'll just
figure out a way to get there it's
pretty neat reminded me of the creation
principle Yeah a hundred percent and in
Jiu Jitsu right we talk about this
concept of you want to be first and you
want to be third yeah
yeah you know so this idea of deliberate
targeted actions to get the reaction
from the opponent that you're looking
for and then capitalizing on that
um that reaction of theirs and it's it's
a it's a powerful concept there and it's
a powerful Concept in life in business
as well
uh number six the acceptance principle
recognizing when it's better to yield
than to resist
a big one
bro the example in the book was marriage
yeah right so so for me it was um you
know I tell the story about my wife and
I my now wife then girlfriend and the
struggle that we had regarding my
beliefs and this is this is like
generational beliefs Brazil Macho crazy
family women do dishes and stay in the
kitchen and don't ask questions like
that's what I kind of grew up with and
um you know that's not what you married
that's not what I married dude holy
um so so I marry and and Eve says Henry
like so I'm like when I'm starting to
even think about a family I'm like babe
you know like you're not gonna work
right you're just gonna kind of take
care and do this and she said well I
have different beliefs about that
my mom she's like her mom was like ice
right immigration Customs Enforcement
attorney like a federal ice attorney
high level like a senior attorney at ice
in Colorado her dad's a psychologist her
sister's a psychologist her brother is a
is a scientist right a biologist all
successful family everyone's successful
and she says well all I saw was my mom
work 40 50 60 hours a week every week of
my life and I had nothing but admiration
it's all I grew up with and we're
perfectly healthy and we grew up and all
of us are successful and I'm over here
thinking my mom didn't work at all she's
in the house because she had to be and
she's cleaning and she's mopping and
she's doing this and they divorced after
12 years at 13 14 15 years and her
parents are still married after 50 years
so I'm in a tough situation I have a
belief about what it needs to be because
the Gracie family says it needs to be
this way and she's like well let the
numbers speak for themselves
bro we started talking at 11 or 12.
that went till 4 30 morning time 11 or
12 P.M to 4 30 A.M
fair to say I tapped out
and the result is now evident I have a
wife who not only works but she's
integral running the whole Gracie
University chief of operations sorry
chief of staff there putting all the
right pieces in place overhauling all
the systems and has an incredible impact
on the business is the head of the women
empowered program a figure for
self-defense women all over the world
and we have two sons they love it they
see her go to work every day she comes
home she loves them when she's there and
our marriage is amazing because she gets
to live her Legacy and she's doing what
she wants to do and um
acceptance principle saved my marriage
Big Time Jiu Jitsu 101.
uh number seven the velocity principle
adapting your speed to maintain balance
and optimize outcomes how much in Jiu
Jitsu do we go stop go stop so
if you're fast always fast you're
predictable if you're always slow you're
predictable
right it's the velocity principles a
constant changing of our operational
speed to disrupt our opponent so this is
the idea of you know knowing when to go
knowing when not to go and I use the
example of sleeper hold this pillow
right launch don't launch launch don't
launch and there were so many factors
coming into the public launch of this
pillow that um covid came in and then we
stopped and then I plan on going and
then Kenny my marketing director who
actually trains here with you guys he
lives in San Diego Kenny Wang he was
like Hannah no we can't launch right now
because it's the wrong month and timing
of when to go and wins and when you go
go
but when you're not when it's not time
to go pull right and just being able to
be flexible in the velocity and in Jiu
Jitsu we do so much of the changing of
our pacing
um and I talk about that in great length
there and it's a critical principle and
it comes into the clock principle which
is the kind of the other side of the
timing principles clock principle right
recognizing that the right move at the
wrong time is the wrong move and the
clock principle also talks about
disrupting the other person against you
so if you're going to do a technique and
you have your anticipated timing my job
is to disrupt your anticipated timing of
your move to throw the whole thing off
and in the in the book I talk about an
example of a young man a 16 year old boy
named Shane there was a psychologist who
trained with us and called in and said
hener I have a kid who has suffers from
the most severe case of social anxiety
I've ever seen right he vomits profusely
in any type of social encounter going to
school he vomits every morning before
school it was crazy I think he would
love Jiu Jitsu so I said great I would
love a chance to work with this and if I
can help change his life by all means
let's do this
so we set it up for a Thursday and I set
it up for a time where I knew no one
would be in the building so that he
wouldn't feel this anxiety so at four
o'clock class it's like four five four
ten and the mom calls me from the
parking lot and says Henner We're not
gonna make it I said what do you mean
she says well we're outside parked in
front of the building but he's not
coming to the class we tried and we want
to thank you for allocating the time and
I'm sorry I said you're outside my
building right now can I come out and
say hi
she says of course so I walk out in my
ghee I walk out and I hear the most
abdominally enforced cry I've ever heard
in my life screaming cry
the mom is standing outside the car
passenger side on the curb he's sitting
in the passenger side back seat mom is
outside I say can I go
and she says yeah
like I kind of mouth it to her and I go
around the passage of the driver's side
I get in the car and I sit down and he's
crying you guys
[Music]
folding over with every breath and
crying and punching it out and I'm like
I've never seen this before in my life
this is a situation like Jiu Jitsu I
don't have the technique I don't know
the answer the move for this submission
that this guy has me in so I sit down
I'll say a word for 20 minutes
while he cries
depletion principle
oh it's in the books later he then sits
up he runs out of steam he sits up he
looks at me
and now he's not he's breathing normal
and he's not hysterical anymore
and I said hey Shane
what do you like to do for fun
and he says
video games
I said tell me more
15 minutes asking them questions and I
don't know anything about these games
and he's over here telling me everything
and at the end his normal conversation
with me I said hey bro thanks for making
it in today
if you're open to it I'd like to give
you a tour of the facility beautiful
mads beautiful facility I think you
really enjoy we have a museum come check
it out
can we do that you know what yeah
I said cool let's go we walk out we go
in there empty building just the
reception is high we walk by tour the
mat all I'm thinking
is there can be no chance that he leaves
this building without doing jiu jitsu
hero because the chance that I get him
back a second time is zero of zero so
there's no way so I'm walking and I'm
nervous because how am I gonna get this
guy on the mat and not cause a vomiting
fit in the middle of this building
so I'm giving you the tour go to the
locker room we come back by the private
rooms right there room number one I open
the door to the private room
I walk in and I step on the mats and I
say Shane these mats are so soft
take off your shoes so you can feel them
he walks in with his shoes off mom walks
in goes to the side small room this
exact size right here green mats on
every wall looks like an insane asylum
padded walls padded floor no nothing
else no exit he walks in I shut the door
bottom
mom's in the corner she sits down I say
Shane do me a favor lay down right here
in the middle of the mat the classic 10
minute intro of Gracie Jiu Jitsu I mount
on top of him and I say how it we're
Bros now I said how would you escape
well I push you off I said go give it a
go pop blah blah blah blah I'm laughing
I'm keeping the energy very like
friendly Bob Bob come on bro give it a
chance let's go my friends are coming
huh we're just playing
I can't get out I said switch hold me
down boom one second trap and roll
wow that was awesome do it again I'd do
it the other way oh man you lay
you like he does it he does it two three
six techniques one hour later mom
doesn't say one word throughout this
whole time
I look over in the corner and she's
crying silent tears falling on her face
and me and Shane are all in I don't even
think he noticed but I was seeing that
we're having the best time doing these
techniques we wrap it up amazing job bro
we get up we go out
I'll see you guys on Tuesday
on Tuesday it only takes 15 minutes to
get him out of the car
on the next class he comes in after the
Tuesday class we do the whole routine
again we train we're all good the next
class he comes in Henry I need to use
the restroom he goes he throws up he
comes to the mat we train again
eventually I hand him off once he's
ready to another instructor he starts
doing private classes with him and then
he transitions into group classes doing
Jiu Jitsu in a group he eventually
graduates high school his dad is a
captain at LAPD and so he's dealing with
this couldn't be more grateful than mom
can't believe he graduates high school
earns his blue belt eventually goes to
college lives a normal life
Shane's gonna be okay clock principle
the right move at the wrong time is the
wrong move I didn't know what principle
I was going to use for Shane in that
moment but I depleted his resources in
the car by patiently waiting and then
when we got to the actual door and I
opened it and I said now is the time I'm
going to call him in I'm going to shut
the door we're friends he's going to
trust me this is going to work Jiu Jitsu
worked in that situation I had faith I
threw my my chance I threw my
opportunity I mounted on him I didn't
know what reaction it was going to be
and today he's a different man because
of it and the doctor cannot believe it
who referred him Henry I've never seen
this before this type of transformation
on this type of social anxiety it's
almost incurable because it's so
pronounced and it's so deep Jujitsu
saved him
clock principle
number nine the river principle which
you already talked about overcoming
obstacles by flowing around them you got
it number 10 the frame principle
increasing Effectiveness by enhancing
systematic efficiency so in Jiu Jitsu we
aim to substitute
muscular strength with skeletal
structure everywhere we can it's helpful
to be strong right it's it's it's never
a liability really it's there it's added
it's an asset but what strength we have
has limitations in how far it'll take us
so when you substitute your skeletal
structure which doesn't require the
physical muscular strength you can
accomplish more with less it's
efficiency at its finest my grandfather
loved this principle and I talk about
this idea of operationally in a business
for example how changing the operational
framework of a business can drastically
increase your Effectiveness right in
terms of what you get out of your Human
Resources what you get out of your
mechanical resources so I discussed some
examples for Gracie University of how
changing the structure of the business
changing the framework of the business
just exponentially grew our potential
and our impact in the world and it's one
that again found its it's it's rooted on
the mats but is equally effective in
life in business
number 11 the kuzushi principle yeah so
the kazoo seeking first to understand
then to be understood that's the life
application of the kazushi principle
that I my kind of definition that I gave
it for jiu jitsu this is the kazushi the
the term kazushi is literally the
breaking of balance right it's a known
principle in Judo in Jiu Jitsu and
right every sweep every trap and roll
every takedown you're breaking the
balance and then you're driving their
way in a direction where they don't have
the appendage to balance themselves so
when you talk about the pyramid
principle you talk about bass when you
talk about the kazushi principle you're
essentially breaking the Pyramid of the
opponent
in the Life Application of this and
remember as I'm writing this book I'm
really reflecting on my life and I'm
saying okay where in my life did I what
does Breaking balance have to do with
dealing with people and businesses and
family and relationships and then I
realized well you can't break the
balance
that you don't first understand
I need to know the pillars on which you
stand to then be able to isolate and
defeat a pillar and then off balance you
in the direction I want to take you so
that's where I gave it the life
application and entrepreneurial
definition of seeking first to
understand then to be understood
and there was an example here where I we
I one day as someone emails me says
Hannah we have a one star Yelp review
disaster
disastrous Yelp review full paragraph
sometimes you get the little pissed off
people and nobody worries about them
right but you guys have seen the
paragraphs where they just rip into you
and you're like oh this is we got to
manage this so I get this one star Yelp
review which I take very personally
because we work so hard to create such a
unique student experience
and um I say find me the phone number
for who this and what the Yelp review
says is I had my daughter go to her
first class after years of getting her
ready for this she went to her first
class she was paired up with another
girl who was too aggressive nobody
recognized my daughter in the class it
was a disaster and they didn't take care
of her and she her partner was too
aggressive with her and she wanted to
quit the class and I wanted to step on
the map because it didn't something the
teachers were paying attention to my
student nobody knew it was her first day
so the mom had incredible anxiety around
a negative First Class for her
five-year-old daughter
and I thought holy cow this was a
terrible experience
I thought what do I do about this
and then I thought
give me the phone number I'm gonna call
and I called my managers into the room
and I got her on the phone on speaker
and the mom's name was Myra and I said
Myra I understand you had a negative
experience can you tell me about it
oh hi Henry yeah yeah because I didn't
teach the class it was another
instructor of mine I said tell me
everything she went boom took her time
explaining everything I just told you
and I said you know what I said first of
all I'm really sorry this happened
and I said
there's no excuse and know that steps
will be taken so that no other student
ever experiences what Miranda
experienced her daughter
I said but that's not good enough
Miranda never got the introduction to
jiu jitsu that she should have gotten
and that she deserves so what I'd like
to do is offer her
a private class with myself and I want
you to come with her
so that you can also be introduced to
jiu jitsu the way it should be done oh
my gosh that's so generous of you that's
amazing in fact I only ever wanted to
come to the class with my daughter
because I wanted to do Jiu Jitsu and I
never had a chance when I was a kid this
is awesome
I said great let's do it so I set up the
class with Bobby one of our female
amazing female instructors me Bobby and
then Myra and Miranda we do this private
class
an hour-long class boom just having fun
Gracie games for the girl techniques for
the Mom they're having the best time the
class ends and I said look I don't want
to go just there I also want to sponsor
a whole month of private classes with
Bobby you're going to love her she's one
of our best instructors she's going to
take care of you guys
oh my gosh this is amazing I said you
know and then after that if we earn you
back then we'd love to have you back in
group classes or whatever you want but
to me what matters most is that Miranda
gets the introduction to jiu jitsu that
you knew was possible and that you were
hoping for when you brought her that
first time she was robbed and we're
gonna make it right
this is amazing and then they did the
first second class of Bobby the review
disappeared turned into a five-star
review raving fans and students for
lifelong now they're training with us
she had another son who has a baby
newborn babies gonna come in it's all
good
and in all of the situations it started
with where are you at Myra where are you
at calling her up and not saying hey
why'd you write that that's not true but
instead tell me everything so this can
never happen again so if you're in a
business where it's customer service
where it's and sometimes the customers
are the employees as we know the most
important customers are our employees in
an organization seek first to understand
then to be understood this is true in
business and in personal relationships
number 12 the reconnaissance principle
believing that the answers you seek do
exist and never underestimating the
power of new information
number 13 the prevention principle
accepting that sometimes the only way to
win is to avoid losing we kind of
addressed that one already uh number 14
the tension principle recognizing when
tension is an asset and when it's a
liability something you definitely have
to pay attention to
number 15 the fork principle which I
thought was a very unique name for this
principle optimizing outcomes by
pursuing win-win equations yeah
and Jiu Jitsu right we always aim to
create dilemmas for our opponents such
that if they choose a
they lose if they choose B we win that's
the whole game right it's tracks
everywhere and then I'm thinking well in
life I'm not trying to trap you and trap
you and trap you so in reflecting how
this principle has played out in my life
it became more a matter of recognizing
that
the most successful organizations and
relationships are ones where all the
stakeholders are winning
true win-wins and you have to understand
that coming from a family where the
entire reputation and prowess and and
and really revolution of the Gracie
family
resulted from the opposite approach in
order for the Gracie family to win
someone had to lose
so you have a karate practitioner they
have to suck in order for us to be good
and so that's called a win-lose right
and I'm not speaking out against that
per se but I'm just kind of letting you
guys know and sharing the fact that
that's the DNA that I was given someone
has to lose for someone else to win and
if both people are winning nobody's
winning that's what I was brought up in
and it didn't limit itself to the Gracie
challenge matches I have to say that
some of the entrepreneurial influence of
previous generations
leaned on this idea in the workplace
where no no
it has to be disproportionately
favorable for us in order for us to be
in this relationship at all and that's
when I saw how many relationships fell
through
in my previous generations of Gracie
family members how many opportunities
were lost how many relationships were
soured how many Partnerships failed as a
result of one party seeking that win
lose because eventually all win loses
become lose loses
so I had some very good mentors I was
privileged at 17 18 19 years old to be
teaching very successful entrepreneurs
in every field right you can imagine so
I'm asking I'm learning and I'm always
inquiring like yo what's your secret he
says henor treat your people very good
and this is on more than one occasion
but take care of your people create
win-wins and the irony of it all is that
by being trusting sharing and
considerate of other people's needs
we've now grown an organization with 250
schools around the world sharing they're
making money we're making money we're
changing lives every step of the way and
in all these cases the irony of it all
is the partners in this win-win in this
particular example of sharing Jutsu with
the world are the very people were the
who were the losers on the Gracie
challenge matches so long ago right
those arts and all the other traditional
martial artists now are our biggest
allies in Sharing Jutsu with the world
but in order to get to that point I had
to apply the fork principle in pursuing
those win-wins which was very much
against my DNA you guys have been on the
mat early on talking about Fabio talking
about all my uncles you ask a question
what do they say come here let me show
you that you don't know what you're
talking about you had to lose in order
for the move to be right am I right
there couldn't be like yo a great
question Jocko and that's a good point
and that has validity and so does this
couldn't exist someone had to lose for
something to be right so again this is
the DNA that we grew up with in Jiu
Jitsu and so for me it was very tough to
shake that DNA when I became the leader
in the business and deciding how I
wanted to operate it and that's where
Eve came in and go no like it can be
like this tune it can you can you can
share and you can do this and you can
allow other people to win with us and I
think we'll go further and we went from
a single school with four employees to
now 250 schools and a headquarters with
50 employees in Torrance who work
full-time there all because everyone's
winning
uh number 16 the prop posture principle
identifying the source of the problem
and then targeting your resources
accordingly
number 17 the false surrender principle
feigning compliance in the face of
adversity and then seizing the
opportunity when it prevents it presents
itself so this story is this story in
the book is funny because it's the only
chapter where it's kind of written in
the first person by my wife so Eve gives
this example and she's brand new on WWE
on tour European tour overseas with the
big circus of all these guys you know
what I'm saying I'm not there and I'm
like this is nuts and like I'm in a
dating relationship but she's traveling
with this circus of crazy people
um some are great people but some are
not so much and she's overseas and
they're in the lobby of the hotel
and there that other people are drinking
Eve not so much and there's a guy who's
having a little too much to drink very
known wrestler that people know the name
of and he starts getting a little oh
even only been training for like three
months four months right basic beginner
so this guy starts tussling with Eve in
the lobby and everyone's watching and
kind of that's kind of being silly with
it and he's like oh Jiu Jitsu and
they're tied up and they freaking
scramble and they fall to the ground
even on the bottom and he lands in her
guard and he's just tussling and
twisting and turning and he elbows her
in the eye and in the moment her eye
starts to throb and swell up black eye
on the road and she's a backstage
reporter who has to be on camera
so she's pissed and people are there and
eventually they kind of pull each other
off each other like this Jiu Jitsu
playful banter went too much they pull
it off so she relaxes for a second
he's freaking walking away laughing she
runs up she jumps on his back
she inserts both Hooks and sinks the
rear naked standing
starts to grab at her arm and starting
to stumble to the right stumble to the
left
he drops to his knees and he passes out
face first on the ground
she let him go the whole place erupts
you got choked out by a girl as crazy
this man the other the whole thing went
crazy the reputation spreads in the WWE
that Eve choked out the guy this is one
of the guys so and then Vince calls her
to the office and is like she gets back
to Cal to Connecticut or wherever the
next show whatever happens Vince is
there and calls her into the office so
Eve tell us what happened and she he's
of course she's very he's he's concerned
about the HR aspect of this she's
concerned about keeping her job because
of who she choked both of them are
fearful and she goes are you okay even
he she says yeah I'm okay you know just
he was being silly and it got out of
hand and I choked him unconscious and he
was willing to leave he needed to get
choked oh dude and by the way false
surrender so she after the thing she
kind of calmed down got pulled off this
was a literal false render this is not
like a life in business application this
is a jiu jitsu application of the false
surrender principle that she used
overseas she did this and then she says
no I just choked him out everything's
okay and no problem he went Vince
McMahon that's the funniest thing I've
ever heard that's awesome and I'll tell
you what like I was so happy because
after she choked him out I'm not on tour
with him and like all the guys were on
noticed and like everyone was like yo
she's a shooter she knows how to fight
like she can choke someone for real and
that was my insurance policy dealing
with that circus for the next five years
and I couldn't have been happier even
though she was pissed about the black
guy
uh awesome uh 18 depletion principle
overcoming resistance through patience
persistence and pressure we talked about
that one isolation principle leveraging
the influence of a crowd and the power
of isolation
number 20 the sacrifice principle giving
up something of actual or perceived
value to gain a tactical advantage in
another form
21 the momentum principle recognizing
where things are heading
and knowing where things need to go
number 22 the pivot principle we talked
about this one you you have to adjust
sometimes you have to make some other
moves changing your perspective on a
person product or process to increase
your effectiveness
number 23 the tag along principle
identifying Trends Innovations and
opportunities that will help you reach
your goal with greater efficiency this
is you know similar to uh using what
other people are doing and making it a
win-win it's a beautiful way to operate
number 24 the overload principle
identifying where you have a unique
Advantage then doubling down to maximize
your success
number 25 the anchor principle
committing wholeheartedly to people
principles and processes that optimize
your Effectiveness and impact
it's a good one and look I'm obviously
I'm just reading sort of a tagline for
each one of these and each one of these
has one of these stories that you know
you've already given a couple examples
that's what this book is so you can
really start to understand these things
from a couple different perspectives you
get the QR code for the Jujitsu kind of
combat perspective then you'll get sort
of an explanation of what the principle
is and you do give a brief
uh verbiage about the Jiu Jitsu
Principle as well and then you get into
some of these stories that reveal and
explain the principle really clearly
number 26 the ratchet principle
believing that small persistent
advancements will add up to significant
gains over time
the boons the buoyancy principle
leveraging the predictability of human
behavior to build your allies and break
your enemies this one's interesting the
fact that people want to get up like
this is like an interesting principle in
Jiu Jitsu people want to get back up so
you kind of know what they're going to
do very predictable and the less
training they have the more predictable
they become and that can be used to your
advantage in a massive way when you just
know how humans behave in the life and
business application we had a situation
where we were running a beautiful
business with uh tons of students who
are having a great time and phones
started disappearing from the locker
room cell phones smartphones and one
time it happened oh that's interesting a
second one happened a week later I'm
like holy cow
this is now becoming a pattern
a third phone goes missing on a Saturday
morning the third phone was the phone of
Billy graziadi who is a biohazard The
Biohazard lead singer stud amazing guy
black belt Billy yeah yeah so Billy's
phone was the third phone missing
so what I did is when you're in Brooklyn
you best watch your back
don't steal Billy's phone dude so when
Billy came and my phone's missing so
what had been happening is when your
first phone is gone I look at a roster
of 85 students in a class and I'm like
it could be any one of them who went to
the bathroom
the second phone is gone
I'm like all right let me
cross-reference the the people who
attended both those classes when a third
phone was gone there was only one name
on all three lists
17 16 or 17 year old boy named Daniel
so that Saturday Billy's the hand on my
phone is gone I said bro I looked at the
roster I said I got you I called the Dad
I got the number from the emergency
contact information I said hey you know
Mr Andrade I want to come over and say
hi I need to talk about something what's
going on I go to the house
Daniel's there the mom is there the
little sister is there and Daniel's
older brother who's like 23 24 you know
and we all sit at the dinner table
and I say guys so we have a situation
and um some phones have gone missing
at Gracie University and we think that
you know Daniel is the one who took
possession of them
no no no no no no no no Daniel Daniel
did you no I didn't I don't know what
you're talking about huh I said well
we need to find those phones
and
I'm certain
that you're the one who took him
so
we need to we either need to find those
phones or you're never going to train at
Grace University again
silence
got up walked away
well interestingly before he walked away
his brother said when he was denying it
initially his brother said Henner I know
older brother I know my brother he
didn't take the phone so like his
brother's denial got doubled down by the
older brother so they were like backing
each other train too no so we didn't
have that relationship the older brother
was just you know a little stud and he
says Henry if he says he didn't take it
he didn't take it I said bro I respect
the brotherliness
but he took the phones
but I appreciate the support you're
giving him
I said we either find those phones or
you never train with us again
he stood up he walked away
and came back with the phone
and their parents were like this oh
so embarrassed right like they are like
so embarrassed
and I said I appreciate you being honest
Daniel and bringing this back
I said
is this all you have
and then I said he said no got up and
went and got the other one
and then I said Daniel
what about the rest
he said that at first he said there's
only two I say Daniel
whether another one or another two after
these two
he said two
so now we know the answer it's one more
even though he was denying the third one
a big time
and then he said yeah I sold the other
one already
I said okay
so here's the situation we have
the bigger problem than the phones being
lost is the
disastrous effect this had on the
culture of the school where there's
nothing but trust from the locker room
to the arm bars trust is the core value
amongst all students and teachers here
and you broke that
I said so
we only have two options
you either return the phones pay for
them and never train again or you have
to help me repair what was taken
in the form of trust
and you have to do it with your peers
from whom you stole
and dad said
Hannah do you think they're going to
hurt him
I said no
they're not going to hurt him I'll be
there
it's going to be fine
I said you guys can think about it
Monday night is class at 6 30.
if you're there we do the talk
okay I will let you know like very tense
boom Monday morning comes Monday
afternoon the dad texts me we're coming
to class they show up
Daniel gets up in front of everyone
8 500 guys
and says you guys I'm sorry but I stole
phones from the locker room
I shouldn't have done it
and it was a violation of trust
and I love this school Henry has been
nothing but good to me he don't
I love training with you guys and I hope
I can still train with you guys
bro
[Music]
I said you guys if you'll have him back
I said to everyone if you'll have him
back I'll have him back
and they all
I said all right there you go after
class the guys he stole from and others
come up hey bro that was really cool you
did that it's all good
and man no Billy the other guys hey bro
don't worry about it man we all made
mistakes for sure it's all good it's all
good it's all good
the guy never stole again and continued
training and and he is in the book they
interview him for the book I might have
put my my co-author Paul interviewed a
bunch of other people to bring in other
stories and he interviewed Daniel and
said yeah how have you been bro that was
I was mixed up with the wrong people
doing the wrong things needing money for
the wrong reasons cellophone for 500
bucks get the cash
terrible idea I never stole again after
that and the fact that Henner brought me
back in and let me do that and let me
make it right I was very scared but man
it changed my life and I'm so grateful
for that this is the buoyancy principle
because predictability of human behavior
was what allowed me to catch him or
after the first phone I could have blown
up and trying to do X Y or Z but instead
I was patient right and let basically it
play out and after three phones and
cross-referencing those rosters we got
him we got that rear naked joke and then
it turns out it was just a major life
lesson that ultimately benefited him in
the long run which I'm grateful for yeah
uh
28 the head control principle
identifying the primary source of
influence in an organization and
targeting your efforts accordingly
number 29 the redirection principle
using unfavorable circumstances to
create favorable outcomes
Chapter 30 or number 30. the mobility
principle accepting accepting the things
you cannot change while having the
courage to change the things you can
isn't that an AAA saying I think so I
think it is an AAA saying alcohol looks
Anonymous the courage to accept that I
think it is yeah I've never been to that
group or discussion but I've heard it
just in passing and I'm like that's
because in Jiu Jitsu right how often are
we stuck in a position where the
opponent is immovable we move ourselves
right and that's something so heavily
reinforced every day that yo it's all
good this doesn't move I can move
relative to it and I can still make my
Effectiveness as a result of that
and talking about it in life and
business once you realize that something
is the way it is and it's going to be
the way it is guess what you have two
options
move relative to it or keep butting
heads with it and and reduce your
Effectiveness that way so
um in this chapter I talk about the need
for me to adapt to the the state kind of
mandate surrounding law enforcement and
my resistance initially for all the
reasons I thought were right but no when
you get in and you speak the language
and you become part of this law
enforcement kind of state regulating
process you can accomplish so much more
so I I yielded to the state's
requirements in many ways and as a
result the impact has been exponential
on the other side of that so I just wish
I was more mobile sooner yield sooner to
the reality of things than here we are
yep uh 31
the center line principle
owning your life by setting boundaries
wherever they're needed
absolutely and then the last and final
of the principles
the Grand Master principle living with
the confidence of a black belt while
learning with the humility of a white
belt and in that chapter you refer to
your grandfather who
the ultimate white belt the ultimate
black belt and the ultimate Wipeout
there you go the ultimate Guy created it
but still has and goes through life with
an open mind and still learning his
whole life to the end 95 and this guy's
like yo Henry let me show you this new
detail I'm like what are you doing
he's humble always open to Improvement
in Opportunities and I think that we all
get to a point of Effectiveness in our
fields and in our crafts and in our
martial arts and in our businesses that
we think we know you know and this is
just a constant reminder of
you know using the principles to
constantly evolve in every way possible
and I just as we were kind of
documenting these principles we got to
the end and I had 31 principles
documented and I'm like 31 is not a good
number to end on I swear this is exactly
what happened I was in the shower and
I'm like
do you end a book well not a book but
even the original 32 the 32 principles
video course that was intended to share
these with the world I'm like all right
we got 31 solid principles that are
micro principles and all very actionable
in Jiu Jitsu
um long before the book was contemplated
we need a 30-second principle 8 times 4
is 32
I might but it can't just be another
principle it has to be one principle
that encapsulates all the principles and
their continuous and constant deployment
in every aspect of our or in this case
in jujitsu
essentially always using the principles
to constantly refine your deployment of
the principles in every single way
and I thought yes that's what it is it's
the everything principle and that we had
to just pay homage
and call it the Grand Master principle
because that's what he embodied he had
all these he didn't label them all like
we did but he embodied all of them his
entire life and we benefit today from
the amazing art of jujitsu because of
his constant and never-ending deployment
of these principles to evolve the art
that we all now love so much yeah you're
actually in in the book you're
um
there's a pretty interesting point you
say he didn't have a teacher for much of
his life so he had to be his own teacher
and he was able to do this because he
embodied all the core principles of the
yard even though he hadn't named them
even though he'd helped to invent the
art of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Elio never
stopped seeking knowledge he never
believed that he knew it all or that he
was bigger than the art itself
those types of fonts never crossed his
mind instead he was constantly trying to
evolve the techniques to accommodate his
frail Physique in approaching larger
stronger opponents my grandfather was
driven by an unyielding pursuit of
efficiency the Apex principle of the art
and the staple of every core principle
we've explored
and then you say this these principles
are now yours to explore experiment with
modify and use to create Solutions or
techniques to overcome the obstacles and
adversities that inevitably await you
down the road please give yourself the
permission
to be your own teacher so that you may
evolve into the Grand Master of your own
life
you know at the end of the day I feel
like you know the computer is only as
good as the operating system right and
we all have an operating system that is
a result of our upbringing right all of
your history all of your past is who you
are today same is for you same as for me
and the way I look at it is that there
are many people out there who are not
particularly thrilled about their
operating system about how they react
and how they respond to adversity right
personal and professional
and my thought was I'm very proud of the
operating system that I have it took a
long time to develop this operating
system I'm very I'm very proud of How
It's applied not just in Jiu Jitsu but
in every aspect of my life and now that
I've
observed and kind of cataloged how these
principles have applied in so many areas
of my life I thought man it would be
cool if
people around the world who have if you
do jujitsu
it's very likely that you aren't even
aware the extent to which these
principles can improve your personal and
professional life outside of the
training on the mats right so there's
one population where I felt like they
just need to be told and given
permission to apply Jiu Jitsu to
everything that's the people who do Jiu
Jitsu then there's the people who don't
do Jiu Jitsu
who are not particularly proud of their
operating systems and their way of
dealing with adversity
and since we deal with adversity every
minute of every day in Jiu Jitsu and we
develop very healthy
um you know operating systems as it
pertains to dealing with adversity I
would like to give my operating system
to anyone who who wants to improve
theirs particularly as it pertains to
adversity and that is what the kind of
certainly ambitious attempt of this book
is hey you don't do Jiu Jitsu but guess
what let me show you some videos in
every chapter where you'll understand
what it is so you're absolutely clear on
the physical application and then let me
explain the personal and professional
application and if this type of you know
fluid and and and effective
um efficient way of living and dealing
with adversity is sounds intriguing to
you and it sounds
um attractive to you then adopted as
your own it's here read about it learn
about it and become about it and like I
said in the beginning I think that
people who will read this book will if
they were on the fence of like should I
try Jujitsu or should I not by the time
they read this they're going to go holy
cow like this isn't even about fighting
right like we always talk about it
honestly when's the last time you had a
threat of a real street fight it's very
rare especially because of our
de-escalation and our confidence and our
boundary setting capabilities that is of
course
emboldened by our techniques and our
skill sets but let's be honest we're not
worried about a fight right like we're
capable we're ready something happens
even if it's someone else we go put out
the fire if we need to we're very proud
of that ability and to do so without
hurting someone is amazingly humanizing
and and allows us to be the
compassionate Souls that we are in a
violent physical altercation but for
most people it's not even about the
fight it really is people start Jiu
Jitsu for self-defense but they stay
with Jiu Jitsu because it makes them
better people and everyone knows that
but no one has really ever explained
exactly how and why that is and once I
identified that for myself and the
direct and
um you know the explicit ways in which
the Jujitsu principles I've applied in
life and business I went okay I think
that some people can benefit from this
um and if they end up trying a class at
the end of all of this they find a local
school and go give it a shot I hope it's
a good school I hope they take care of
them I hope they don't break them on the
first day you know that's my Only Hope
in all this I'm like I'm gonna attract
some people to jiu jitsu I can't promise
that the school you go to is gonna do
things in a safe and structured and a
contextually relevant way
but my hope is that um you know through
more educating and discussions like this
Jiu Jitsu schools around the world also
make improvements right they also make
changes that ultimately protect the
beginners because the guy who's had a
school for 17 years and has 112 students
I don't think he wants that I think he
wants to have 500 600 700 students
because besides the financial benefit of
having a successful growing business
where you actually retain your students
there's also a community service
component to this which is imagine the
level of fulfillment that we feel by
servicing the community in such a
profound and vast way in terms of just
the sheer numbers of people that we're
impacting whether it's children women or
men
so for all those reasons I hope that
people continue to in the wild wild west
that is Brazilian Jiu Jitsu right now I
hope that people
you know really try to take the steps
that we took so many years ago to
improve that student experience so that
Jiu Jitsu as popular as it is
is more sustainable and is more
retentive of these students who are
giving it a chance than it historically
has been
yeah and I think it has improved a lot
um and I it just so if you're out there
listening like well it almost sounds
scary what you're saying right like I
don't want to go there's all these
schools most schools are good most
schools you go into and you should be
able to tell pretty quickly you should
get treated well you should get welcomed
you should get taught you shouldn't get
beat up you should you should feel like
your first day was pretty relaxed and
and depending on what your attitude goes
going into this now Echo and I were
talking about this uh earlier and you
know we were all talking about this
earlier when I was freaking starting Jiu
Jitsu I wanted to get roughed up I
wanted to fight people and so guess what
happened I've got I got roughed up
that's what happens when you go into
Academy with an attitude like you want
to be aggressive and you wanna you wanna
fight you're gonna you're gonna receive
that if you go in to a Jiu Jitsu Academy
because you want to learn and because
you want to expand your horizon you
should be immediately reciprocated with
that type of attitude and that's what
you should get if it's not like that you
should be able to smell it in four
minutes yes and if it's if it's not an
open accepting environment just get on
your shoes and walk out you have no
point in being there people that are
mature instructors they want to take
care of you they want you to train they
want you to be at their school they want
you to do Jiu Jitsu all we all want you
to do Jiu Jitsu it's going to make your
life better so don't be nervous go out
and try and the other thing is people
what school should I go to go try you'll
go to the schools in your area try two
or three of them try four of them if
they're there don't think that the first
school you go into is where you have to
commit you want to go on a few dates
great advice good very good advice yeah
it's a real relationship and that's what
I always say if I don't have if I have a
school there I can tell you what they're
going to teach you and I can tell you
what curriculum they're going to do and
what the safety Protocols are
doesn't mean it's the best school for
you it just means I can promise that
um if you if I don't have a school there
my advice is always this try don't do
not sign an agreement do a class and
even before doing a class I say watch a
class and if as you watch you cannot see
yourself doing that thing or you cannot
make sense of the thing that you're
witnessing don't even do the class but
if you do it and say man I wish I would
have suited up today and did that then
the next time you do the class and then
once you do that two or three four
schools then you make your decision who
makes you feel the best who speaks about
Jiu Jitsu in a context that makes sense
to you and to your objectives because
some want competition from day one some
want Fitness the vast majority wants
self-defense at least in the beginning
to feel safer in their own skin right
who don't have that confidence to
protect themselves and their family and
if they don't speak to those needs and
wants that you have when you show up
don't expect it to change in 60 days or
six years it they are that school's
identity is what you see on day one so
be very careful what you trust because
if they say yeah you're going to learn
those things later you're going to learn
self-defense and down the line where
when do we learn how to block a punch
between two standing people in a violent
verbal altercation that turns physical
where is that encounter discussed and if
they can't give you a straight answer on
Tuesday at 7 30 PM we're going to talk
about that be careful because they're
making promises that they can't keep and
then when you sign that year agreement
now you're financially stuck which I've
seen so many of do gotcha gotcha for the
year so just be careful what you sign
yeah
but
GO train Jiu Jitsu people go train Jiu
Jitsu uh
does it get us up to speed I think we
covered
we covered your some of your activities
I think we're we're doing pretty good
tell me about this renergie pink Mist
the energy
well it seemed to have worked today yeah
I kept me fired up this whole time and
um I didn't know I needed this in my
life yeah well there's you know it's
good for you it's truly good for you
um it's got no sugar in it it's
sweetened with monk fruit which is a
beautiful thing for you it doesn't have
a ton of caffeine in it it's got 95
milligrams caffeine it's all good man
there's no no artificial flavors it's in
fact we went to the length of instead of
putting chemicals in it to keep its
shelf life we pasteurized it so it just
gets heated up to kill whatever might be
in there to keep itself life good so we
went as as pure as we could possibly go
congratulations that's what we're doing
yeah
um
where can people find you we got quick
flip we got sleeper hold we got
gracieuniversity.com yeah that's sort of
the Hub right that's the Hub yeah
graceuniversity.com for all Jiu Jitsu
men women children law enforcement
Gracie survival tactics all the course
dates all the opportunities are there
all the online courses and what I'll say
to anybody out there who
right they've heard enough of your
podcasts enough recommendation to try
Jujitsu they're still not showing up at
a school because they're scared like we
talked about in the beginning they don't
believe they can do it my recommendation
is go to gracieuniversity.com watch two
three four free lessons and if you can't
immediately say wow that not only makes
sense what they're saying I could see
myself doing that
um then then you didn't pay anything so
it's all good it was free but if you see
it and you go man I totally see myself
doing this go find a school whether it's
one of ours or any school start learning
Jiu Jitsu and if there's no school that
you like start a Gracie garage or find
one near you or just find a person
online and just start practicing going
through these techniques learning these
skills the way I look at it and the way
it's kind of communicated in the Gracie
family is you need to learn how to you
know read and write
you need to learn how to ride a bike can
you learn how to swim in the ocean and
you learn how to fight like when you're
a kid in this family there's some basic
skills you have to learn and back in the
day it was horse riding too not so much
anymore but the point is you just have
to know some things as a human being and
the fact that so many parents allow
their kids to grow up in a world where
they teach them how to swim in a pool
but they never teach them how to swim in
a fight
and you can drown in a street fight in a
bullying encounter as quickly and
severely as you could in a pool
so these are skills that are real that
everyone should have growing up
um and the fact that some parents let
their unleash their kids on the world
without the ability to protect what's
theirs even if that means their space
right they're they're their state of
mind their physical possessions when
someone's going to take something from
you you should be able to say no you're
not going to take this and if you
attempt it's going to be a bad day for
you simple conversation but you can't
say that unless you can back it up
and you do so with the highest level of
love and compassion then you get the
people who say you've all heard this I'm
a lover not a fighter nah Jocko I'm not
going to come to the studio I don't want
to legit I'm a lover not a fighter no
you don't understand all the biggest
lovers are on the mats right now because
if you get into a fight let's say
without Jiu Jitsu either one of you
studs with your athleticism how much of
a liability are you to yourself and to
the person that you fight you're an
absolute atomic bomb of liability
because you're going to over aggress
like any police officer who's untrained
you're going to go absolutely violent on
this guy punch his face into the
pavement brutalize his skull break your
hand everyone goes to the hospital and
you get a lawsuit so if that's what
lovers do then I don't want to be a
lover instead if you learn Jiu Jitsu no
no no you can attack me I'm not going to
hurt you I'm going to tie you up he
don't go so far to say Hannah if I get
into a street fight it shouldn't be
called a fight it's the wrong
classification because there aren't two
violent people trying to hurt each other
there's one aggressor whose mental case
and the other person is physically
de-escalating that encounter that's what
my fight should be called the physical
demonstration of de-escalation and
that's what it actually is so when you
think of it that way the biggest lovers
should learn Jujitsu so if you're a
lover not a fighter you need to learn
Jiu Jitsu because if not you're the
biggest liability to yourself so
graceuniversity.com quickflipapparel.com
for quick flips are great but any
organizations any anyone out there who
wants to do quickflips for the whole
team we're happy to do that we can
sample one show it to the team see if
you guys like it and then sleeper hold
is um travel pillows right
sleeperhole.com it's if you travel on
our semi-regular basis for work and you
suffer from bobblehead in the flight
this is the best thing you're going to
ever have in your life I sleep for two
and a half hours straight on commercial
flights economy just strap in
full head support I'm gone and then
there's optional patches you can put on
the forehead one says do not disturb one
says Wake for food and one says sorry
for snoring so while I'm gone the flight
attendant always knows the appropriate
method of interaction based on my
request versus hey do you want to eat
right now don't wake me up I just taught
an eight-hour seminar I'm trying to
sleep I don't need your airplane food
right now but she doesn't know that
she's trying to be polite so
um anyways so that's what's going down
and then of course on social media at
Henry Gracie everywhere and
um stoked yeah thank you guys and you
have at Gracie University HQ you got
your YouTube channel don't forget about
that YouTube
yeah that's the one that started it all
and like those breakdowns really are the
driver of traffic and awareness to
everything else that we're doing in Jiu
Jitsu and one day it was like Hey
Valente called me he's like Henry Dan
Hardy GSP
arm bar why didn't the arm break people
don't know why Dan Hardy's arm wasn't
broken when GSP caught him you guys
should do a breakdown gee said and
explain that I'm like cool easy work
like it was called to Gracie breakdown
and we did one got like I don't know 10
20 30 000 views the next one I think was
Fedor and um and and for Doom a massive
triangle win we did that one on a Sunday
but I was there you went to the fight
yeah I was there dude that was the best
I did that breakdown on a Sunday by
Wednesday it has you know three 400 000
views I'm like people like this they
like understanding what the beauty of
Jiu Jitsu application in MMA where it's
kind of chaotic but they can understand
and dissect and then send them to the
website at the end of that
gracieuniversity.com if you want to
learn what we just explained and it just
became that funnel for us and uh and now
it's what people recognize hey I love
the breakdowns TSA agent at the airport
like yo I've been loving the breakdowns
I'm like oh do you train he's like nah I
just love the breakdown all right cool
man like do a class one day gu online go
check it out right on
um Echo Charles any questions well yes
speaking of breakdowns right remember
the OG breakdown how to tie your belt
yeah see that was the OG breakdown how
to tie your Jiu Jitsu the best one in
Hollywood oh yeah
Hollywood super lock classic the
original they're they're actually what
was the original one called it was like
the I think it's called the basics yeah
something simple like that it was like
classic and then uh and then the
Hollywood and then the super lock and I
just yeah people loved it you know why
they call it Hollywood or you think he
can guess it's actually one of the best
breakdowns there is to be honest with
you it's really good it's one of the ogs
[Music]
yeah it's old school how to Tire jiu
jitsu belt and um and then there's that
one and then there's the pant tying
video where the GI pants yeah some
people don't know bro people people when
they tie the pants in a weird way and it
kind of gets all bunched up and they
don't know to pull the strings laterally
right they don't do this they just tie
it up and it's all bunched up and the
pants start to fall off
so I created a video where I explained
the pant time and people love those and
um yeah you have a few breakdowns with
that kind of stuff because you have the
one where this one the string comes out
of the pants
yeah it's pretty yes very Innovative we
were just making random videos people
just gravitated and just before you know
it and then you do a Conor McGregor
Habib nurmaga Madoff breakdown and gets
you know two million views overnight
because people want to know like what
happened and they see and so we just
kind of and we talk about the momentum
principle in the book and how that led
to that then we started doing street
fight breakdowns and then it went one
step further where there's a bullying
incident in Indiana and a kid gets beat
up in the locker Bay at his school we
see the video and then I was just like
yo I'm gonna reach out you're like yo
Gracie breakdown well yeah so in that
case you got to be sensitive right so in
that case I said wait a minute this is
crazy normally I would just explain what
he could have done it but I'm like hold
on let's go one step further and then
Austin McDaniel that was like a critical
moment we reached out to the family and
said hey we want to do this the mom
called me back like six months later hey
we we saw you tried to reach out to our
attorney that you want to train this way
and the other I said listen this is what
we do your son Austin uh sorry that
happened we want to fly you the mom the
dad and the son all of you guys to
California to train him for a week
please let me do this we brought Austin
to California 12 year old just
overweight like just this big kind of
like 12 year old kid who just got
annihilated at school and I got him in
there
train him for a week day one you see the
progression we filmed the whole thing
and we did this progression
and by the last day this kid is a
different human being like power push
verbal assertiveness with me and heat on
training several hours every day boot
camped him and then we sent him back and
we posted that video three four five
million views of different platforms and
now people are like this is amazing and
then basically because we did that every
bowling video that goes online they're
sending it to us and then every six
months to a year we're recruiting
another kid to come out and we're doing
these Transformations we're recording it
and this is just showing parents that
this exists out there because bullying
the challenge is if you don't take steps
to right to address the challenges that
these kids are facing it's like a
balloon if kids getting harassed every
day verbal physical psychological a
cyber if they're getting harassed it's
like air being injected into a balloon
indefinitely and continuously over time
for that same child and unless they
build their confidence and start to
deflate that balloon and like get back
to a normal state it just keeps going
and then eventually it pops we don't
know when we don't know where we don't
know what that looks like and every kid
is different sometimes the pop is a
Columbine
sometimes the pop is a suicide
sometimes the pop is any range between
those two extremes but almost always
what do you see it's tied back to
incessant bullying that was unchecked
and uncommunicated and they leave a note
and now you know my gosh this is why he
was doing this these kids were making
fun of him he didn't have an outlet so
for me every time I see those the same
way when I see a cop video go viral for
excessive force all I'm thinking is
in many cases poor cop they didn't get
the training that they needed they're a
victim as much as they are the the
culprit here in a in a youth suicide or
a school shooting of a kid I'm always
like holy ago I wish I would have had
this kid for a week two weeks three
weeks so I make these videos hoping that
other parents go man my kid's getting
bullied let's open up the discussion get
them the training that they need and all
of this is momentum from the UFC and
from awareness about MMA and the Gracie
breakdown and then using that as much as
we can for good doing these breakdowns
changing lives with these Jiu Jitsu
Transformations so that people on the
outside go all right you know it's one
thing to talk about Jiu Jitsu another
for people to see problem transformation
new human being this guy Austin that was
like eight to ten years ago Austin went
back never had a problem with that bully
or any other bully again graduated high
school enlisted in the Marines
immediately after shredded up full stud
went to the Marines 100 good to go I
think he's now transitioning to the Army
or another military branch and he's
fully good to go and they interview him
for the book and his dad as well about
the reservations they had in coming to
California and Austin where he's at now
and just the pivotal role that played
he's just like yo that was the beginning
of the rest of my life was to be told
that I can look at someone and say don't
take one more step I didn't know that no
one taught me that
so you know there's certain skills that
we expect people and kids in the world
to know but unless they're taught unless
it's talked about it's largely you know
unknown to the people who need it most
so you guys do great work and just
constantly drawing attention to it
um and I benefit the number of people
who've shown up and said yo I heard
Jocko and I wanted to try Jiu Jitsu just
from some random discussion you guys
have had uh has been awesome and I
always wanted to get here to say thank
you guys for being just such ambassadors
and pushing it
um you know with the with the video here
and not being able to put the mask down
and actually show I mean of course you
practicing it people love seeing those
videos as well but thank you amen any
other questions Echo yeah your dad did
uh Marshall martial arts Consulting for
like movies right like Lethal Weapon one
and triangle oh yeah Gary if you see in
the Harry busy and the uh Mel Gibson
triangle in the rain dude are the most
classic yeah he did some he got here was
working he was cleaning houses for some
people and one of the people there was a
producer of movies and oh you do Jiu
Jitsu and this and that and then he's
teaching of the garage at the same time
okay come choreograph this scene he met
the director and boom boom boom and he
was in Lethal Weapon 4 as one of the bad
guys in Renee so I had to go watch that
scene in in preparation for this uh
podcast both those scenes yeah I forgot
about I forgot that was your dad in the
Rene Russo getting tossed in the glass
yeah she gets smashed in the garage
succeed Mel Gibson is like all like just
so happy watching his girlfriend beat
everybody up it's kind of like you and
you're hearing about your your wife like
uh choking dudes out it was a great
scene and I remember that particular
scene when he was filming he's like yo
this is the alligator pad I think it's
the name they called it which is what he
wears on his body underneath his shirt
to get slammed in the glass and it was
like this really thin but very durable
thing and I'm like oh that's bad I was
like I don't know 12 13 14 and I'm like
dude you're gonna be in a movie that's
cool
awesome Hannah any closing thoughts No I
um just what an honor and uh thank you
guys for helping us increase the
awareness about not just Jiu Jitsu but
the Life Application of it and um
I appreciate you guys awesome man uh
thanks for joining us thanks to you and
thanks to your family for bringing Jiu
Jitsu to America for bringing Jujitsu
around the globe thanks for all that you
do to continue to you know spread the
sport the martial art
and and the philosophies of Jiu Jitsu
around the world it is much appreciated
thank you thank you Rose
and with that Henry Gracie has left the
building
that we could have done multiple
podcasts but still it's still four hours
or something like that right yeah yeah
fully but even going deeper into the
principles could have been kind of cool
actually the forking one okay it was a
Twist on it but that's a chess technique
as well it's called forking and it's
just what how you explained it before
his actual principle his actual
principle is a win-win which is it's a
different take on it but forking is like
the Jujitsu chess version where it says
version is triangle arm lock yeah like
they have to make a decision and ever
any decision they make yeah is is the
outcome that you want you know so chess
yeah you basically threatened two people
with one guy and then when this guy
moves you just take the other one kind
of a thing
see I know that yeah well awesome
awesome discussion super super cool
um
and we're doing Jiu Jitsu by the way yes
we should be doing Jiu Jitsu hey if you
weren't convinced to do Jiu Jitsu yet
yeah go on yeah you have to get there
when you get there
you're gonna need some fuel you're gonna
need Jocko fuel you're gonna need to
rehydrate you want to get Jocko hydrate
it's so good to go it is such a win the
Jocko hydrate and also similar
greens you know Jocko Greens Greens do
not have to taste like dirt and uh mowed
grass shaking in the mixer they don't
need to taste like that they can taste
like choco greens what's funny is you
kind of say it kind of with this joking
tone no but that is literally the
standard for greens you know they'll put
the greens in there and hopefully maybe
put up I don't know pineapple or apple
you know some in there make it taste
good because it doesn't taste good I
know this because my mom's is a greens
person and even growing up she had the
greens and I was like I have no idea how
you eat this kind of stuff or put this
in a smoothie or whatever you whatever
you're doing
um and so I know but yeah your greens
actually taste good your mom likes my
greens yes she did yeah she totally
approved them see the whole gig there
you go if they're good with echo's Mom
yep you know they're good she's been
she's been drinking greens forever now
she knows the best kind of green so you
know uh so yeah chocolatefuel.com get
greens get hydrate get the milk
get the milk powder get the joint
Warfare get the Supergirl you're
probably gonna want some you start
training the Jitsu you want that joint
Warfare
bro I actually I meant to tell you and
it's not about that it's about Cold War
so my
um keep the story short so my wife my
lovely wife she was she was going on
like a little girl's trip in town she is
sure she's currently on it right now
staycation staycation-ish but it was
some girls that came in and one of them
is let's say for lack of a whole long
story and explanation she's immune
compromise so she was like hey
I kind of feel a sickness coming on
right now my wife is saying this so I
can't be going down to this hangout for
a week or however long
sick because you know for all these like
very important reasons so she's like oh
just give me the Cold War she's so she
she did her own protocol two two and two
so two in the morning two for lunch and
two at dinner right and she was like Hey
I am for real getting sick like you know
that's a game that's a lot of cold war
going on like that's a fixable frontal
assault yeah sickness you know that's it
but that's what she did so I was like
yeah all right I mean good luck you know
and that's your staycation so I'm like
you know good luck and boom knocked it
out nothing she was getting sick not
sick currently on the staycation right
now with her immunocompromised friend
right now yeah that's what I'm talking
about it counts uh that's that's cold
war by the way hey you can get this
stuff you can get a jockoffuel.com you
can get a subscription on geography.com
to this stuff get a subscription to like
joint Warfare get a subscription krill
oil
get a subscription to Greens those are
things that you're gonna want to take
every single day
um so anyways check that out Dr phil.com
you can save a little bit when you do
that subscription as well that way
you're getting hooked up
if you want to buy it in a store go to
Vitamin Shop go to Wawa look in the
bottom right and Wawa
go to Vitamin Shop go to GNC military
commissaries a fees Hannaford Dash doors
Wakefern ShopRite HEB
thank you Texas thank you HEB you guys
are crushing
will you go in there and support it pays
off we appreciate it
that allows them to bring even more
product in allows us to get into more
stores so thank you same thing with
Meyer up in the midwest Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields and by the way
small we're just out of CrossFit at the
CrossFit Games
so many people came by and that owned
CrossFit gyms
they want they're going to sell they're
going to sell Jocko fuel in their
CrossFit gyms
Jiu Jitsu gyms same thing
why not help out the people that are
coming to your school or come to your
gym if you want to sell our stuff in
your gym go to JF sales at
jockoffool.com
and you can sell it set up a wholesale
account oh yeah we'll hook you up but
we're making the clean stuff we're
making the good stuff it'll help you in
everything that you do jocklefuel.com
also origin USA
when you do Jiu Jitsu you're going to
need a ghee yep
I mean look
there are other Gees you can get it is a
thing that you could do wouldn't be a
good move though no it would be not it'd
be a it'd be against the principles of
Jiu Jitsu beginning a secondary a
tertiary just like a bad key don't do
that
get an origin ghee origin USA origin UA
usa.com also
you can't go to a club in a ghee
technically once again you could do it
be breaking some principles yeah some
legit principles don't do it instead get
a pair of origin jeans made in America
get an origin t-shirt made in America
get an origin hoodie made in America
that's what we're doing
all made in America we got the hunt gear
we got the the RTX gear which is like
your workout clothes we got what you
need all made in America
bringing manufacturing back to America
not supporting slave labor
that's not what we're doing here so
check it out there you go
um
that's what we're doing origin USA
originusa.com it's true also Jaco has a
store called Jocko store so this one is
jockostory.com it's where you can
represent on this path Jiu Jitsu path we
got some Jiu-Jitsu stuff on there shirts
Jujitsu shirts Jujitsu rash guards on
there as well but if you just want to
generally represent discipline equals
freedom and get your you know shirts and
hats and hoodies
um also a thing called the shirt Locker
this is a subscription scenario where
you get a new shirt every month new
designs interesting designs coming out
by the way heads up and if you care you
want to check out a peek of the designs
Jocko store.com click on the top right
where it says joint Sherlock I'll give
you a little little peek on the current
design that's going on right off if you
care if you want to if you want to see
what up otherwise it can be a surprise
up to you
where you give up you give a peek before
you release the of the month like what's
this month August right
yeah it's called the August shirt or
whatever they have names to them too
which have layers and some of the
designs but on the site it says the
August shirt and you can see it doesn't
have all the whole thing it'll just show
like part you know there's a chance
let's say
this was set up in a different way sure
there's a if you were isolated if you
were just locked in this room all the
time yeah there's a chance that you
could be making these shirts thinking
that they're cool yeah and thinking that
these designs there's a chance that like
no one else was getting them if if you
didn't know that there's a chance that
could be you're like no one's getting
them let's say you were just Glock you
had no communication with the outside
world yeah right and you're just doing
what you're doing and so you're making
these shirts and you're putting these
layers in you're giving them names and
you think it's super cool yes but like
no no one else cares right that could be
happening I mean it's kind of
interesting that that's not happening
and that like people love the freaking
shirt locker but that's the situation
that you're in it's very possible you
know you're luckily you can see the the
fruits of your labor well
let's say the the fact of the whole mat
or the whole matter is is if you listen
you know and you know it'll be fun and
look or is every single person gonna get
every single design and get what's
behind it and the layers every single
one every single person
probably not
but but enough I mean it's pretty
profound how many people like at the
Jocko live so many people were
representing
and it's weird too the same thing
similar thing when I'm putting together
what I'm going to talk about at Jocko
live I have no idea what anyone's gonna
think about it yeah like I literally am
just I could go out there and it could
just people could go dude I'm they could
be walking out you know what I mean I
don't know I don't know what I'm doing
yeah you know like a comedian they do a
bunch of club shows in a small club
right and they try this joke they try
that joke they try another joke they try
them together they hone it they fix it
they add another one they do little they
do
hundreds of little eight minute little
six minute gigs and they get that
feedback and they own it all
and then they by the time they go record
one for a Netflix special oh yeah
they've got it they already know
I don't have any of that experimentation
dude I'm just rolling in hey man it's
like a trip wire or no uh what's a
balance wire what's that thing called
the tightrope tightrope I'm watching I'm
walking a high wire no net no net I
could just go out there and just
things could fall apart I'm on the big
stage so that could be happening to you
with the shirt Locker luckily it's not
luckily it just so happens that what you
make lands so nicely done
um don't forget about Primal beef
you need steak
you need steak in your life I mean you
definitely do and so we got
primalbeef.com the this is farm raised
beef
it's grass-fed and it's
finished on fruit and grain it's a
different gig do you know the whole are
you I mean how much of a
I don't know farmer I guess in this case
are you a little person like do you know
how that's gonna translate into like
Texture Intense I know now yeah yeah I
didn't know I'd never even heard of it
before yeah I've never heard of it I've
heard of course I've you heard of grain
fed grain finished you heard a grass-fed
only you heard a grass-fed grain
finished but you've never I never heard
grass fed
fruit and grain finished yeah one minute
it's good it's even like the fat like
when you look at it it has like a
different color to it it's it's freaking
amazing yeah it and that's a fun little
not fun little but that's a crazy how
it's so procedural like that where like
you know how like eggs are like that too
where like certain kind of eggs are
super like orange you know because of
how they're raised and all this and like
um has an impact yeah like or if you if
you cook uh I don't know fish or steak
or beef on like the grill but you burn a
certain kind of wood good you know it's
going to taste different you know like
all that kind of stuff that's
interesting well Sean glass
teammate from the team at the herbs who
also has five kids by the way so you
know he we know he needs to feed the
kids for good food sure but he put He
gave a little recipe on the gram and
it's like salt pepper
butter in the pan in the in the cast
iron pan
two minutes aside Flip Flip Flip eight
minutes so you go two sides two two
minutes first three minutes yep I just
did this last night yeah
freaking legit so my I actually look am
I a chef
am I jack Arnold no
no you know this about me I'm only me I
got a feeling there's a huge butt coming
for those of you that don't know we've
never talked about this but we Echo and
I have a running joke Echo will make a
huge disclaimer and then say butt blah
blah blah he's gonna say what he's gonna
say so you're not a chef you're not a
Cattleman you're not really pretty much
anything my I'm not a mind reader you
have no reason to say what you're about
to say but you're gonna say it anyways
okay so go ahead you're not a chef but I
do
the steak that I cook most of the time
is pretty good like restaurant quality
you're better than me you think no
better than a restaurant oh better than
the restaurant okay okay yeah yeah so
it's tough to and now with the Primal
beef it's tough the restaurants can't
compete with it with the grain and fruit
fish I wonder actually go on there but
so I will say I have a protocol it's
it's two and a half two and a half but
it's only on a certain heat I don't know
the temperature of the heat I just know
eyeball it you know and it works but
that's interesting I might do the two
and two and two and two I recommend it
yeah I recommend it so there you go uh
primalbeef.com go on there get yourself
some steak some beef let's go get strong
also subscribe to this podcast also
subscribe to Jocko underground also
subscribe to our YouTube channels
Jocko podcast Channel origin USA channel
Jaco Food Channel also psychological
warfare also flipsidecampus.com Dakota
Meyer making cool stuff to hang on your
wall books 32 principles you know the
deal order this book Henry Gracie
really cool read really good information
and really good principles final span
leadership strategy you know all the
books I've written the way the warrior
kid books by the way all the bullying
stuff that we talked about today that's
in the book
it's in the books different types of
bullies as a matter of fact are covered
in these books
so way of the warrior kid one two three
four five
get them all
and also we have a leadership
consultancy
it's called Echelon front go to
echelonfront.com if you need help inside
your organization with leadership that's
what we do we have a bunch of Live
Events as well our next event is in
Dallas it's sold out the one after that
is in San Diego if you want to come out
to come and get it
um that's called the muster we have the
FTX we have Council we have Battlefield
all kinds of stuff going on we have a
women's assembly our chief operating
officer
Jamie Cochran she's running an event for
women September 14th through the 16th in
Phoenix Arizona anything you want to do
with that epsonfront.com we also have an
online Training Academy everything that
I said today
talking about you oh you can learn
online like we learned this at Echelon
front that we could teach
through an academy through an online
Academy so we have an entire series of
courses
that you can go through you can learn we
have live sessions we interact go to
extreme ownership.com and you know Jiu
Jitsu is like Jiu Jitsu is like a magic
trick for fighting
what we talk about at extreme
ownership.com this is a magic trip magic
tricks Maneuvers techniques for
leadership and life go on there and
learn about them
and if you want to help service members
active and retire you want to help their
families gold star families check out
Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
America's Mighty Warriors dot org and
also don't forget about Micah think up
there in the mountains
currently doing jiu jitsu
on a mountain lion
and winning by the way Heroes and horses
dot org Micah takes people veterans up
into the hills so that they can find
themselves if you want to connect with
us on the interwebs for Henry Gracie go
to gracieuniversity.com
Instagram at
gracieuniversityhq YouTube Gracie
breakdown Facebook Gracie University
Henner he's also on Instagram and
Twitter he's at Henner Gracie and of
course Echo is that Echo Charles I am at
Jocko link just watch out for the dang
algorithm
because it is a sneaky Jiu Jitsu
practitioner and it will choke you out
and waste a bunch of your time and take
a bunch of your money so watch out for
it thanks again 200 Gracie for coming
out here to share his experiences and
Lessons Learned thanks to the Gracie
family and all the Jiu Jitsu
practitioners around the world
out there learning and sharing the
gentle art
also thanks to our people in uniform in
the Army Navy Air Force Marines Coast
Guard who protect Freedom around the
world so we can live in peace same thing
goes to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
you all protect us here at home and we
are thankful for your service as well
and we hope that you all
train Jiu Jitsu it will make you better
to everyone else out there
remember
the message from the black belt the
Grand Master
a true Grandmaster Elio Gracie you
should always be learning
you have to stay humble you have to keep
an open mind you got to try new things
and learn new maneuvers
and as the Grand Master principle says
live with the confidence of a black belt
while learning with the humility of a
white belt
that is a good call
and train some Jiu Jitsu while you're at
it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out